MORNING WELCOME TO THE ASSEMBLY
NATURAL RESOURCES TO COMMITTEE.
FOR TO START I'D LIKE TO THANK
ALL OF THE STAFF MEMBERS WHO
MADE OUR RETURN TO THE CAPITAL
HAPPENED TODAY DURING THESE
EXTRAORDINARY TIMES A
PARTICULARLY I WANT TO THANK
GOD THAT NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE STAFF WHO'S DONE AN
INCREDIBLE JOB IN THE LAST
THREE WEEKS. DOING THEIR BEST
TO REACH OUT TO ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS DESPITE THE SOCIAL
DISTANCING ISSUES. AND WORKING
WITH THE BILL'S AUTHORS AND
WITH MYSELF. THANKS TO ALL OF
YOU FOR YOUR INCREDIBLY HARD
WORK- DUE TO THE STATE HOME
ORDER WE ARE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCING HERE IN THE
CAPITAL ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITOL BUILDING. SO WE'RE ONLY
ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER
OF PEOPLE PARTICIPATE IN THE
HEARING IN PERSON. WE HAVE A
FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
WITNESSES TESTIMONY TODAY. FOR
THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WE'RE
HAVING A PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN
PERSON HEARING. IN THIS SPACE
WE CAN ONLY ACCOMMODATE TWELVE
MEMBERS A MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF
STAFF AND A LIMITED NUMBER OF
THE PUBLIC AND MEDIA. SO WE CAN
MAINTAIN SIX FEET OF SPACE AT.
THEY'RE ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL
DISTANCING PROGRAM CALLED
PROTOCOLS FOR THE PUBLIC TO
ENTER AND LEAVE THE CAPITAL.
AND FOR THOSE HERE TODAY IN THE
HEARING. IF ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC IN THE ROOM WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN A BILL. PLEASE
RAISE YOUR HAND WHEN I CALL FOR
SUPPORT FOR OPPOSITION ON THAT
BILL. AND I WILL ASK YOU TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE AT THAT
TIME. WE ALSO THE PUBLIC NOT
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE. YOU CAN
EXIT THE HEARING ROOM ONCE
YOU'RE DONE TESTIFYING OR
RETURN TO YOUR SEAT. PLEASE BE
SURE TO OBSERVE PHYSICAL
DISTANCING UPON LEAVING THE
CAPITOL INCLUDING LIMITING
ELEVATOR USED TO ONE PERSON AT
A TIME. FOR WITNESSES IN THE
VIDEO ROOM THE V. DUBBED THE W.
V. OUR WITNESSES. IN ADDITION
TO BE ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM%
INSIDE THE HEARING ROOM WE HAVE
SOME BILL WITNESSES MAKING USE.
OF ONE OF OUR WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOMS- WHICH WOULD
BE ROOM ONE TWENTY SEVEN HERE
IN THE CAPITAL THOSE WITNESSES
WILL APPEAR ON THE SCREEN SO
MEMBERS CAN WATCH THEIR
TESTIMONY LIVE FROM OUTSIDE OF
THE HEARING ROOM AND ALSO ASK
QUESTIONS OF THE WITNESS. NOW
THERE MAY BE A SLIGHT DELAY FOR
THE STREAM FROM THE WITNESS
VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOM SO
PLEASE BE PATIENT I THINK THE-
THE WORD FOR THE DAY WILL BE
PATIENTS FOR ALL OF US AS WE
GET USED TO THE SYSTEM. FOR
DIAL IN WITNESSES WE WILL ALSO
BE USING A MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGHOUT WHICH ANY
WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL.
THE CALL IN NUMBER FOR THIS
HEARING IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE
SEVEN. AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
ONE THREE ONE FIVE. FOUR TWO
ZERO TWO THAT'S. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO. YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AS WELL AS
OUR ON YOUR TV SCREEN. IF
YOU'RE CALLING IN. PLEASE DO SO
WHEN THE ATHOR OF THE BILL
YOU'RE TESTIFYING ON IS
BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE A
BILL. IF YOU ARE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE THIS INCLUDES MUTING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCAST AND YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE SOUND
DISTORTION AND I CAN'T. SAY
AGAIN HOW IMPORTANT THAT IS.
HE'S ALSO BE ADVISED IF YOU ARE
A MAIN WITNESS PROVIDING
TESTIMONY FOR OR AGAINST A
BILL. YOUR REMAIN ON A LIVE
LINE AND WILL NEED TO MEET
YOURSELF UNTIL YOU ARE CALLED
ON TO SPEAK. IF YOU'RE HAVING
ANY PROBLEMS WITH A MODERATED
PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN CALL THE
COMMITTEE DIRECTLY AT NINE ONE
SIX. ONE NINE TWO ZERO NINE
TWO. AND OUR STAFF WILL DO
THEIR BEST TO HELP YOU. I ALSO
WANT TO NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO
THE POSITION LETTER PORTAL ON
THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. THANK
YOU FOR BEARING WITH US AS WE
IMPLEMENT METHODS TO CONTINUE
TO SERVE THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. WILL ALSO BE
MINDFUL RESPECTFUL OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH CONCERNS WE ALL
FACE. WE HAVE OUR FIRST OF ALL
I WOULD LIKE TO BEFORE I GO TO
THIS- ESTABLISH A CORPSMAN TAKE
ROLE. SO IF YOU CAN PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. FRIEDMAN HERE
FRIEDMAN HERE FLORA. FLORA HERE
CHAO CHAU HERE EGGMAN EGGMAN
HERE GARCIA LOW MOAN MATHIS
YOUR MATHIS HERE MCCARTY. PEROT
YOUR TO CHECK HER. STONE STONE
HERE TO CHEER. THANK YOU WE
HAVE TWO BILLS PROPOSED FOR
CONSENT TODAY AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY SEVEN AB THIRTY ONE
SIXTY FOUR AND ONE BILL
PREVIOUSLY SET FOR HEARING THAT
HAS BEEN PULLED BY THE AUTHOR
AB NINETEEN OH SEVEN AT LEAST
SIXTEEN BILLS TO HEAR TODAY.%
I'D LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
AUTHORS OF MANY OTHER VERY
WORTHY BILLS THAT WERE REFERRED
TO COMMITTEE WHICH
CIRCUMSTANCES ARE NOT GOING TO
ALLOW US TO HEAR OUR PASSED
THIS YEAR I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THEM NEXT YEAR
WHEN WE HOPE WE HAVE MORE
CAPACITY AND RESOURCES TO
CONSIDER MORE IMPORTANT BILLS.
WITHOUT THE FIRST BILL UP TODAY
IS AB TWO NINE NINE ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MIGUEL SANTIAGO.
HEY JENNIFER. HI THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR FOR WORKING WITH US
ON THIS COMMITTEE I LEARNED
THIS- BILL HAND I THINK YOUR
STAFF AS WELL- THIS BILL
EXTENDED EIGHTY NINE HUNDRED
EXTENSION DEADLINE AND WITH
STARTING OF OUR MENTAL
STANDARDS ON ENVIRONMENTAL
LEADERSHIP DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS
A LOT THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
HELPING US TO PROPOSES- ARE THE
AMENDMENTS WHICH WOULD REDUCE
OUR VEHICLE MILES TRAVELED FROM
FIFTEEN TO TWENTY- WE WOULD
REDUCE- THE- JOINT BUDGET
COMMITTEE BROUGH OF-
INVOLVEMENT- AND WOULD ALLOW
FOR GHG- PURCHASES TO BE 50%
LOCALLY TO REDUCE OUR THOSE
EMISSIONS. AND THE REST WOULD
BE AS IS FOR ONE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND JUST- CONTINUOUS WORK
ON LIES YOU KNOW THIS IS
DEVELOPED OVER ABOUT EIGHT IN
SINCE LAST EXTENSION EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND ON OUR HOME OF THAN
THE PROCESS IS NOT ABOUT THE
APOLOGIZE AND BEING THE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR HARD WORK ON THIS
AND THE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY
VOTE FOR THE WILL ONE WITNESS
WHO ALSO MATH TESTIFIED THANK
YOU. I WOULD I. THIS AND I
WOULD ASK THEM TO STAY THEIR
NAME FIRST AND WHERE THEY ARE
CALLING FROM ALL THE WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION AND IN SUPPORT
WILL GET TO THE PRIMARY
WITNESSES AND ANYBODY WHO'S
CALLING IN WHO IS NOT AN
OFFICIAL WITNESS WILL ONLY BE
ASKED TO STATE YOUR NAME AND
YOUR POSITION WE WILL NOT TAKE
TESTIMONY WHEN WE MOVED OUT
PORTION OF THE HEARING. AND
AGAIN PLEASE DO ROOM I REMEMBER
TO PUT ALL OF YOUR OTHER
DEVICES ON MUTE MINIATURE
CORRECT CORRECT MYSELF AND SAY
THERE WERE TWO PEOPLE WHO WILL
MAKE THE STATEMENT THAT THE MY
BELIEVE I SAID ONCE ALL THE
CORRECT MYSELF ON THAT OKAY
THANK YOU FOR THE CORRECTION SO
WHENEVER THEY'RE READY
MODERATOR YOU CAN ALLOW THOSE
WITNESSES. PLEASE GO AHEAD THE-
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE- MY NAME
IS EDGAR QALAT HIM I WITH THE
MAYOR OF OUR LAW FIRM I WANT TO
THANK THE OUT AUTHORED MEAL
SANTIAGO AND- DETERMINES
SOMEONE FRIEDMAN WHO HAPPENS TO
BE MY ASSEMBLY WOMAN- FOLLOW
THAT WORK ON THIS BILL- WE
SUPPORT IT MOVING FORWARD AND
ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTION THAT THIS COMMITTEE
MAY HAVE. THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
YOUR TIME AND CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU THE NEXT WITNESS. TIM
LYNCH WITH PLATINUM ADVISORS
ALSO ON BEHALF OF MILLENNIUM
PARTNERS- IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL BE- ISSUES ARE WELL KNOWN
TO THIS COMMITTEE AND WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND
THE COMMITTEE AND THE SPEAKER'S
OFFICE FOR- FOR- GETTING A
PRODUCT. FOR THE COMMITTEE THAT
WE CAN SUPPORT. ASSEMBLYMAN
EVEN IF I MAY ADD YES. I SAY
YOUR NAME AGAIN PLEASE. OTHER
AT THE CLOUDY AND WITH WITH ME
AROUND- ONE POINT OF
CLARIFICATION I'D LIKE TO ADD-
AS LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES
CONTINUE TO WORK THROUGH FOR A
LOAD AND EMPLOYEES WORKING FROM
HOME PROJECTS ARE TAKING MUCH
LONGER TO GO THROUGH THE
PROCESS SO WE RESPECTFULLY
WOULD ASK IF THE DEADLINE COULD
BE A PERSON ADDITIONAL YEAR.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TO TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. THANK YOU. LET'S
MOVE NOW TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. MODERATE IF YOU CAN
PLEASE KEEP UP THE WITNESSES
AND IN OPPOSITION. IN LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND WE DO
HAVE A FEW PEOPLE QUEUING UP TO
WILL GIVE THEM JUST A MOMENT.
LINE SIXTY EIGHT LET IT GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS TIFFANY AND I'M WITH
THE CALIFORNIA BY MIDDLE JUST
THE LINE. HAD A MEMBERS LIKE TO
RESPECTFULLY SHARE CONCERNS
REGARDING AB TWENTY NINETY ONE
WHILE WE APPRECIATE THE OFFICE
GOING TO WORK WITH CONERNED
ORGANIZATIONS WE WILL BE AT
CLOSING THE BILL TODAY- WE HAVE
A NUMBER OF CONCERNS WHICH YOU
LOOKED IN OUR LETTER WHICH WE
SUBMITTED TO THE COMMITTEE WE
ALSO LIKE TO REGISTER
OPPOSITION FROM THE SAN ANDRES
POPPING THE ENVIRONMENT.
COMMITTED FOR BETTER
ENVIRONMENT PHYSICIANS FOR
SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY LOS
ANGELES AND LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
FOR JUST ACCOUNTABILITY. THANK
YOU. AND NINE SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. A GOOD
MORNING- MANAGER AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THIS IS DAVID
HEADED FROM THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK TO YOU THIS MORNING UP
WE'VE FOR A NEUTRALIZE AB NINE
HUNDRED WHEN IT WAS FIRST.
ENACTED BUT THE FOLLOWING YEARS
HAVE INDICATED SOME PROBLEMS
WITHOUT AN IMPLEMENTED OF SNOW
WE HAVE PROPOSED SOME
AMENDMENTS. THERE ARE MANY
COMMON LETTER TO TAKE CARE OF
THAT WE'VE SEEN IN PARTICULAR
WITH RESPECT. PROJECT SOME OF
UNSERVED SUPPLIED WITH. WERE
OUT OF YOU. THE UPDATE IN ORDER
TO HAVE A TRUE THAT SHE CROTCH.
WE PROPOSED CHANGES THERE- IT
ALSO CHANGES YEAH OR A NEW IDEA
ABOUT HOW OFTEN. NEED TO BE
COMPUTED AND VERIFIED. CORD
WITH THOSE PEOPLE WITH BUT A SO
THE COMMUNITIES GET SOME COLD
BENEFITS WENT OFF THAT- OR
PROVIDE. WE WOULD BE HAPPY TO
WORK WITH THE AUTHOR BUT CAN
YOU TRY TO MAKE THE CHANGES IF
WE THINK THERE- THAT THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HELP THE LARGEST
PROJECTS. IN CALIFORNIA STEP UP
AND HELP ME OUR CLIMATE GOALS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU.
THOSE I BELIEVE- I'M SORRY
PLEASE PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY I
APOLOGIZE- NO FURTHER
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE
ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO VOICE THEIR
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. MODERATE IF YOU CAN QUEUE
UP ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WHO ARE WISHING TO TESTIFY.
ABSOLUTELY WE DO HAVE ONE RIGHT
NOW AND THAT COMES FROM LINE
SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AT WRIGLEY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE REGISTER IN OUR
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL THANK YOU.
YOU OKAY THE MODERATORS A
MOMENT IN CASE ANYBODY ELSE'S
CALLING IN. AND AS A REMINDER
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN FOLLOWED BY ZERO
THIS IS ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC WHO IS HERE IN PERSON
WHO WISHES TO VOICE A POSITION
ON THE BILL PLEASE RAISE YOUR
HAND NOW. I SEE NOT. OKAY
WITHOUT I WILL THEN TURN TO THE
COMMITTEE TO SEE IF ANYBODY HAS
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. MR
MURATSUCHI. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR I. WANTED TO ASK IF I MAY
THE- MISTER PETTIT WHAT THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IF WITH THE- OPPOSED
AND ACCEPTED AMENDMENTS- BUT
ARE THEY REMOVING THEIR
OPPOSITION. WHAT WE'RE GETTING
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION OF
WOMEN WERE GETTING A LOT
CLOSER- TO BEING ABLE TO
SUPPORT BUT WE'RE NOT QUITE
THERE YET- AS I MENTIONED I
WOULD BE HAPPY TO WORK. WITH
THE PROPONENT IN WITH STAFF TO
TRY TO BRIDGE THE GAP. ALL
RIGHT AND THEN- A QUESTION FOR
THE AUTHOR. I NOTICED A MISTER
SANTIAGO AND THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS. THE POINT WAS MADE
THAT. OF THE SEVENTEEN PROJECTS
THAT HAVE BEEN CERTIFIED IN
EIGHT YEARS OF AB NINE HUNDRED
ONLY TWO PROJECTS HAVE BEEN
BUILT TO DATE AND NEITHER
INCLUDES HOUSING. DO YOU HAVE.
ANY INSIGHT AS TO WHETHER AB
NINE HUNDRED IS MAKING A
DIFFERENCE AT ALL- WILL WE
BELIEVE IT DOES BECAUSE I STILL
SHORTENS DOWN THE TIME. SO THE
PROCESS MANAGER MIGHT ANSWER. I
HAD AT. THE PROCESS- THAT'D
TAKE THE LENGTH OF THE PROCESS
IS THE IS. THE LOCAL HAVE
HAPPENED TO THE LARGE DEGREE
LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES APPROVING
THE PROCESS BECAUSE THERE'S A
COUPLE DIFFERENT STEPS. NUMBER
ONE IT IT THE- IT'S GONNA GET
APPROVED- THROUGH THE OF THIS
AT THIS POINT TO THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND- TO THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE. THEN IF THE
LOCAL MUNICIPAL WHO HAVE TO
APPROVE IT SO THIS WILL STILL
HAVE AN IMPACT. ONCE APPROVED
BY LOCAL MUNICIPALITY IF THERE
IS A DESPITE A LEGAL DISPUTE IT
WOULD REDUCE THE TIME TO ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY DAYS
FROM A PROCESS THAT WOULD TAKE
ABOUT THREE TO FIVE DAYS.
DURING IN CALLING IT IS THE
LARGER PROBLEM- IN DEVELOPING
DEVELOPMENT UNDERSTOOD
CALIFORNIA'S WE READ IN THE
PAPERS AND BE BEEN CONSTANTLY
BRIEFED. IT'S JUST A LENGTHY
PROJECT- AS A REFERS TO HOUSING
THERE ARE SOME PROJECTS- EITHER
GO THE PIPELINE NOW- THAT
INCLUDE HOUSING INCLUDING. A
SENIOR HOUSING- IS SO THERE IS
A BUT AGAIN WHAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO. I AT LEAST I
WOULD SAY THAT YOU'RE REFERRING
TO IS THE LAW PROCESSOR TAKES
TO ACTUALLY SOMETHING APPROVED.
SO THOSE PROJECTS- ALTHOUGH
THEY HAVE BEEN COMPLETED YEAH
YOU CAN SIZE SEVERAL PROJECTS
THERE ARE IN THE PROCESS IT IS
THAT ARE. BEING WORKED ON. THAT
HOW MANY TRAVELING HAVE HOLLY
THE HOLLYWOOD CENTER PROJECT
FOR EXAMPLE HAS. DON'T CALL ME
AS  CAN LOOK AT THE MINUTE I
THINK IT'S ABOUT A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY- FOR THE HOUSING SENIOR
A CORRECT MYSELF WITH YOU- OR
YOU CAN GIVE ME THE TIME TO
TAKE A LOOK AT IT I THINK IT'S
ABOUT A HUNDRED AND THIRTY.
SENIORS SENIOR HOUSING HORRIBLE.
I JUST WANT TO STATE THAT MADAM
CHAIRWOMAN I'M- BUT THAT'S OKAY
I THINK THAT I THINK WE HAVE
THE ANSWER UNLESS YOU'D LIKE
THE WITNESS. MR SO I CAN VERIFY
THAT NUMBER WITH YOU AS WELL TO
FIVE. THAT'S OKAY I WILL TAKE
YOUR- YOUR WORK FOR THAT. I
JUST WANTED TO- STATE THAT. NOT
HAVING BEEN INVOLVED IN THE
CONVERSATIONS FOR THE APPROVAL
OF. V. ASSEMBLY BILLS THAT
DEALT WITH THE OAKLAND ETS AND
THE CLIPPERS PROJECTS- I HAVE
HEARD AND I AM I SHARE THE
CONCERNS RAISED BY THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL. IN
TERMS OF. YOU KNOW THE ACTUAL
GOOD FAITH COMPLIANCE WITH- THE
ARM. NEGOTIATED J. SHE
EMISSIONS- CONDITIONS THAT
WERE- IMPOSED A THROUGH THE
LEGISLATION A. B. SEVEN THREE
FOUR AND AB NINE EIGHT SEVEN.
AND SO I WILL BE FOLLOWING
THIS- THIS BILL TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE- YOU KNOW TO IN FACT.
PROVIDE A WAY NOT ONLY FOR THE
DEVELOPERS IN TERMS OF SPEEDING
UP THE PROCESS OF DEVELOPING
THESE MAJOR PROJECTS BUT ALSO
TO ENSURE THAT THIS IS A WIN
ALSO FOR THE ENVIRONMENT- AND
MAKING SURE THAT GHG REDUCTIONS
REAL LOCAL GAC REDUCTIONS ARE
IN FACT ACTUALLY CHIEF- BUT FOR
TODAY I WILL BE. VOTING FOR THE
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIRMAN I COMMENT. YES GO
AHEAD WE DO HAVE A- COMMITTEE
MEMBER WHO DOES CITY SUPPORTING
THE BILL BUT IF YOU WANT TO
COMMENT THAT'S FINE YEAH AND I
JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT THERE
WAS ANOTHER PROJECT A FRIEND
GOT THREE OH PROJECT OVER IN
SUNSET THAT HAS MIXED
AFFORDABLE HOUSING- IN IT AS
WELL AND I DO I BELIEVE THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THAT MADAM
CHAIR PUT TOGETHER ADDRESSED
THE ISSUE OF G. H. T. CONCERNS
THAT HAVE BEEN DONE- IS SPENT
OUT OF STATE IN THE PAST AND
SECOND THOSE WERE STAND ALONE
BILLS. IS I IS I RECALL THAT
ARE SUFFERING ABOVE WHAT THE
WITH THE- THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
COME MEMBERS. WITH QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. OKAY JUST TO CLARIFY-
THAT MOTION THEN WOULD INCLUDE
THE AMENDMENTS I'M ASSUMING AND
ALSO THE EXTENSION THE ONE YEAR
EXTENSION OF THE SUNSET DATE AS
THEY'RE REQUESTING. WHICH THE
CHAIR IS- MANY O IT IS FINE
WITH YES MISTER SANTIAGO I
WANTED TO CLEAR SOMETHING UP
BEFORE I WALKED IN HERE AND
JUST A IT WAS TOLD TO ME BY THE
SPONSORS THAT YOU MAY HAVE BEEN
OKAY WITH AN EXTENSION TO-
TWENTY FOUR IS THAT ACCURATE
RIGHT NOW IS A STANDS IT'S ON
THAT ONE. THAT'S WHAT I WAS
JUST MENTIONING I WAS ASKING IF
HE AS WILLING TO THANK HAVE
THE MOTION INCLUDE THE ONE YEAR
EXTENSION OF THE SUNSET TO GET
THE PROJECTS AN ADDITIONAL YEAR
THANK YOU MANAGER THAT AFFECTS.
HERE YOU OFFER- YEAH. OF
COURSE. OKAY SO WE HAVE A
MOTION TO HAVE A SECOND. THE
MOTION AND A SECOND WE HAVE A
ROLL CALL PLEASE. DO YOU WANT
TO ASK YOU TO CLOSE. I'M SORRY
I'M MISTER SANTIAGO PLEASE
PARDON ME- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE RESPECT WHEN AFTER I
BOUGHT THEY DO NOT. OKAY AB
TWENTY NINE NINETY ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN
HI FLORA FLORA ALL RIGHT CHAO
CHOW HI EGGMAN. EGGMAN NOT
VOTING GARCIA GARCIA NOT VOTING
LIMóN. Là M<c.cyan> NOT VOTING</c>
MATHIS. OUR OFFICE ALL RIGHT
MCCARTY. BRO WROTE I HERE AT CG.
WHERE IT'S A GI STONE STONE NOW.
THE MEASURE AS SIX VOTES OUT.
THANK YOU AGAIN. OUR NEXT BILL
I SEE MISTER MULLIN. TURN NEXT
BILL IS AB TWENTY EIGHT ZERO A
TWENTY EIGHT OH NINE. MOVE SIDE
WITH THE MOTION AND A SECOND.
MISTER BOWMAN EVER YOU ARE
READY THE PERCENT. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS- FIRST
TAKING A BABY TWENTY SIX TWENTY
ONE ON REGION REGIONAL
RESILIENCY PLANNING. AS YOU
KNOW CLIMATE CHANGE IS ALREADY
AFFECTING CALIFORNIA AND IS
PROJECTED TO CONTINUE TO DO SO
WELL INTO THE FORESEEABLE
FUTURE. CURRENT AND PROJECTED
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE
INCLUDE INCREASED TEMPERATURE
SEA LEVEL RISE INTENSE
WILDFIRES ALTER PRECIPITATION
PATTERNS EXCESSIVE FLOODING
SEVERE DROUGHT AND MORE
FREQUENT STORM EVENTS. THESE
IMPACTS TO RESULT IN ADDITIONAL
CONSEQUENCES INCLUDING
DETRIMENTAL EFFECTS ON HUMAN
HEALTH AND SAFETY ECONOMIC
CONTINUITY ECOSYSTEM INTEGRITY
AND PROVISION OF BASIC SERVICES
MANY IMPACTS WILL VERY BASED ON
ACOMMUNITIES PHYSICAL SOCIAL
AND ECONOMIC CHARACTERISTICS
WHICH TEND TO EXTEND BEYOND
CITY OR COUNTY BOUNDARIES. THIS
MAKES REGIONAL COORDINATION
BETWEEN LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
NONPROFITS AND PRIVATE SECTOR
ENTITIES A VITAL COMPONENT OF
THROW RESILIENCY PLANNING SOME
LOCAL ENTITIES ACROSS THE STATE
OF BEGUN THE PROCESS OF
PREPARING FOR THE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE HOWEVER MANY
ENTITIES HAVE NOT BEGUN
COORDINATING THIS PREPARED AS
WITH THE CHASE AND ENTITIES IN
THE REGION. AND SOME HAVE NOT
BEGUN PLANNING OUT ALL DUE TO
THE LACK OF COORDINATED
PLANNING THE STATE'S CURRENT
MECHANISM FOR FUNDING
ADAPTATION PROJECTS HAS BEEN
PRIMARILY PIECEMEAL WITH NO
COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY FOR
COORDINATING ITS INVESTMENTS TO
ENSURE THE MOST EFFECTIVE
RESILIENCY RETURN AB TWENTY SIX
TWENTY ONE SIX TO FILL THIS GAP
BY DEVELOPING GUIDANCE. FOR
POTENTIAL STATE FEDERAL OR
PRIVATE INVESTMENT IN FUNDING
REGIONAL PRIORITY ADAPTATION
PROJECTS ACROSS THE STATE AND
ENCOURAGING LOCAL AND REGIONAL
ENTITIES TO COLLABORATE ONE
PLANNING FOR CLIMATE ADAPTATION
IN A WAY THAT PROMOTES REGIONAL
SOLUTIONS THAT IMPROVE
EFFECTIVENESS AND EFFICIENCY OF
ADAPTATION ACTIONS PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY THIS
MORNING. IS SALLY. THIS BROWN
FONG BY WITH THE CLIMB READING
AS A BAY AREA CLIMATE NETWORK
VIA THE PHONE. THANK YOU- NICE
THE MODERATOR TO PLEASE KEEP UP
THE WITNESSES. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY BEFORE
YOU TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY SIX TWENTY ONE. MY NAME
IS MACK ARNOLD AND I'M IN TERMS
CEO A VALLEY VISION NONPROFIT
HERE IN THE CAPITAL REGION IN
MY WORK ABOUT THE VISION I'VE
BEEN AN ACTIVE LEADER OF THE
CAPITAL REGION I'M WRITING THIS
COLLABORATIVE OR C. R. C. SINCE
TWENTY FOURTEEN AND CURRENTLY
SERVICE IT'S CHAIR. IN THE
CAPITAL REGION OUR CLIMATE
RISKS CENTER. ON EXTREME HEAT
WILD FIRE AND BOTH DROUGHT AND
FLOOD. AND OTHER REGIONS OF THE
STATE FACE DIFFERENT RISKS. I'M
ALSO THE IMMEDIATE PAST CHAIR
OF THE STATEWIDE ALLIANCE A
REGIONAL CLEVERNESS FOR CLIMATE
ADAPTATION OR ARE KIND. A
COALITION OF SEVEN DIVERSE
VOLUNTARY URBAN NUMBER ON THAT
WORKS OF COMMUNITY LEADERS AND
CLIMATE PRACTITIONERS WHICH ALL
TO CREATE AND IMPLEMENT
EFFECTIVE ADAPTATION PLANS. TO
BUILD REGIONAL RESILIENCE TO
CLIMATE IMPACTS I SPEAK TODAY
BASED ON THIS EXPERIENCE AND
ALL OF US AND ON BEHALF OF
VALLEY VISION AND MYSELF. YEAH
THE MOST SCALE FOR CLIMATE
ADAPTATION WORK IS REGIONAL.
REGIONAL LEVEL. SO ARE ABLE TO
SPEND. BOUNDARIES AS THEY DO
WHILE ALSO RESPONDING TO
REGIONAL CLIMATE RISKS AS THEY
ALSO MUST TO. GET THE CURRENT
ECONOMIC CHALLENGE NOW FACING
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WILL GREATLY
THREATEN THEIR ABILITY TO
CONDUCT THIS ESSENTIAL PLANNING.
AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY ONE WILL
CREATED DURABLE FRAMEWORK FOR
EFFECTIVE ADAPTATION PLANNING
AND ACTION IT WILL ALSO ENSURE
THAT NECESSARY FUTURE FUNDING
CAN BE ALLOCATED IN A MANNER TO
SUPPORT SUCH A COLLABORATION.
AND RESPECTED I FIRST NATURES
ARE REGION'S. SPECIFICALLY WE
BELIEVE THAT AB TWENTY SIX
TWENTY ONE FRAMEWORK HELPS TO
SUPPORT THREE LEGS OF THE STOOL
NECESSARY FOR SUCCESSFUL
REGIONAL ADAPTATION WORK FIRST.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT CAPACITY
INCREASING THE CAPACITY OF
LOCAL PLANNING ENTITIES TO
CONDUCT ESSENTIAL MULTI AGENCY
AND MULTI JURISDICTION
COLLABORATION. SECOND REGIONAL
NETWORKS SUPPORTING THE IF
EFFORTS OF DIVERSE LOCAL AND
REGIONAL NETWORKS STAKEHOLDERS
TO PROVIDE ACCESS INCLUSION
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
TO. ADAPTATION PLANNING
PROCESS. AND THIRD TECHNICAL
AND SCIENTIFIC CLIMATE SERVICES
SUPPORTING THE NEED FO LOCALLY
APPROPRIATE LEVELS OF TECHNICAL
IN APPLIED SCIENCE ADVICE FOR
ADAPTATION PLANNING. THESE ARE
THE ELEMENTS THAT WOULD
CONTRIBUTE TO EFFECTIVE
ADAPTATION RESPONSE AND WE ARE
PLEASED TO SEE THEM BEING
DEVELOPED BY AB TWENTY SIX
TWENTY ONE. AND TO SUPPORT THE
BILL AS A RESULT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ON GROUPS
WORKING WITH THE- CLIMATE READY
TO INSTITUTE UC BERKELEY I'M
ALSO THE DIRECTOR OF THE BAY
AREA CLIMATE ADAPTATION NETWORK
AND MANY YEARS AGO WITH
JONATHAN ARE FREE I WAS A CO
FOUNDER PARKA- I THINK THIS
MORNING IN PORT OF AB TWENTY
SIX TWENTY ONE. WE NEED A TRULY
INTEGRATE CALIFORNIA CLIMATE
ADAPTATION PROGRAM WE NEED A
STRUCTURE. THAT BRINGS TOGETHER
STATE AND REGIONAL AND LOCAL
RESOURCES IN THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE AND POWERFUL MANNER
WE NEED REGIONAL PLAN. TO
COORDINATE OUR ACTIONS WE NEED
REGIONAL. NETWORKS JUST SUPPORT
AND INFORM THOSE PLANS AND WE
NEED. REGIONALLY FOCUSED
ACTIONABLE SCIENCE TO GUIDE THE
WAY SO THAT'S WHY WE- SUPPORT
TWENTY SIX TWENTY ONE IN ITS
EFFORTS TO. CREATE SUCH A ARE
BEGINNING ABOUT THE STRUCTURE
OR FRAMEWORK- SO WE CAN ADDRESS
TOGETHER. HELP IF THE
STRUCTURE- ON NATURAL SYSTEMS
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY OUR
CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. NO CALIFORNIA AS
YOU KNOW HAS BEEN A GLOBAL
LEADER. IN REDUCING CARBON
EMISSIONS FOR THE LAST FIFTEEN
YEARS SINCE THE PASSAGE OF. AB
THIRTY TWO. THIS DIDN'T HAPPEN
BECAUSE WE HOPE THAT
INDIVIDUALS ARE. LOCAL
GOVERNMENT OR HOME THANK YOU.
THESE ARE STATE AGENCIES WOULD
DO THAT RIGHT IT HAPPENED
BECAUSE- WE. ALL GOALS WE HAD
MANDATE WE HAVE INNOVATIVE
REACHES AND LOW CLIMB PROBE AND
WE HAVE THE POTENTIAL. OF FOR
INCOME. OF ALL THAT AND WE
BELIEVE IT'S TIME FOR
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE ADAPTATION
PROGRAM TO REALLY GROW UP IN A
IN A SIMILAR FASHION WE KNOW WE
GET IT THIS IS A VERY DIFFICULT
TIME IN OUR STATE AND GLOBALLY.
BUT THE CLIMATE IMPACTS ARE NOT
GOING AWAY- AT ALL- THE GETTING
WORSE SO CALIFORNIA HAS A
CHANCE NOW. AND WE MUST DO THIS
IN THE NEXT THREE YEARS TO
BECOME A GLOBAL LEADER ON
CLIMATE ADAPTATION OF BY THE
WAY WE CAN CREATE THOUSANDS OF
GOOD JOBS IN A PROP THAT. WE
BELIEVE AB AB TWENTY SIX TWENTY
ONE CAN IMPORTANT PART OF THAT
MOVEMENT FORWARD THANK YOU FOR
TAKING THE TIME. IF YOU THERE
ANY MEMBERS THE WISHING VOICE
THEIR SUPPORT. FOR THE BILL
HERE IN PERSON IN THE ASSEMBLY
IN IN THE CHAMBERS. OKAY SEEING
NO HANDS GO UP WILL GO TO THE
TELEPHONE LINES IN THE VIDEO
CONFERENCING ROOM TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO VOICE
SUPPORT- MODERATOR IF YOU CAN
PLEASE. LET US KNOW IF THERE'S
ANYONE ON THE PHONE. CERTAINLY
AND IF YOU WISH TO SHOW YOUR
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. MY NINETY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
JUSTIN HIGHER FROM THE BILL CON
BALLY LEADERSHIP GROUP IN THE
PROUD TO SUPPORT EIGHTY TWENTY
SIX TWENTY ONE FOR THE REASONS
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED THANK YOU
SO MUCH. THANK YOU. PROVIDING A
MODEL FOR WOULD YOU OTHER PHONE
TESTIMONY. YES NEXT WITNESS.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A FEW MORE
THAT HAVE CUED UP AND WILL GIVE
THEM JUST A MOMENT. OKAY SO
GOOD MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
COULD SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP
GROUP WAS SHOWING THE EXAMPLE
OF HOW TO GIVE. TELEPHONE
SUPPORT TESTIMONY. LAW FALL
THEIR EXAMPLE. IT WILL BE JUST
ANOTHER MOMENT THANK YOU. NINE
EIGHTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WELL BRIAN SHOW ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CLIMATE AND
AGRICULTURE NETWORK ALL FOR.
THANK YOU. MODERATOR THERE MORE
PEOPLE ON THE PHONE. WE DO HAVE
ONE MORE IN IT WILL BE JUST
ANOTHER MOMENT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NINE THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BACK MORNING FIFTY BALK
WITH WITH FINAL VISOR LIKE
EXPRESS BOARD OF CALIFORNIA HOW
OLD LINE. THANK YOU. MODERATORS
THAT OUR LAST QUEUED UP PHONE
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT FOR. YES
THAT WAS THE LAST ONE FOR
SUPPORT THANK YOU WITH YOUR
ANYBODY HERE IN THE CHAMBERS
WISHING TO VOICE OPPOSITION. TO
THE BILL SEEING NONE WILL MOVE
TO THE PHONE TO SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE IN THE VIDEO ROOM OR BY
PHONE WISHING TO VOICE
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. MODERN
IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE YES IF
YOU WISH TO OPPOSE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
THERE IS NO ONE IN THE QUEUE AT
THIS TIME PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME WE WILL MOVE
TO MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. MS
EGGMAN. THANK YOU OF GOOD
MORNING MISTER MULLIS NICE TO
SEE YOU I JUST HAVE A QUESTION
THAT. THAT AS WE ALL CLEANED UP
ALL OF OUR BILL PACKAGES AND
ARE LOOKING AT THE BUDGET. I
UNDERSTAND THE ISSUE OF BUT
SEALEVEL RISE AND IN THE FUTURE
COSTS OF THAT BUT SHOULD WE
REALLY BE TAKING ANYTHING OUT
OF THE GENERAL FUND RIGHT NOW.
IN LIGHT OF A- SHOULDWE REALLY
BE TAKING ANYTHING ON THE
GENERAL FUND RIGHT NOW IN LIGHT
OF THE BUDGET DEFICIT. WELL THE
SEVENTY ONE THAT'S A- THAT'S A
BROADER QUESTION THAT GOES
BEYOND THAT THE SCOPE OF THIS
BILL- OF PERHAPS A
PHILOSOPHICAL ONE IT MAY BE A
VERY PRACTICAL AND ONE THAT WE
FACE. BOB THIS AUGUST IN
PARTICULAR- WITH OUR TRAILER
BILL PROCESS I THINK WE ARE ALL
POLICING FOR THAT REAR. WE ARE
ACTIVELY CONTEMPLATING A
RESILIENCY- PACKAGE THE
RESILIENCY BOND. THAT WOULD BE
A JOB CREATING ONE THAT'S THE
TOPIC OF A IFFERENT
CONVERSATION BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE TODAY. I THINK WE
NEED TO- DEAL WITH THE FACT
THAT WHETHER IT'S- THIS CYCLE
OR A FUTURE CYCLE THERE WILL BE
FUNDING STREAMS FOR. OF THE
GENERATIONAL CHALLENGE OF OUR
TIME IN CLIMATE. THAT WE NEED
TO HAVE A PROCESSES IN PLACE.
SO WHEN THOSE FUNDS BECOME
AVAILABLE- WE HAVE A MECHANISM
IN PLACE TO PRIORITIZE A
REGIONAL PLANNING TO PRIORITIZE
PROJECT- THEY GET THE BEST BANG
FOR THE TAXPAYER BUCK- IN TERMS
OF ANY KIND OF FUTURE BOND
FINANCING OR OTHER FUNDING
MECHANISM SO REALLY THIS IS
ABOUT. INCENTIVIZING THE RIGHT
KIND OF REGIONAL PLANNING BUT-
I HEAR YOUR CONCERNS IT'S ONE
THAT I SHARE THAT WE LIVE IN A
DRAMATICALLY ALTERED. REALITY
IN THIS BUILDING- SOMETHING
THAT I COULD NOT HAVE
CONTEMPLATED WHEN I SHE DID
THIS BILL WILL. BUT KEEP IN THE
MAG OF THAT. CAN THAT CONFRONTS
THIS STATE. WE HAVE KEEP BILLS
TURN IT TO INCENTIVIZE KIND OF
PLANNING IF AND WHEN IT LET'S
HOPE IT'S WHEN FUNDING BECOMES
AVAILABLE TO MAKE RESILIENCY
PROJECTS UP A REALITY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM. DID
I ES QUE. MR MULLIN WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE. I WILL JUST SAY
BEFORE I THINK WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND CORRECT I WOULD
JUST SAY THAT I APPRECIATE YOU
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND I
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE A DOCTOR
EGGMAN SO- QUESTION ABOUT THE
BUDGET. I DO THINK- WE NEED TO
BE THINKING ABOUT THAT WITH ALL
OF OUR BILLS THIS YEAR AND
SOMETHING THAT THE YOU KNOW THE
GOVERNOR WILL ALSO HELP US
WITHIN THE APPROPRIATIONS.
CHAIRS WILL HELP US WITH BUT
THIS PANDEMIC HAS SHOWN US
THAT. ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
PLACES FOR US TO PUT OUR MONEY
IS IN PLANNING AND RESILIENCY
AND BEING PREPARED AND WE DO
KNOW THAT CLIMATE CHANGE IS A
LOOMING. DISASTER THAT'S GOING
TO DO IF- THIS PANDEMIC AND SO
THE MORE WE DO TO MITIGATE THAT
NOW. I THINK. CERTAINLY MONEY
WELL SPENT SO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD WITH THAT
CAN WE HAVE A ROLL CALL. AB
TWENTY SIX TWENTY ONE. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
FRIEDMAN HI. FRIEDMAN HI FLORA.
FLORA NO CHAO JOE HI EGGMAN AYE
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA. GARCIA HI
LIMóN. THE MOAN HIGH MATHIS.
MATHIS MCCARTY. MCCARTY I BRO.
BRO NO. CG CG STONE. STONE HI.
THAT'S EIGHT BOTH. ABLE TO THE
BILL IS OUT MR YOU'RE NOT BILL
PLAY. THANK YOU MADAM TO. AB.
TWENTY EIGHT OH NINE. AB TWENTY
EIGHT OR NINE IS INTRODUCED IN
RESPONSE TO THE STATE AUDITOR'S
REPORT OF MAY TWENTY NINETEEN
THAT MADE SIGNIFICANT
RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW TO
REFORM AND IMPROVE THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY CONSERVATION AND
DEVELOPMENT COMMISSION
OPERATIONS ESPECIALLY AROUND
ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITIES. I HAVE
QUITE A LENGTHY INTRODUCTION WE
DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
LET ME JUST- SUMMARIZE MADAM
CHAIR THAT THIS WORK IS THE
PRODUCT OF AN AUDIT THE BI
PARTISAN AUDIT OF THE B. C.'S
OPERATIONS WHERE WE SAW A GREAT
DEAL OF INCONSISTENCY IN THE
APPLICATION OF ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS. OF THE CORE THIS BILL-
I HAS TO DO WITH THE BAY FILL
CLEAN UP AN ABATEMENT FIND-
WHICH IS A CRUCIAL ISSUE WE
HAVE- TAKEN THOSE ELEMENTS OUT
OF THE BILL WE'RE GOING TO BE
DEALING WITH THAT AND BUDGET
SUB THREE. AND I OMITTED TO
RESOLVING THOSE ISSUES BUT THIS
BILL KEEPS THE PROCESS MOVING
FORWARD ON IMPLEMENTING THE
AUDITOR'S ACT TO READ A-
BECAUSE WE WANT A STRONG BC. I
IN TERMS OF ITS- ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS GOING FORWARD I IN THE
BAY AREA AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU YOU
TOO WE HAVE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE LINES OR
IN PERSON. AS MODERATOR. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
FORGET IN JUST A MOMENT TO
QUEUE UP. WE DO HAVE ONE PERSON
THAT CUED UP TO WILL GIVE THEM
JUST ANOTHER MOMENT. NINE
EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NO RESPONSE
RELEASING THE LINE. PAGE THIRTY
THERE ARE NO MORE COMMENTS IN
THE QUEUE. OKAY NO TO THE WITH
THOSE THE PRIMARY WITNESSES.
FOR THE BELT. OKAY OF IF THERE
IS NO ONE- HERE TO VOICE THEIR
SUPPORT FOR THE BILL IS THERE
ANY OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
ANYONE IN THE CHAMBER ANYONE
HERE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
WISHING TO OPPOSE THE BILL. IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE LINE
WISHING TO VOICE OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. YES MA'AM DO YOU WISH
TO. IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. I'M SORRY SO IT IS THIS
IS THE ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO THE
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WHO WERE-
UP. PRESET TO SEE VOICE
OPPOSITION OR IS THAT THE
GENERAL PUBLIC LINE BECAUSE WE
DO HAVE ONE WITNESS. TO THE
FIRST TESTIFIED OPPOSITION.
OKAY AND WHEN IS YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MY NAME IS LARRY GOLD
BAND I AM EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE THEY CONSERVATION
DEVELOPMENT COMMISSION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR HOLDING THE-
SESSION THIS MORNING I HOPE
THAT YOU AND ALL OF YOUR FAMILY
AND FRIENDS ARE SAFE AND
HEALTHY. THE BAY CONSERVATION
DEVELOPMENT COMMISSION SUPPORTS
ALMOST ALL OF THE AUDIT
RECOMMENDATIONS AND SAID SO
ALMOST A YEAR AGO BECAUSE WILL
BE A YEAR AGO TOMORROW WHEN THE
AUDIT BECAUSE ACTUALLY- WAS
ACTUALLY RELEASED. WE CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WORK WITH MISTER MULLIN AND HIS
STAFF OUR DISCUSSIONS HAVE BEEN
INCREDIBLY FRUITFUL W WELCOME
THE COMMITTEE REPORT WHICH
LISTS A NUMBER OF- SUGGESTED OR
POSSIBLE CHANGES TO THE
LEGISLATION MANY OF WHICH
MAYOR. OUR DISCUSSIONS WITH
MISTER MULLIN STAFF- WE
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE HIS
WILLINGNESS TO WORK WITH US
AND- WE LOOK FORWARD TO-
SUPPORTING THE LEGISLATION
AFTER IT IS AMENDED AS MR
MULLIN SUGGESTED IN SOME. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. ARE THERE
ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE UBLIC
WISHING TO VOICE OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. MODERATES MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE CLEAR UP ANY
PHONE WITNESSES OPPOSITION. AND
AGAIN AS A REMINDER YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND WE HAVE
NO ONE QUEUING UP FOR COMMENT
AT THIS TIME PLEASE PROCEED
THANK YOU WITH THAT I WILL GO
TO MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ANYBODY HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR-
COMMENTS OR CONCERNS. WITH THAT
MISTER MULLIN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE EXPECT PLAY ASK FOR NAY
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND WE HAVE A
ROLL CALL PLEASE. AB TWENTY
EIGHT OH NINE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
FRIEDMAN HI. FRIEDMAN HI FLORA.
FLORA ALL RIGHT CHAO. CHOW HI
EGGMAN. EGGMAN ALL RIGHT
GARCIA. GARCIA HI LOW MOAN. THE
UP BY MATHIS. MATHIS I MCCARTY
MCCARTY AHRI BRO BRO HI YEAR
TUCCI NEAR TO GI STONE STONE
ALL RIGHT. ELEVEN ZERO ELEVEN
TO ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT. THANK
YOU. NEXT WE HAVE MISTER GLORIA.
WITH THE TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY
ONE. THE BILL SECOND OF WE HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND. MR
GLORIA PROCEED I TALK OUT OF A-
I HAVE OUT OF A MOTION AND A
SECOND MADAM CHAIR I JUST LOW
EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION TO YOU
AND TO YOUR STAFF- FOR GETTING
TO THIS POINT TODAY- I DO HAVE
SOME WITNESSES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE BOTH ON A TELEPHONE
AND ON VIDEO CONFERENCING- HIS
SON ACROSS HIS THE SECOND
RECTOR ST ACT- AND MORE TOP
REPRESENT THE CITY OF SAN
DIEGO- ULTIMATELY WE'RE TRYING
TO CREATE A PROCESS FOR THE
COMMUNITY TO PARTICIPATE IN
THIS PROJECT THAT WILL BE
TRANSFORMATIONAL. TO NINETEEN
EIGHTY JOBS IN SAN DIEGO- AND
STIMULATE OUR LOCAL ECONOMY AS
WELL AS BUILDING A WORLD CLASS
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM FOR OUR
COMMUNITY OKAY THANK YOU YOU'RE
WITNESSES PLEASE. GOOD MORNING
AT CHAIR. MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
YOUR- TODAY. I ALSO APPRECIATE
THE- MEMBER GLORIA AND SENATE
BOTTOM. FOR GETTING THIS BILL.
AND THAT KIDS. TO THEM OUT. CRY
YEAH AM NOT A SONOGRAM THAT
THEY- THAT A- OF SAN. THAT AND
BE ABLE FOR THE SAN DIEGO
ENGINE. AND CHAT ONE IS GOOD
SEE YOU AGAIN YOU KNOW I SPENT.
IS A MY KIDDING TRY TO A- AND-
THEN LOT OF MONEY THING IS A
SCARED WOULD. THEY HAVE THE
ORDER AND REGULAR WATER. WITH
YOU. AND NOW MY- YEAR HERE.
WELL HELLO BURIED WITH THE-
THEY- NAY TO THE DEVELOPED
ABOUT WHAT. COME ON THIS. THE
ACT. AND THAT THIS PARTNERSHIP
AND THAT WOULD COME. THE
POSSIBLE ATION. CENTRAL HEALTH.
YEAH PROVIDE THAT THAT EXPLAINS
IT THANK TO THE AIRPORT WHICH
DOES NOT EXIST RIGHT NOW. THE
LEGISLATION ON THE REQUESTED.
WITH THIS NATION ELEVEN OF
FAILED WORK TO SEE THAT. OF
THIS NEEDED TIME AT THAT. YEAH
AT WOULD THAT IN HAS. A SEQUEL
BY SO MEETING THE NEEDS WORK TO
ACHIEVE WITHOUT THAT WOULD NOT
DIG STE. WE ARE COMMITTING TO
WORKING WITH ALL. AND WE BEEN
IN CONTACT WITH ALL OF THEM TO
OUR WHY THIS BILL IS A- SEN
THANK IS. WE CAN AGREE FOR THE
GOVERNOR TO SIGN YEAH AND WHILE
THE STATE AGAIN THANK YOU-
CHAIRWOMAN THANK MEMBERS AND MY
TEAM AND I- WILL BE VERY HAPPY
TO US AND ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH DO YOU HAVE A NEW
ANOTHER WITNESS MORE TOP OF.
SAN DIEGO- BY VIDEO CONFERENCE
WITH. THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I AM WHERE A
TOP ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
SAN DIEGO. WE ARE PROUD CO
SPONSORS OF THIS MEASURE. AB
TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY ONE
PROVIDES FOR A LAST
TRANSPARENT PROCESS FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THIS CENTRAL
MOBILITY HUB THAT STAND I GUESS
DISCUSSED. THIS PROJECT IS A
VERY HIGH PRIORITY PROJECT FOR
THE CITY. WE BELIEVE IT'S GOING
TO BE TRANSFORMATIVE FOR OUR
REGION. AND THE PROJECT- MEETS
MANY OF THE CITY'S CO
BENEFICIAL GOALS THE TRANSIT
COMPONENT. I WILL HELP US MEET
OUR AGGRESSIVE CLIMATE ACTION
GOALS. IT WILL ALSO HELP US
MEET OUR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
GOALS BECAUSE THERE'S A MIXED
USE COMPONENT. AND IT WILL
ENABLE US TO RETAIN THE
THOUSANDS OF US NAVY JOBS THAT
WILL BE CO LOCATED AT THE
FACILITY. MOREOVER THIS PROJECT
ONE FOR THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS IN THE REGION
DURING THE CONSTRUCTION PHASE.
MAKING THIS BILL EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT NOW WE ASKED FOR YOUR
SUPPORT. WE DON'T. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. OF METAL MODERATOR
COULD YOU SEE CAN YOU PLEASE Q.
OF THE WITNESSES FOR PHONE
TESTIMONY IS THERE ANYBODY IN
THE ROOM WISHING TO VOICE THEIR
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL. SEEING
NO HANDS GO UP- MADAME
MODERATOR IF YOU CAN PLEASE GET
THE WITNESSES ARE READY TO
SPEAK AND JUST A REMINDER FOR
THE WITNESSES ON THE PHONE
PLEASE MAKE SURE THAT YOUR
PHONE'S. YOUR OTHER DEVICES ARE
MUTED AND YOUR PHONE IS ON
MEETING. REMINDER IF YOU WISH
TO SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AN
WITNESSES YOUR LINES ARE OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE DO HAVE ONE
PERSON QUEUING UP AND WILL GIVE
THEM JUST A MOMENT.
I NINETY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS IN HIS BRAIN AND ALSO
WITH THE ARK OF CALIFORNIA-
WE'RE NOT AT THE CORE OR UP
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL WE JUST
HAVE TO CONCERNED THAT WE'RE
COMMUNICATING WITH AUTHOR AND
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR TO ADDRESS THOSE
CONCERS SO I JUST WANT TO FIND
THAT WITH YOU. AND ONE OF OCT
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR.
CONVERSATIONS WITH US ARE LOOK
AT. ON THE- THANK YOU. THANK
YOU IS THERE ANYBODY WISHING TO
VOICE OPPOSITION OR CONCERNS TO
THE BILL ANYBODY HERE IN THE
ROOM. NOT A MODERATOR COULD YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL. IF YOU
WISH TO OPPOSE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN FOLLOWED BYZERO. WE HAVE
NO ONE IN THE QUEUE AT THIS
TIME PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU
I'LL BRING IT BACK NOW TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS. COMMENTS SEEING AND
HEARING NONE- MISTER LAURIE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
DOCUMENTS THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THIS RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND CAN WE HAVE
A ROLL CALL PLEASE. AB TWENTY
SEVEN THIRTY ONE. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN HI FLORA
FLORA ALL RIGHT CHAO CHOW HI
EGGMAN EGGMAN ALL RIGHT GARCIA.
GARCIA NOT VOTING LEMOND. LOAN
ALL RIGHT MATHIS. OFFICE I
MCCARTY. MCCARTY I BROKE. RONA
BOATING NEARED CG. MURATSUCHI
AYE STONE. STONE ARE. MEASURE
AS NINE VOTES YOU HAVE NINE
VOTES THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THEY CAN CHECK A
MEMBERS. THANK YOU. WE ARE
MOVING ON TO AB TWENTY NINE
FIFTY FOUR BY ROBERT RIVAS. IS
TO RIVAS. WHENEVER YOU ARE
READY. ONE MEDIC CHAIR
COLLEAGUES I CATCH MY BREATH
WA RUNNING DOWN THE HALL THE
PROBLEM I'VE GOT MY MASK HAD
RUN BACK. BUT IT- GOOD MORNING
IT'S GREAT TO BE HERE FIRST ONE
I THINK OUR COMMITTEE STAFF.
FOR THE WORK ON THE ANALYSIS OF
THE BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH
STAFF- IN THAT AS I MENTIONED
YESTERDAY WHEN I WAS. IN
COMMITTEE AND- I PRESENTED A
FEW BILLS. NO ONE COULD HAVE
PREDICTED OUT QUICKLY THIS
HEALTH CRISIS WILL TRANSFORM
OUR LIVES AND ALTHOUGH THERE'S
A LOT OF UNCERTAINTY MOVING
FORWARD- WE CERTAINLY OR WE CAN
BE ABSOLUTELY CERTAIN. THAT ARE
PRE PANDEMIC PROBLEMS OF
HOUSING. OF HOMELESSNESS. OF
ADDRESSING OUR CLIMATE CRISIS
THESE PROBLEMS STILL EXIST AND
CERTAINLY WILL ONLY GET WORSE
AS WE SHIFT OUR FOCUS TO
ADDRESS OUR CURRENT HEALTH
CRISIS AND DON'T GET ME WRONG.
ADDRESS IT IS HEALTH CRISIS IS
A SHOULD BE OUR NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY BUT WE ALSO NEED TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO PREVENT
EXISTING PROBLEMS FROM GETTING
WORSE SO WITH THAT SAID MADAM
CHAIR. I'M PLEASED TO BE HERE
AND PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
NINE FIVE FOUR. HERE IN
CALIFORNIA ARE LANDMARK
ENVIRONMENTAL LAW. A. B. THIRTY
TWO THE GLOBAL WARMING
SOLUTIONS ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
SIX ESTABLISH A COMPREHENSIVE
PROGRAM. TO REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS FROM ALL FROM ALL
SOURCES HERE IN CALIFORNIA. AB
THIRTY TWO REQUIRES THAT THE
CAL THAT THAT THE CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD. THAT WE
DEVELOP A SCOPING PLAN A PLAN-
THAT THE DESCRIBES OUR
APPROACH- THAT WOULD BEAT THE
APPROACH OUR STATE WILL TAKE TO
REDUCE GREENHOUSE GASES IN
CALIFORNIA. THE SCOPING PLAN
MUST BE UPDATED EVERY FIVE
YEARS. AND THE PREPARATION FOR
THE NEXT PLAN UP I'M PROUD TO
INTRODUCE THIS BEER THIS BILL
HERE TODAY. IT'S A BILL THAT
WILL ENSURE THAT THE NEXT PLAN
UPDATE FULLY CONSIDER AND
LEVERAGE. THE HUGE POWER OF
CALIFORNIA'S NATURAL AND
WORKING LANDS IN ACHIEVING
CALIFORNIA'S AMBITIOUS
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION GOALS.
AS HIGHLIGHTED IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS NATURAL IN WORKING
LANCE COMPRISE OVER 90% 90% OF
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE AND
BEAUTIFUL LANDSCAPE. THIS
INCLUDES FORESTS RANGELANDS
FARMS URBAN GREEN SPACES A
WETLAND SOILS. AND THESE LANDS
HAVE POTENTIAL TO SEQUESTER
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF CARBON.
AB TWO NINE FIVE FOUR IS A
SIMPLE STRAIGHTFORWARD BUT
IMPORTANT BILL. IT WOULD
REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD TO WORKING
COLLABORATION WITH OTHER
RELEVANT STATE AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS. AND IDENTIFIED
OVERALL CLIMATE GOAL FOR
CALIFORNIA'S NATURAL WORKING
LANCE ACCORDING TO THE BILL
LANGUAGE. THIS OVERALL CLIMATE
GOAL WILL IDENTIFY ACTIONS TO
SEQUESTER CARBON AND REDUCE
ATMOSPHERIC GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS IDENTIFY PRACTICES
POLICY INCENTIVES AND POTENTIAL
REDUCTIONS IN BARRIERS. THAT
WOULD HELP ACHIEVE THIS KIND OF
GOAL FOR CALIFORNIA NATURAL
LOOKING LANDS. WHY IS THIS BILL
IMPORTANT. AS A STATE WE MUST
REMAIN STEADFAST IN OUR
COMMITMENT AND EFFORTS TO
REDUCE EMISSIONS OF CARBON. BUT
WE ALSO NEED TO ENSURE THAT WE
DEVELOP PATHWAYS TO REMOVE
CARBON FROM THE ATMOSPHERE
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS THE MET
RESEARCHERS FROM THROUGH OUT
THE WORLD AGREE. IF WE'RE GOING
TO FEND OFF THE WORST IMPACTS
OF CLIMATE CHANGE WE MUST
MAXIMIZE METHODS TO SEQUESTER
OR CAPTURE CARD. CLEARLY
THERE'S NO SILVER BULLET WHEN
IT COMES TO REMOVING CO TWO
FROM THE ATMOSPHERE THERE'S NO
SINGLE TECHNOLOGY OR METHOD. TO
PROVIDE ALL OF THE CO TWO TO
REMOVE ALL THAT IS REQUIRED.
BUT WHAT WE DO KNOW IS ONE.
THERE ARE NATURAL WAYS TO
CAPTURE AND SUPPRESSED A
CARBON. AND TWO THERE ARE WAYS
TO CAPTURE CARD INVOLVE COMPLEX
ENGINEERING. AND QUITE
HONESTLY. REQUIRE A
TECHNOLOGICAL BREAKTHROUGH.
WILL REQUIRE INVESTMENT IN
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND INVOLVED IN
NUMEROUS LOGISTICAL AND
REGULATORY HURDLES ALL OF
WHICH- ARE POSSIBLE. BUT IT'S
GONNA TAKE TIME IT'S GONNA TAKE
MONEY. AND THE SECOND POINT
UNDERSCORES OUR NEED TO FULLY
LEVERAGE THE POTENTIAL OF OUR
NATURAL AND WORKING LANDS. IN
ARCATA CLIMATE CONVERSATION
HERE IN CALIFORNIA. NATURAL
SOLUTIONS FOR SEQUESTERING OR
CAPTURING CARBON ARE RELATIVELY
INEXPENSIVE. CAN BE IMPLEMENTED
WITH LITTLE INFRASTRUCTURE AND
ARE AVAILABLE TO US RIGHT NOW.
THESE NATURAL SOLUTIONS INCLUDE
LAND MANAGEMENT RESTORATION OF
WOODLANDS AND WETLANDS. AND
OTHER PRACTICES THAT INCREASE
THE AMOUNT OF CARBON STARTED
TREASON SOILS. AS DETAILED THE
COMMITTEE NOW SAYS IT'S
ESTIMATED THAT ARE NATURAL
WORKING LANDS HAVE THE
POTENTIAL. TO CONTRIBUTE UP
½70% OF CALIFORNIA'S GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION GOAL. IN ADDITION
TO PROVIDING- ADDITIONAL. SOME
POSITIVES OR SOME BENEFITS SUCH
AS IMPROVED WATER QUALITY AIR
QUALITY FOOD PRODUCTION LAND
CONSERVATION AND WILDFIRE
PREVENTION. AGAIN PASSAGE OF
THIS BILL WOULD PROVIDE FOR
OVERALL CLIMATE GOAL FOR
CALIFORNIA NATURAL WORKING
LANDS THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD
WOULD IDENTIFY BEST PRACTICES
POLICY INCENTIVES AND POTENTIAL
REDUCTION THE BARRIERS THAT
WOULD HELP ACHIEVE THIS GOAL.
IN THIS WAY. THE BILL WILL BE
SURE THAT NATURAL WORKING
THAT'S ARE A VITAL COMPONENT OF
OUR STATES CLIMATE PLAN THIS IS
AN OPPORTUNITY. AN OPPORTUNITY
TO BUILD ON AVAILABLE DATA AND
RESEARCH. A BY VANCE IN NATURAL
WAYS- THAT TO HELP CALIFORNIA
CHEAP EMISSION REDUCTIONS NOT
TO MAGIC CONTRIBUTE TO OUR
ECOSYSTEMS OVERALL HEALTH- THE
VALUE OF NATURAL AND WORKING
LANDS TO CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENT
TO OUR ECONOMY INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES CANNOT BE
OVERSTATED MANAGER. AND WITH
ME- HERE AT THIS HEARING TO
FURTHER INTRODUCED EXPLAIN THIS
BILL IS MICHELLE THE SORROW
WITH THE- NATURE CONSERVANCY.
AND GINNY MERYL WITH THE
CALFORNIA CLIMATE AND
AGRICULTURE NETWORK THANK YOU
MANAGER THANK YOU- MADAME
MODERATOR CAN BE PLEASE HAVE
THE WITNESSES. LINES ARE OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MICHELLE PATH THROW AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE CLIMATE PROGRAM
AT THE NATURE CONSERVANCY. HEY
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE AT THE PORT OF
IMPORTANT BILL AND AS A SPONSOR
WE ALSO WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RIVAS FOR HIS LEADERSHIP.
NOW MORE THAN EVER WE NEED
NATURE TO SUPPORT OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH AND THE HEALTH OF OUR
CLIMATE. SENATE BILL WOULD
ADVANCE. AS WELL AS OTHER
IMPORTANT BENEFIT. THEIR NUMBER
PUBLISHED SCIENTIFI ANALYSIS
INCLUDING SEVERAL THAT WE HAVE
DONE WHICH INDICATE THAT ACTED
LIKE URBAN FORESTRY FOURTH
RESTORATION FIRE RISK REDUCTION
LAND CONSERVATION. AND A
VARIETY OF LAND MANAGEMENT
ACTIVITIES CAN SIGNIFICANTLY
CONTRIBUTE TERM LONG TERM
CLINICAL. TO REDUCE CARBON IN
THE ATMOSPHERE ALSO PROTECT
UNITIES FROM CLIMATE IMPACT
LIKE FIRE EXTREME HEAT.
SEALEVEL RISE IN FLOOD. OVER
THE PAST DECADE THERE'S BEEN
SIGNIFICANT WORK IN THE STATE
ON THE TOPIC AT THE MEETING
GREENHOUSE GAS PRODUCTION
POTENTIAL ACCOUNTING METHODS
AND IDENTIFYING THE RANGE OF
BENEFITS THAT COULD RESULT FROM
CLIMATE ACTION IN THE SECTOR.
THE OF THE POOR A CLEAR CLIMB.
AND COORDINATED THE STATE
ACTION LIKE WE HAVE ANOTHER
FACTORS ARE STILL MISSING. THE
BILL REPORTER CATALYST TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES BY
LEADERSHIP LEGISLATIVE
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE. IN
ADVANCE AGENCY COORDINATION
WITH A CLEAR LEAD. PROVIDES A
CLEAR TIMELINE FOR CLINICAL AND
PLAN ON AND OFF THAT KNOWLEDGE
IS THAT CLIMATE STRATEGY FOR
OUR NATIONAL WORKING LAND IN
CALIFORNIA AND NEED TO TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT OTHER IMPORTANT
BENEFIT. WE STRONGLY SUPPORT
THE FILL ENERGY- I BUT- THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. THANK
YOU KAREN NUMBER OF MY NAME'S
JEANNIE MERYL AND THE POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE AND AGRICULTURE NETWORK
THE COALITION OF FORMER LEADERS
AND THE PEOPLE OUR CULTURE
GROUPS WORKING TO ADVANCE OUR
CULTURAL POLLUTION TO CLIMATE
CHANGE. WE ARE PLEASED TO
SUPPORT AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY
FOUR IT'S RECOGNIZES THE NEED
FOR CALIFORNIA TO FINALLY
ADVANCE TO CLIMATE FULL AN
RELATED STRATEGIES FOR BASTIN
IMPORTANT NATURAL WORKING LAND.
I WANTED TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL RAISED
BY MY COLLEAGUES IN
AGRICULTURE- FIRST THERE IS NO
ONE SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH FOR
ALL FARMS EXPECTED ARE LAID OUT
IN AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY FOUR.
WE DO HAVE MODELING FROM THE
STATE AND OTHER RESEARCHERS.
ARE THAT IT'S BEEN ABLE COULD
QUANTIFY THE POTENTIAL FOR
INCREASED CARBON SEQUESTRATION
FROM AGRICULTURE. BASED ON THE
BIRTHDAY FARM MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES. AND I THOUGHT ****
THERE WILL BE NOT THEY'LL BE
NECESSARY TO HAVE A VARIETY OF
PATHS FORWARD TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
INCREASED CARBON THINK FONG
FARM. AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY FOUR
DOES NOTHING TO TAKE AWAY THAT
FLEXIBILITY AND DIVERSITY OF
APPROACH MANY PROGRAMS ARE
CERTAINLY UP IN THE AIR AS THE
STATE GRAPPLED WITH THE
FINANCIAL IMPACT OF THE COPA
NINETEEN CRISIS. WE DON'T KNOW
WHETHER OR NOT THE STATE WILL
CONTINUE TO USE THE GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTIONS FUND TO SUPPORT
CLAIM IT'S MORE LIKE A CULTURE
PROGRAMS WE WILL CERTAINLY
ADVOCATE THAT THANK YOU. BUT
REGARDLESS OF SHORT TERM BUDGET
DEFICIT AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY
FOUR HAS A LONGER TERM VIEW OF
WHAT IS NECESSARY TO HELP THE
STATE ACHIEVED AT TWENTY FORTY
FIVE CARBON NEUTRALITY GOAL.
UNDERSTANDING THE POTENTIAL OF
NATURAL WORKING WITH TO HELP
MEET OUR CLINICAL THIS CRITICAL
TO THAT TWENTY FOUR FORTY FIVE
W. TROUT EFFORT. AND SHOT
SHOULD NOT I NEED FIRE
IMMEDIATE CRISIS. FURTHERMORE
NOTHING IN A TWENTY FIFTY FOR
THE WHAT ARE THIS TO IMPOSE
REGULAR. ON TO LIMIT OR CHANGE
THE TYPE OF CROPS. GROWN IN THE
STATE. OF THE BILL SIMPLY
STATES THAT THERE RESOURCES FOR
IDENTIFIER CLINICAL AND INCLUDE
NATURAL WORKING LAND IN THE
LATEST COPING PLANS DURING THE
PANDEMIC WE HAVE MORE FARMERS
THAN EVER BEFORE SIGNING UP FOR
THE HEALTHY SOILS PROGRAM OF A
LANDMARK PLANS FOR ACT. GRAHAM
HE HAS REACHED. OVER A FOR
HUNDRED TO SIXTY HEALTHY SOIL
APPLICATION WAS FEBRUARY. AND
THAT'S UNPRECEDENTED- AB TWENTY
NINE FIFTY FOUR WILL ALLOW THE
STATE TO UNDERSTAND THE
OPPORTUNITIES TO SCALE UP THIS
WORKING MEANINGFUL WAYS. AND
FARMWORKERS DEMONSTRATING
TODAY- EVEN DURING UNCERTAIN
TIMES BUT THEY WANT THE STATE
CLIMATE EFFORTS TO CONTINUE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYBODY IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
WISHING TO VOICE THEIR SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL. SEEING NONE NOT A
MODERATOR COULD YOU PLEASE KEEP
THE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. IF YOU WISH TO SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN FOLLOWED
BY ZERO IT WILL GIVE IN JUST A
MOMENT. WE DO HAVE ONE ACTUALLY
WE HAVE THREE THAT CUED UP
RIGHT NOW AND WE HAVE A FEW
MORE TAT ARE QUEUING UP OKAY
PLEASE. WHEN YOU'RE READY STATE
YOUR NAME AND WHERE YOU'RE
CALLING FROM. AND LINE EIGHTY
TO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
THAT THIS RECALL MONSTER TO NOT
A WITH THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC
LAND I'M NOT GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
DIRECTOR- WE ARE FULLY SUPPORT
THE BILL- WE ARE PRACTITIONERS
OF. PROJECT THAT- CREATE
INTERVENTION- IN THE URBAN
LANDSCAPE TO HELP PREPARE FOR-
THE IMPACT OF CLIMATE CHANGE
AND HELP TO THE ASA QUEST YOUR
CARBON YOU THINK IT'S
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT TO HAVE. A
STEP GOALS TO ACHIEVE GOALS AND
ONE AFFECT THE AUTHOR AND-
DURABLE. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER.
LINE ONE OR TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THE
GYM LOOK AT SPARKS NORMALLY ON-BEHALF OF THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY- BUT I'M ACTUALLY
ALSO TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
SUITE OF OTHER ENVIRONMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS THAT SUPPORT THE
BILL INCLUDING THE CALIFORNIA
LEGAL CONSERVATION ORDER
SPECIFIC FOR STRAT ENERGY UNDER
THE WILDLIFE THE CLIMATE CENTER
AUDUBON CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
RELEASED. IN A LAND TRUST THANK
YOU SO MUCH THE AUTHOR AND
MEMBERS THREE CONSIDERATIONS.
REPORT LEGISLATION HAVE A GREAT
DAY. THANK YOU NEXT CALL AND
LINE ONE OF THREE. SURE MY
MOTHER PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M NOT
LACKEY I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
MADNESS THAT WHICH IS NOT OPEN
IT'S JUST YET CALIFORNIA
HABITAT CONSERVATION AND I
COALITION. IN CALIFORNIA FIFTY
BROKEN CORPS IN THE RAPIDLY IN
COURT I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR OR- STUFF. THANK YOU ARE
THERE ANY OTHER CLAIM ONE UP ON.
WE DO HAVE THREE MORE IN THE
NEXT ONE IS FROM LINE ONE OH
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. CHECK
BEEN RATHER REGISTERING STRONG
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF. YOU TO
CHANGE THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND
NINE ONE TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS PRETTY BAD AT THE
ON BEHALF OF HERE BUSINESS
COUNCIL AND THE FEAR CONSORTIUM
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO REGISTER
OUR STRONG SUPPORT. AND NINE
ONE OH NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BUT MARKET ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN FARMLAND TRACKED WHILE
FARM ALLIANCE CENTER FOR FOOD
SAFETY OCCIDENTAL ARE IN A
QUALITY CENTER EAGLE FARM AND
THE CALIFORNIA CERTIFIED
ORGANIC FARMERS THANK YOU. NO
FURTHER IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU AND NOW I
BELIEVE WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION IF WE CAN QUEUE
UP THE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
TO MINUTES APIECE PLEASE. YOUR
LINES ARE OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS BILLION WILL PERFORM
WITH THE CALIFORNIA KEEPER
COMMERCE. HE INTENDS TO BE OFF
OF THEM AND FOR THE VERY
IMPORTANT DISCUSSION OF GLOBAL
HEALTH. ABSOLUTELY AND INTO IN
OUR HAVING YOUR CHILD CALL. ARE
CONCERNED THAT WE IN OPPOSED.
THAN FROM THE LARGER A OF HOW
WE DEFINE MEASURE AND REACH
THOSE GOALS. AND AS AN INITIAL
DISCUSS. BUT CARBON. OVER WILL
BE ON IT LIKE THAT. GOVERNOR
CLINTON SAID IN A GOAL CARBON
BY TWENTY CORD FIVE AND
ADMINISTRATION WE GOT WORKS TO
EVALUATE WHAT THAT CAN AND
SHOULD MEET. THIS BILL WILL BE
THE FIRST TIME THE LEGISLATURE
HAD SPOKEN ON THE BIG IMPORTANT
ISSUE OF CARBON NEUTRALITY. AND
WILL MEMORIALIZED IN THE BACK
YOU DIRECTED THAT WHETHER
INTENTIONAL OR NOT FOR THE
MARKET TO REACT. WITH FEAR THE
LEGISLATIVE MANDATE OF GOAL
SETTING FOR THE AGRICULTURAL
WORKING WENT FACTORED BEFORE AN
ECONOMY LIKE WHITE CARBON
NEUTRALITY GOAL IS EVALUATED
AND FLUSHED OUT BY THE
LEGISLATURE WILL SPEND BIG OPEN
THE MARKET THE CALIFORNIA. THE
FOCUS HEAVILY ON IT
AGRICULTURAL WORKING WENT BACK
A CARBON EMISSION NOTED BY THE
IN ALPHABETICAL FIVE ONLY 9% OF
GLOBAL. EMISSIONS RATHER THAN
ENGAGING. ALL FACTORED. CARPET
AND SEQUESTRATION. WE REALIZE.
THAT WE INTEND TO BE ALL AND
THEREFORE WE ARE TOO MUCH BUT
YOU'RE- THAT CAUTION. IN
ADVANCE THE INDUSTRY THE GOAL
PRIOR TO THE CAR NEUTRAL
DISCUSS. WHEN OUR MANY FAT.
INDUSTRY AND IN THAT INTO THAT
BUT CARD. IN WE CAN INSURE WIN
THE LEGISLATURE HAS THE ABILITY
AT TO A GREAT. BIG GOAL I GOT
TO MEET THEM LOOK AT HOW THE-
WANTS THE THAT WOULD BE
PROBABLY CALL THE BORDER. IN A
MATTER OF NATURE THE
APPROPRIATE AND I'M OPERATE FOR
CALIFORNIA PROVIDERS. WELL
ABOUT WAITING THAT IN. BOB ABLE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WITH
PLEASE. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS DELIVER WITH
THE FARM BUREAU AT WE WITH IN
THE AFTER AND ARE OPPOSED TO AB
TWENTY NINE FIFTY FOUR BUT WE
AGREED THAT OUR NATIONAL
WORKING LAND MANY ACRES OF WHAT
TERM PRODUCTION AGRICULTURE ARE
THE SOLUTIONS TO CLIMATE CHANGE
AND WE WANT TO PARTICIPATE IN
THAT DISCUSSION BUT WE ALSO
KNOW THAT IF WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE TO BE SUCCESSFUL WE
NEED TO SEE THE WHOLE PICTURE.
OUR CONCERN IS THAT THE BILL
DEVELOP THE PATHWAY OF CREATING
A GOAL AND MEASURING PROGRESS
TOWARDS THAT GOAL- WITH ITEMS
LEFT OUT I'LL GIVE YOU ONE
EXAMPLE IN THE LATEST DRAFT OF
THE NATURAL MARKING LANDS A
COMMENDATION PLAN WHICHWILL
LIKELY BE THE BASIS FOR
DEVELOPING SEQUESTRATION GOAL
IT ONLY PROPOSES TO ACCOUNT FOR
STATE FUNDED THE- PROJECT WELL
THE IS A- INVESTMENT. THAT
LEAVES OUT OF THE PROJECT ARE
BEING DONE WITH FEDERAL.
INCLUDING MILLION. ANY REDUCE
THE A AND R. AN ANY VOLUNTARY
PER WORK BE YOU CAN SO WE DON'T
THAT SETTING AN IMPORTANT GOAL
AT THIS AND TRACKING WITH
MISSING DATA IS APPROPRIATE I
WE ALSO KNOW THAT OUR FARMERS
AND RANCHERS BY NATURE ARE COST
CONSCIENCE AND LIKE ANY-BUSINESS OWNER THERE IF THEY'RE
GOING TO MAKE INVESTMENTS IF
THEY CAN GET A RETURN ON THAT
INVESTMENT FROM A CORPORATE
PERSPECTIVE IF THE PRACTICE OF
A FARMER RANCHER TO EIGHT. YEAR
OLD OR IMPROVE THE LEAVE THEIR
PRODUCT- IT'S OUR BELIEF THAT
THAT OUR MEMBERS WOULD HAVE
DONE THAT ARE READY AND MAKE
THAT INVESTMENT THIS MEANS SPUR
LAND STEWARDS TO DO EVEN MORE
THAN THEY'RE ALREADY DOING THEY
NEED THEY NEED FINANCIAL
INCENTIVES AND WHILE THE STATE
HAS PROVIDED FUNDS THEY'VE DONE
SO INCONSISTENTLY AND LOOKING
AT THAT POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT
BUDGET DEFICIT WITH TWO YEAR
AND THREE YEAR PROJECTED IMPACT
CONSISTENT AND ADEQUATE FUNDING
WILL LIKELY BE NOTHING IN SHORT
WE ARE CONCERNED THE STATE'S
BUDGET. WON'T MATCH. TEN FOR
WORK OR NOT. TOWARD THE
WELLINGTON. WILL CREATE WONDERS
AND LOSERS. SOME COMMODITIES OR
TYPE AGRICULTURAL OPERATIONS
NATURALLY HAVE A GREATER
CAPACITY TO SUPPORT YOUR CARBON
THAN OTHERS- AN ORCHARD CROP
WITH DEEPER ROOT OVER IT I TEND
MAY DRAW DOWN MORE CARBON THAN
AN ANNUAL CROP. SO GIVEN THAT
SOME FARMS MAY BE ELIGIBLE FOR
INCENTIVE TO WHERE THE OTHERS
ARE NOT. AND MORE SIGNIFICANTLY
SHOULD A FARMER MAKE A DECISION
ON WHAT TO PLANT BASED ON WHAT
DROPPED ON THE MOST CARBON.
RATHER THAN WHAT'S BEST FOR
THEIR LAND OR WHAT THE MARKET
DICTATES. WE'RE GONNA SEE MORE
CONSOLIDATION OF FARMS WE'RE
GOING TO SEE MORE PRESSURE ON
THE SMALL FARMS THAT ARE MAKING
A SPECIALTY ITEMS. AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE WE'RE GOING
TO SEE SOME OFF THE DIVERSITY
THAT MAKES CALIFORNIA
AGRICULTURE. NOBLE AND ADAPTIVE
IN THESE THESE DIFFICULT
CIRCUMSTANCES. SO BASED ON THAT
WE ASK YOU TO CONSIDER CONCERNS
AND TO RESPECT YOUR QUESTION
ABOUT. THE THANK VERY MUCH IS
THERE ANY. IN THE COMMITTEE
WERE WISHING TO VOICE
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION. OKAY
THEN LET'S OPEN THE LINES FOR
OPPOSITION AGAIN PLEASE MAKE
YOURSELF ADD BY HITTING SIX AND
TALK BY HITTING. SIX STAR SIX.
AND ARE JUST YOUR NAME AND
WHERE YOU'RE COMING FROM PLEASE.
THAT A MODERATOR IF YOU CAN
OPEN THE LINE FOR OPPOSITION.
IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
HEY WE DO HAVE SEVERAL IN THE
QUEUE RIGHT NOW AND WE'LL GET
IN JUST A MOMENT.
NINE FIFTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
WILL BE OFFERING BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU. THE COLOR AND LIGHT BY NO
ONE ZERO NINE ONE ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE LAUREN
ONLY PAYCHECK ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA KIND GENEROUS AND
GROWING THAT WE CAN MEET THE
FARMERS WEEK WHAT YOU'RE NOT
PROFIT THERE'S A THAT THE
ASIAN. WHAT YOU'RE CURRENT
HEALTH ASSOCIATION FAR WEST TO
QUIT DEALER CALIFORNIA
FRUSTRATED THAT THE ASIAN
AMERICANS STAFF HERE FOR HOURS.
APPLIQUE AMERICAN FARMERS THE
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION. AND
WE HAVE ONE LAST ONE AND THAT
IS FROM LINE ONE OH FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS GAIL DEL HANNAH WITH
WESTERN GROWERS ASSOCIATION AND
WE ARE IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU
FOR THE COMMENT IF THE STATE.
WAS AT OUR LAST CALLER IN THE
QUEUE. NO FURTHER COMMENTS
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU WILL
NOW GO BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS.
FOR THE AUTHOR. DOCTOR EGGMAN.
THANK YOU NICE TO SEE YOU
MISTER RIVAS. AND I AM A- HUGE
HUGE BELIEVER IN HAVE SEEN A
LOT OF THE REALLY FINE CARBON
SEQUESTRATION PROGRAMS ARE
GOING ON ESPECIALLY ON THE- ON
THE COAST- I'M NOT CAN SUPPORT
THIS BILL TODAY JUST BECAUSE OF
THE- I SHARE A LOT OF THE
CONCERNS FROM THE AGRICULTURE
COMMUNITY. OF JUST YOU KNOW I
MEAN THE AGAIN LIKE MISTER
MULLINS BILL I'M TAKING
EVERYTHING IN THE CONTEXT OF
THE WORLD THAT WE'RE LIVING IN
RIGHT NOW NOT JUST THINGS THAT
ARE GOOD IDEAS- THAT WE ALL
NEED TO DO BUT ALSO WHAT. HOW
HOW WE'RE GONNA LOOK COMING
THROUGH THIS AND SO I KNOW THAT
IN GENERAL THE FOOD PRODUCTION.
ARE DONE HOLE CONNIE IS BILL IS
VERY UNCERTAIN RIGHT NOW WITH A
LOT OF UNCERTAINTIES OUT THERE.
THIS ONE MORE GOOD IDEA BUT
WITHOUT ANY FUNDING AND WITH
THE POSSIBILITY OF THINGS WHEN
THEY ARE BEING AND THEN MAKING
NEW DECISIONS WHEN THERE'S
ALREADY I THINK A LOT OF
CONCERN. ABOUT THE CURRENT-
TRANSPARENCY OF THE PROCESS
ESPECIALLY THROUGH THE PANDEMIC
WE DON'T KNOW HOW LONG IT'S
GONNA LAST. BUT TO ADD ONE MORE
SO WELL I APPRECIATE THE IDEA
AND I- BUT SMETHING WE NEED TO
ADDRESS. I CAN'T SUPPORT THIS
OKAY THANK YOU FOR SHARING THAT
WITH ME. ANY OTHER COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS. YES
AT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PRESENTATION I DO AGREE THAT
WORKING LINE TO SOMETHING THAT
WE NEED TO BE TAKING ADVANTAGE
AND WE HAVE AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
THAT. BEING IMPLEMENTED RIGHT
NOW I GUESS MY ONLY CONCERN
WITH. WITH THE WORKING LAST
SEASON MAKING IT CLEAR THAT
IT'S NOT AND- IN LIEU OF
EMISSION REDUCTIONS IN THAT
NEEDS TO BE OUR PRIORITY- AND
WHEN WE WIN THAT FIGHTENOUGH I
THINK WE NEED TO BE LOOKING AT.
AT EMISSION REDUCTIONS AND THE
TICKET ORDER THAT THE GOVERNOR
DID THIS AND MAKE THAT CLEAR
AND- IT'S NOT CLEAR TO ME IN
YOUR BILL THAT WE HAVE THOSE
FROM ADDRESS ALSO. YES WITH
WITH YOUR SENTIMENT IN YOUR
INTENT AROUND THAT AROUND THAT
WELL I THINK THE INTENT OF THE
BILL OBVIOUSLY IS TO CAPITALIZE
ON A LOT OF WORK THAT HAS
ALREADY OCCURRED YOU KNOW THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT ISN'T NEW-
AND- ALSO SEND I THINK THE- THE
COMMITTEE NOW SAYS DID A GOOD
JOB TO IDENTIFY A LOT OF THE-
DID THESE PEACE. PROGRAM AROUND
ACTUAL WORK AND- YOU KNOW I
APPRECIATE ALL OF THE CONCERNS
I APPRECIATE THE OPPOSITION
AND- BUT NO THIS CERTAINLY THIS
CRISIS IS IN A WAY FOR GOVERNOR
ACT- THE OTHER IS SOMETHING
THAT HAS BEEN. A PRIORITY AND
IS THE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
NEEDS TO PRIORITIZE A SOMETHING
THAT AS THE ANALYSIS YOU
ALLUDED TO. THE CARD IS ALREADY
TAKING TO MAKE THIS OF ALL THE
NEXT COPING PLANET THE
LEGISLATION IS A PRIORITIZE AT
WORK. AND SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE END TO THIS AWESOME VERY
BROAD IN SCOPE IN AND FOCUS.
THE WORKING. YEAH THE CAR.
QUESTION AND- YOU KNOW DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN. TO REVERSE
WHAT THE DATA TELL US THEY NOW
TO WORKING LAN ALL RIGHT NOW.
G. D. G. SO. AND THAT'S EXACTLY.
AND CAN DO BETTER ME. YOU KNOW
THE FOR THAT 9% OF THIS STATE
YOU KNOW THE THAT ALLOW. YEAH
HE- HERE CALIFORNIA INVOLVES
THESE NATIONAL WORKING LANDS.
YOU KNOW I THINK THE FACT THAT.
YOU KNOW- WHAT I APPRECIATE
ABOUT THIS TOPIC ABOUT THIS
ISSUE. IS CERTAINLY WHAT'S
GOING TO WORK IN ONE PART OF
THE STATE IS GOING TO WORK IN
OTHER PARTS TO SAY WHAT'S GOING
TO WORK ON YOU KNOW. THESE
PATHWAYS METHODS ARE GOING TO
WORK ON THE ONE SIDE OF THE
PLANET ARE GONNA WORK ON THE
OTHER SIDE. AND SO THERE'S A
LOT OF RESEARCH THAT HAS BEEN
DONE. SO THERE'S A LOT MORE
RESEARCH THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE.
BUT SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
PRIORITIZE WE KNOW THAT. THIS
THIS EFFORT. TO GO SO FAR AS
OUR DOCTORS ORG AND- I'LL-
WITH. THE LATE TIME TO THE IT.
PORN BUT YOU KNOW I'D BE HAPPY.
WITH YOU. THE ONE. YEAH ANY OF
CONCERNS. I MEAN I I'M GOING TO
BE A PART OF A OF YOUR BILL TO
DATE I JUST IN. REALLY HAS A
TEN AS WE TALK ABOUT PART
CAPTURE IT AN EASY WAY OF
OPENING THE DOOR STUFF THAT
ONLY I MISSION REDUCTIONS
BECOME SECONDARY WHEN I SHOULD
BE PRIMARY INCITEMENT AS WE'RE
DOING THIS WORK AS THE
LEGISLATURE WE'RE GOING TO GO
ABOVE AND BE DONE WITH AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER ORACLE- A. R.
B. SEVENTY PLANNING TO DO. I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
TALK ABOUT THE MODELS
GUARDRAILS AND THAT WE DON'T
LOSE SIGHT OF FOR EMISSION
REDUCTIONS- BECAUSE AT THE END
OF THE COMMISSION REDUCTIONS ON
TO HELP US WITH CARBON TO HELP
US WITH OTHER A PARTICULAR
MATTER THAT ARE PARTICULARLY
POWERFUL AND COMMUNITIES. LIKE
MINE NO I. AT THIS DISCUSSION
CAN. THAT WOULD JUST BE REMISS
IF I DID AND HIGHLIGHT THAT
CONCERN AND THAT NEED TO. TO
DISCUSS THAT WHETHER IT'S A
LANGUAGE OR WHETHER TO AND TEN
AND THIRTY FROM THE INTENT OF
THE OF THE AUTHOR HERE TO THE-
ABSOLUTELY. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONCERN. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBER. MMHM OKAY
MISTER RIVAS WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE- CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
TIME AND THE DISCUSSION AND
REQUEST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
ITEM THANK YOU MANAGER. THANK
YOU AND I DO A HOPING NINE I'M
SHOULD CONFIDENT THAT YOU WILL
CONTINUE THE DISCUSSIONS WITH
THE OPPOSITION. TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT SO-
HOPEFULLY BENEFIT FOR THEM-
GOING FORWARD ABSOLUTE THAT DO
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE BILL.
DO WE HAVE A SECOND. HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND ROLL CALL
PLEASE. A. B. EXCUSE ME AB
TWENTY NINE FIFTY FOUR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
FRIEDMAN HI. FRIEDMAN ALL RIGHT
FLORA FLORA NO CHAO CHAO ALL
RIGHT EGGMAN. ABOUT EGGMAN NOT
VOTING GARCIA HI S. CI THE MON
MATHIS. MATHIS NO MCCARTY
MCCARTY ALRIGHT BRO ROW NO MERE
TUCCI MURATSUCHI AYE STONE.
STONE ALL RIGHT. VOTERS SIXTY
THREE SIXTY THREE THE BILL IS
OUT THANK YOU NEXT WE HAVE AB
TWENTY NINE FIFTY NINE- BY
MISTER CALDERON I BELIEVE IT'S
BEING PRESENTED BY MR MCCARTY.
TERRIBLE WE HAVE A MOTION ON
THE CONSENT AGENDA TO HAVE A
SECOND OKAY WE HAVE A ROLL CALL
ON THE CONSENT AGENDA PLEASE.
OKAY THE CONSENT AGENDA
CONSISTS OF AB TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY SEVEN AND AB THIRTY ONE
SIXTY FOR THE MOTIONS ARE TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WITH CONSENT
RECOMMENDATION. FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN AHRI FLORA. FLORA ALL
RIGHT CHOW. CHOW ALL RIGHT
EGGMAN. EGGMAN ARE AYE GARCIA
GARCIA HI LOW MOAN. MATHIS
MATHIS I MCCARTY HI MCCARTY
ALRIGHT BRO BRO ALL RIGHT
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI AYE STONE.
STONE ALL RIGHT TEN ZERO TEN TO
ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR IS
PASSED. OKAY MISTER MCCARTY
WHENEVER YOU ARE READY YES
THANK YOU I'M HERE TO PRESENT-
THIS MEASURE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALLED AROUND
AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY NINE IN
THE PAST TEN YEARS CALIFORNIA'S
IS DOTTED SEVERAL NEW RECYCLING
LAWS FRANKLY THROUGH THIS
COMMITTEE- RELATE TO THE
RECOVER MATERIALS WHEN WAS IN
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN A. B.
THIRTY THIRTY SIX COOLEY ENABLE
FARMERS TO PRODUCE. AG BY
PRODUCTS TO TRANSFER THESE
MATERIALS DIRECTLY TO OTHER
FARMERS TO BE USE AS ANIMAL
FEED WITHOUT USING THE HAULING
SERVICES OF A SOLID WASTE
FRANCHISE- THESE PROVISIONS CAN
ONLY BE UNDER THE NARROWLY
PRESCRIBED- NEARLY PRESCRIBED
CONDITION UNFORTUNATELY FOR THE
PAST TWO YEARS THE FREIGHT
INDUSTRIAL SOURCES AS MORPHED
WITHIN A. B. THIRTY THIRTY SIX.
MS HAS BEEN MISSING FOR TWO TO
AN INCORRECT CLEANING INCLUDE
SOURCES SUCH AS RESTAURANTS AND
IT'S RESTORE AT THE END INTO
THE INITIAL BILL THIRTY SIX IS
ONLY MEANT TO AT A CERTAIN BY
PRODUCTS FROM AG SOURCES THAT
IT IS CLEAN. NOT ENTER WASTE
STREAM THE PURPOSE THE BILL AND
THE PRIOR BILL WILSON ABLE FARM
TO FARM TRANSFERS OF AG BY
PRODUCTS FROM GROVER TO ANOTHER
FARMER FOR THE USE OF ANIMAL
FEED AT THIS MISTER CLARIFIES
THE PROVISIONS WITHIN THE PRIOR
BILL AB THIRTY THIRTY SIX AND
OFFERS A- FULL LEGISLATIVE. FOR
WHICH INDUSTRIAL GENERATORS OF
SCRAPS MAY SEND THE FOOD BY
PRODUCTS SERVICE ANIMAL FEED.
BUT TESTIFYING WITH TODAY. MARK
THREE LOOK SIR IS AND CLASS. WE
HAVE CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU
MISTER HERE IN PER WOULD YOU
TO. BY TWO MINUTES PLEASE WHO.
I AM SURE MEMBERS OF THE ON
MODEL OR YEAH. SERVICES AND
CHAIRMAN. OF THE CITY OR PRICE.
WE WANT TO MAKE THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THE EXCELLENT NOW. WE
WALKED BY THE SERGEANTS STAFF
HERE. YEAH FOR A LOT OF YEAH.
YEAH READERS OF ONE OF MONEY I
NINE PUBLIC SERVICES WON A
LARGE SCHOOL SOLEMNLY
OPERATIONS IN THE STATE AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS. ALL OF THE
BILL THIRTY SIX. MR COOLEY
COOPER BEING YEAH THIS IS ALSO
A. DONATION FOR LOCAL
FRANCHISING BUT. ON THE
PROCESSING WE WERE VERY. OUR.
THIS BILL. TWENTY NINE. FIVE
THIRTY THIRTY SIX ADDRESSING
THE ISSUE AROUND OF COURSE. AND
WHAT IS WHAT IN THE ALL OF THE-
QUESTION. ONLY. FIVE TWENTY
NINE NINE THE SOURCE ORGANIC
ANIMAL FOR FROM THEIR OP. THAT
IS PATENTLY NOT TRUE TWENTY
NINE FACT I WOULD JUST SUGGEST
THAT YOU- ARE REFER TO PAGE
FOUR OF THE ANALYSIS WHICH
CLEARLY SHOWS THAT THAT'S NOT
THE CASE. TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
NINE IS NOT DESIGNED NOR DOES
THE MEASURE LIMITED ANYWAY. AND
AGRICULTURAL SOURCE FROM
SELLING OR GIVING AWAY ITS
AGRICULTURAL WASTE PRODUCT TO
ANOTHER ENTITY FOR ANOTHER USE
AND THEREFORE NO HARM IS CAUSED.
AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY NINE WILL
ELIMINATE THE CONFUSION
REGARDING HOW TO THIRTY THIRTY
SIX IS INTERPRETED. AND WILL
PROTECT LOCAL FRANCHISE
AGREEMENTS BETWEEN HOLLERS AND
LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES WE WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR WE WANT TO
THANK MR MCCARTY FOR BRINGING
THIS MEASURE BEFORE YOU TODAY.
WE URGE YOUR IPHONE THANK YOU
THANK YOU CLEARLY THERE WAS A
PROBLEM WITH YOUR MICROPHONE SO
IF YOU WANTED TO RESTATE ANY OF
THAT TESTING FOR THE MICROPHONE
SWITCHED ON THAT'S- THAT'S-
PERMISSIBLE THE- LADY. WE ALL
HEARD IT I'M JUST NOT SURE HOW
MUCH OF IT WAS HEARD BY THE
PUBLIC OKAY NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE- OF NOT A MODERATOR IF
YOU CAN QUEUE UP THE NEXT
WITNESS. YOUR OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD I'M SORRY THE WITNESSES
HERE IN PERSON IN THE ROOM. YES
GOOD MORNING SHARE MEMBERS
NIGHTCLUB OPERATOR WASTE. NINE
YOUR FRIEND A LITTLE BIT CRISIS
THE THERE WAS A LOT OF OFFICES
THEY'LL PROBABLY FEDERAL BILL
BECAUSE THAT THAT LEGISLATION
OUT PASSED TWO YEARS AGO EITHER
IN THIRTY THING. WHICH AT THE
TIME WAS INTENDED I'M SORRY
WHAT A MINUTE IS HIS MICROPHONE
ON THIS TIME. LET'S JUST MAKE
SURE. DONE OKAY TIME NOW THANK
YOU YOU CAN CREATE A SORRY
NECROPOLIS OF CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE HERE IN SUPPORT.
AB THIRTY THIRTY SIX WHICH
PASSED A COUPLE YEARS AGO WAS A
VERY NARROWLY CRAFTED BILL THAT
CODIFIED SOMETHING THAT
EXISTING PRACTICE FOR DECADES-
NAMELY- FOOD PROCESSORS SENDING
THEIR BY PRODUCTS TO ANIMAL
FEED IT'S A GREAT THING WE LOVE
IT- IT'S A GREAT FOR RECYCLING
AND TRADITIONALLY AYE MATERIAL.
BEEN PART OF THE SOLID WASTE
STREAM. INTO AB THIRTY THIRTY
SIX JUST CALL BY THAT AND SAID
THAT IF YOU ARE- DISCARDING OF
THESE MATERIALS FROM THE
SOURCES. THEN YOU CAN SEND THEM
TO A THE- A- ANIMAL THE
OPERATION WHETHER OR NOT THAT'S
COVERED IN A FRANCHISE IT WAS
DONE BECAUSE OF A SPECIFIC FOOD
PROCESSOR IN AUTHORS DISTRICT
AND- ULTIMATELY. WAS VERY
NARROWLY CRAFTED SINCE THEN
IT'S BEEN REINTERPRETED- BEYOND
WHAT I THINK ANYBODY HAD
IMAGINED TO MEAN THAT ANYBODY
WHO GENERATES ANY KIND OF FOOD
IS SUDDENLY NO LONGER PART OF
THE US ALWAYS FRANCHISE IS NO
LONGER SUBJECT TO THE LOCAL
CONTROL OF JURISDICTIONS. WHICH
IS- I MEAN FRANKLY. SOMEWHAT
PREPOSTEROUS SINCE THE REASON
WE HAVE ALWAYS FRANCHISES IS TO
DEAL WITH THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
IMPACTS. OF FOOD WASTE AND
OTHER P. TRESSEL MATERIALS THE
FRANCHISE SYSTEMS ALSO THE
BEDROCK OF OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTIONS IN THE RECYCLING
AND WASTE WORLD. WE WOULD NOT
BE ABLE TO HAVE OUR CURRENT
RECYCLING SYSTEM WHATSOEVER IF
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WERE NOT ABLE
TO ISSUE LONG TERM FRANCHISES
FOR THAT MATERIAL SIMILARLY AS
WE ROLL OUT COMPOSTING PROGRAMS
AND ORGANICS PROGRAMS THOSE
CANNOT WORK IF THE FRANCHISE
SYSTEM DOESN'T WORK. AND BEYOND
RECYCLING- THE LOCAL FRANCHISES
HAVE BEEN USED TO ADVANCE CLEAN
AIR REQUIREMENTS FOR FLEETS
LABOR REQUIREMENTS A LOT OF
OTHER THINGS AS WELL- THIS
REALLY SHOULD NOT BE A
CONTROVERSIAL BILL. SINCE THE
INTERPRETATION BEING OFFERED BY
THE OPPOSITION IS WAY BEYOND
WHAT WAS INTENDED ORIGINALLY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DO WE HAVE A- ANY OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO VOICE
THEIR SUPPORT HERE IN THE ROOM.
OKAY SEEING NONE OF THAT A
MODERATOR DID WOULD YOU PLEASE
OPEN THE LINE FOR SUPPORT. IF
YOU WISH TO SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND FOLLOWED BY ZERO
AND WE'LL GET IN JUST A COUPLE
MOMENTS. ON. WE DO HAVE SEVERAL
THAT HAVE TO DUCK DOUBLE GIVE
THEM JUST ANOTHER MOMENT. LINE
ONE EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M SURE MEMBERS STEVE CARLSON
FOR ATHENS SERVICES OUT IN
STRONG SUPPORT. NEXT CALLER.
WE'LL GET IN JUST A MOMENT.
NINE ONE TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS KELLY JENSEN
REPRESENTING RECOLOGY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
NINE FIFTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE CAN YOU CLEAN ENERGY
IN SUPPORT. WE HAVE THREE MORE
THE Q. AND WE'LL GET THEM JUST
ANOTHER MOMENT. LINE ONE TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
TWENTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS GATHER
UP ANYTHING ON BEHALF OF
RETHINK WAKE ME TRUMP THE PART
OF AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY NINE
THANK YOU. LINE ONE TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOR ON A ON
BEHALF OF THE RESOURCE RECOVERY
COALITION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. OUR LAST ONE COMES
FROM MINE AT ONE TWENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JOHN MOFFITT
ON BEHALF OF WASTE MANAGEMENT
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND I
BELIEVE WE DO HAVE SOMEBODY IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM WISHING TO
HAVE VOICED THEIR SUPPORT.
PROVIDE A YOUNG A MAP OF THE
CALIFORNIA NATURAL GAS VEHICLES
COALITION IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SIR ANYBODY ELSE IN
THE ROOM. OKAY LET'S NOW MOVE
TO THE OPPOSITION I BELIEVE
THAT WE HAVE TO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION- IF YOU CAN PLEASE
Q. OF THE WITNESSES NOT A
MODERATOR. BY THEIR OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. A GOOD MORNING AGAIN-
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS TAYLOR
OCEAN WITH A CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU- WHILE WE APPRECIATE THE
WILLINGNESS OF THE FUNDS ARE
NOT THERE TO HERE ARE CONCERNED
WE DO REMAIN OPPOSED AB TWENTY
NINE FIFTY NINE I CALCULATE
THAT PRODUCERS HAVE A LONG
HISTORY OF USING A SIGNIFICANT
AMOUNT OF BY PRODUCTS
TRANSPORTED BY NON FRANCHISED
POLLARD FROM A VARIETY OF
SOURCES FOR ANIMAL FEED- THESE
ARE THINGS LIKE FOR INVEST
BRINES AND GREAT PROMISE NOT
HOLD. PRODUCT FROM NOT
PRODUCTION PLANT AND BAKERY
WASTE ENSURING THAT THE BY
PRODUCTS AVAILABLE AT SEAT FOR
LIVESTOCK HAS HAD MULTIPLE
BANDAGES IT PROVIDES VALUABLE
NATURE DURING ALSO SPECIALLY AT
A TIME WHEN FEED PRICES HAVE
VARIED DRAMATICALLY IT KEEPS-
THESE TYPES OF PRODUCTS OUT OF
LANDFILLS AND AVOID THE NEED TO
EITHER GROW FEET AND- YOU CAN.
RESOURCES IMPORT FEED OFF FOR
HELP I WOULD ARGUE THAT OUR
LIFE SECOND PRODUCERS AND
ALLOWANCES FOR THE DIVERSION-
PROVIDE US WITH. THE ABILITY
TO. GEN RECYCLERS WRECKING
THESE BENEFITS EXISTING LAW
WITH. CRAP TO NAY DRAWN THE
CONDITION. THE BY PRODUCT MONTH
ME IN ORDER TO BE. OUTSIDE
DIFFERENT AT THE REMAINS BUT WE
WERE PURPOSEFUL AND ALLOWING
THEM TO BE FROM A LARGE
UNIVERSE OF COLLECTION SITE. AB
TWENTY NINE FIFTY NINE HOWEVER.
IN THE CHIP AWAY AT THAT LIST
OF ELIGIBLE COLLECTION SITE
EVEN THOSE THAT THAT MEET THE
NARROW CONDITIONS IN THE LAW-
MIDDLE TO REQUIRED THOSE BY
PRODUCT GENERATORS TO BEEN
WORKING WITH DOLLARS FOR
DECADES NOW DO SO UNDER
FRANCHISE AGREEMENTS. WELL THE
SPONSORED CONTENT MAYBE TO
CLARIFY THE LANGUAGE IN THE
BILL AND FORTY FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE ON THE RESULT IN
MORE QUETIONS- THE BILL
PROPOSES TO AT. THE LIMIT THE
AMOUNT OF BY PRODUCT THAT CAN
BE SOURCE FROM OTHER RETAIL
FOOD FACILITIES AT FOR
OPERATIONS ARE BOTH PROCESSING
PRODUCTS AND OFFERING FOOD ON
SITE LATE COMMERCIAL BAKERY.
THIS BILL WOULD MAKE IT UNCLEAR
IF THEY MAKE THE PER PRODUCT
OUTSIDE OF FRENCH AND HAULING
AGREEMENTS. THESE QUESTIONS OF
THE PARK ABILITY WILL CONTINUE
TO PLAY MANY FACILITIES AND
WHAT CONCERNED THAT EITHER. OUT
OF AN ABUNDANCE OF. DO Q.
INCONSISTENT INTERPRETATION OR
BECAUSE OF INCREASED BIRD AND
DIVERTING THESE PRODUCTS FOR
ANIMAL FEED WILL NO LONGER BE A
PRIORITY FOR THE PARTY. AT THE
BY PRODUCT. THE TYPE OF AND
WE'LL PRODUCERS ACCESS TO
IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF ANIMAL
FEED. NINE WHEN. THE MY KEVIN
CASTRO CAL AFTER. ARE RAN AND
GERRY HAVE LOST MARKET
OVERNIGHT. AND THE TO TRY. THAT
MAY OCCUR FOR THIS BILL WILL
EXAGGERATE THOSE PAINS FOR THE
LIVESTOCK INDUSTRY. FOR THESE
REASONS WE OPPOSED FANTASY NINE
AND RESPECT OR QUESTION ABOUT.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU IN OUR
NEXT WITNESS IS HERE IN PERSON
YOU MAY PROCEED. THANK YOU.
I'LL BE ON THE ON THE UP
CALIFORNIA GRAIN FEED BUT ONE
MOMENT LET'S MAKE SURE YOUR
MICROPHONE IS ON LOOK AT. IT'S
ON OKAY DENNIS I'LL BE ON A ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA GRAIN FEED
PACIFIC EGG AND POULTRY
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA EGG
FARMERS. SO THE GHOST RUNNER
DISSOCIATION AND THE ALLMAN
ALLIANCE. HI THIS MEASURES IS
ABOUT ORGANIC RECYCLING. WHEN
FORMER CHAIRPERSON CHILLS
BOROUGH PASSED HIS MEASURE AB
EIGHTEEN TWENTY SIX. THEY HAVE
A GOAL 75% ORGANICS DIVERSION.
REQUIRED ORGANICS TO BE MANAGED
LOCALLY. ONE OF THE MAIN
DISCUSSIONS IN THIS ROOM IN
THIS COMMITTEE WAS HOW DO WE
PROMOTE COLLECTING ORGANICS
THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
TRADITIONALLY RECYCLED. WILL
NOT IMPACTING TRADITIONAL
SECTORS THAT HAVE BEEN
RECYCLING ORGANIC FOR DECADES.
SUCH AS HOLLYWOODLIFE FEED AND
ECONOMIC LAND APPLICATION SO
THAT WAS THE CONVERSATION THAT
WAS HAD. ON THAT BILL WHICH IS
THE VERY. NEXT BOOK REQUIRE.
THIRTY SIX WAS A REAR TO HOLD
FOR LIFE FEED BEING PUT OUT OF
THEIR CON. THEY HAD FOR DECADES
BY THESE NEWLY CREATED
MONOPOLISTIC FRANCHISE
AGREEMENTS THERE WERE
ENCOURAGED BY PREVIOUS
LEGISLATION. ACCORDING TO THE
US EPA HIERARCHY OF FOOD WASTE
FEEDING LIVESTOCK IS A HIGHER
AND BETTER USE THAN HOW THESE
MATERIALS WE CAN HANDLE TO THE
FRANCHISE HOLLERS. IN ADDITION
THE LIVESTOCK FEED DOLLARS HAVE
COMPETITIVE CONTRACTS WHICH ARE
GOOD FOR THE GENERATOR AND GOOD
FOR THE ENVIRONMENT. THIS
MATERIAL HAS BEEN RECYCLED FOR
DECADES THE COMPETITIVE
CONTRACTS THERE WERE NEVER
SUBJECT TO THESE FRANCHISE
AGREEMENTS. ADDITIONALLY THIS
MATERIAL REPLACES. VIRGIN FEED
MATERIAL SUCH AS GRAY AND
ALFALFA. 41% OF A GEHRY RATIONS
17% OF A FULLY WRAPPED PULL
PULL TO RATION OUR FOOD BY
PRODUCTS IF THIS MATERIALS NOT
MADE AVAILABLE THE MOST BY
PRODUCTS MUST BE REPLACED WITH
GRAIN IMPORTER FOR THE MIDWEST
ALFALFA GROWN ON MORE LAND
WATER FERTILIZER INPUTS HERE IN
THE STATE. THAT'S DISCUSS THE
ANALYSIS SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE WHICH IS THE FALL A BILL.
TO MISTER JUST ROSE BILL.
RECENT REQUIRE RECYCLING TO
DIVERT 75% OF THE RIVER ANNEXED
NOT ALREADY RECYCLE. AND THAT'S
THE KEY THE ORGANIC JUST LIKE
THERE WAS A CURRENT ALL OVER
THE STATE- PRIOR TO EIGHT TO
TWENTY SIX. CALPERS REPORT ON
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE-
RESULTING COSTS TO TAXPAYERS
AND RATEPAYERS OF AT LEAST
TWENTY TWO BILLION DOLLARS TO
GET THE INFRASTRUCTURE IN ORDER
EMPLOYMENT THE 75% DIVERSION
RIGHT. SO THE ORGANIC MATERIAL
SUBJECT TO THIS BILL. THAT HAS
ALREADY BEEN GOING TO FEET.
THAT IS IN OUR CYCLE FOR
DECADES IF IT IF THIS IS PASSED
EVERY TIME THAT IS THEN TAKEN
THROUGH A FRANCHISE AGREEMENT
WILL ADD TO THAT TWENTY TWO
BILLION DOLLAR COST TO REPAIR
THE TAXPAYERS. AND FLOOD BUT
THE EXISTING ALREADY TAXED.
INFRASTRUCTURE IF WE USE THIS
STUFF OUTSIDE TOWARDS LIVESTOCK
FEED WE AVOID- THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE OF THE FRANCHISE
AGREEMENTS. OUR CONTRACTS ARE
COMPETITIVE IF YOU CAN IF YOU
CAN YEAH SURE THING THE WASTE
HAULERS CAN DO AND BET ON THEM
AS WELL AND MANY OF THEM DO BID
ON THESE CONTRACTS. HOWEVER
THEY WANT TO PUSH OUT THE
COMPETITION THROUGH LEGISLATION
RATHER THAN THE MARKET PLACE.
AND FINALLY THE CARPORT IS THIS
IS NOT AN URGENCY THERE ISN'T
COVE RELATIONSHIP HERE AND SO
WE WELCOME THE CONVERSATIONAL
HELP GOING TO BE THOSE ARE
CHARACTERS LIKE THAT WE HAVE
MUCH INFRASTRUCTURE OF FULL DE
INCREASED ORGANICS- RECYCLING.
HOWEVER WE THINK THAT THIS
CONVERSATION SHOULD OCCUR IN A
MUCH LARGER COMPETITION HOW
WE'RE GOING TO BE TACKLE THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I
WOULD ASK THE MODERATOR TO
PLEASE ON THE LINE FOR THOSE
WHO ARE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL. IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE DO HAVE ONE THAT CUED
UP AND WE'LL GET IN JUST A
MOMENT.
NINE ONE TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
CHAIR NUMBERED REBEKAH BACK AND
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA AND
BOB THERE'S A LINE IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU. FOR THE
COMMENTS PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU ARE THERE OTHER CALLERS.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER CALLERS. NO
OTHER CALLERS AT THIS TIME
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU IS
THERE ANYBODY IN THE ROOM
WISHING TO VOICE OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL. SEEING NONE I'LL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
MISTER MATHIS. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- I WILL LIGHT ON MY
OPPOSITION SINCE MISTER
CALDERON IS IN HERE- I RESPECT
FOR MY COLLEAGUE WHO I'M SURE
IS IN THIS FIRST IS MISTER
CALDERON WOULD BE ON THIS BILL-
EASY. I LOVE YOU TOO MAN EIGHT
I THINK THAT ON A I UNDERSTAND
THE INTENT OF THIS BILL. BUT IT
IS VERY POORLY TIMED OX
SPECIALLY WITH THE CURRENT
MARKETS WITHIN AGRICULTURE-
WE'RE GOING INTO THE
DISCUSSIONS OF MEAT RATIONING
AND OTHER THINGS RIGHT NOW I
THINK ANY- ADDED REGULATIONS-%
PUT ON THE INDUSTRY. DEALING
GETTING INTO FEET STOCKING AND
ANY OF THESE THINGS WE- AS
MENTIONED IN THE TESTIMONY
THERE'S ALREADY A LOT OF
ORGANIC RECYCLING ALREADY
HAPPENING- IN FOLKS THIS ISN'T
JUST A CALIFORNIA THING THIS IS
NATIONWIDE I AM ON A WEEKLY
CONFERENCE CALLS. ARMED WITH.
DIFFERENT AGRICULTURAL GROUPS
DEALING WITH WHAT IS GOING ON
DURING THIS PANDEMIC AND IT'S
NOT JUST CALIFORNIA THAT
THIRTEEN IT'S NATIONALLY IT'S
INTERNATIONALLY WE'RE DEALING
WITH A POSSIBLE FOOD SHORTAGE
HERE AND PUTTING ANYTHING IN
THE WAY OF. FOOD PRODUCTION AND
CAUSING ANY ADDED INCREASED AT
THIS TIME ISN'T GOING TO HELP-
ESPECIALLY WHEN WE ALREADY
BEFORE THIS HAD ONE IN FIVE
KIDS GOING HUNGRY EVERY NIGHT
IN OUR FOOD BANKS ARE DEALING
WITH SHORTAGES AS WELL- MEMBERS
I ASK YOU TO EITHER VOTE NO OR
OF STAND ON THIS SO WE CAN KEEP
FOOD PRODUCTION AT THE
FOREFRONT- INNKEEPER PEOPLE
FED. ESPECIALLY DURING THIS
TIME A PANDEMIC THANK YOU THANK
YOU OTHER COMMENTS DR EGGMAN.
THANK YOU AND. I ALSO WON'T
QUESTION ME TOO DEEPLY MISS
MCCARTY ALTHOUGH I'M SURE YOU
ARE VERY WELL VERSED BUT I JUST
WANT TO MAKE A STATEMENT THAT I
WOULD NOT BE SUPPORTING THIS
BILL TODAY THE ISSUE THAT
CAUSES THE BIGGEST- HARPER AND
IS LIKE THE OTHER RETAIL FOOD
ESTABLISHMENTS RIGHT SO THERE'S
LIKE BROUGH POPS OUT WINERIES
THINGS LIKE THAT THAT HAVE A
LOT OF WASTED THAT GOES FOR
FEED STOCK RIGHT NOW. SO WHY
NOT MAKE THAT EXPLICIT IN HERE
SO THERE'S I THINK THERE'S ROOM
TO WORK IN A LOOK FORTY MAYBE
SUPPORTING THIS LATER BUT
INTELLIGENCE TIGHTENED UP SO
THIS MISTER AT MATHIS POINTED
OUT IT DOESN'T AFFECT THE
FEEDSTOCK WITH I MEAN. EVEN IF
IT'S COMPOST. THIS IS LAND
FILL. GOING TO FEED- STOCK
RIGHT NOW THAT IS CURRENTLY IN
EXISTENCE SHOULD BE THE
PRIORITY PEOPLE ANIMALS
COMPOST- SO INTO SOME OF THOSE
THINGS I THINK ARE MORE CLEARLY
DEFINED. I WILL BE ABLE SUPPORT
THIS BILL. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WISHING TO
MAKE A COMMENT. SURE. WE ARE
LIVE IN AND- BECAUSE THAT THAT
THE TIME SAID THAT DEALING WITH
THE CALL OF IT IT STARTS FROM
LONG TERM REALITY IS SOMETHING
THAT WE NEED TO PRIORITIZE BUT
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
DON'T USE THAT AS AN EXCUSE NOT
TO DO ANY OF OUR OTHER WORK-
AND THAT WE WOULD FIND A WAY TO
MULTI TASK- WERE WORTH UP
APPROPRIATE I WAS HERE WHEN WE
DID THE COOLEY BILL- AND WAS.
AROUND WHEN WHAT THE INTENT WAS
IN THE DEAL LESS THAN- I DO
THINK THAT THERE'S SOME
CLARIFICATION THAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE IN THIS BILL AND I DO
THINK THAT THERE'S A SPACE FOR
THE OPPOSITION AND THE OTHER TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON WHAT THAT
FACE MIGHT BE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE HONORING A DEAL THAT WAS
MADE BEFORE INSTALL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL A I JUST
ENCOURAGE US TO CONTINUE TO
WORK AT THE TABLE ON THE SAME
WAY YOU WORK COLLABORATIVELY
NEEDED THE COOLEY BILL A FEW
YEARS BACK. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE CA
MEMBERS. MR MCCARTY FEEL LIKE
TO RESPOND YEAH THAT THANK YOU
OBVIOUSLY I'M NOT IN THE WEEDS
AS MUCH AS SOMEONE MEMBER
CALDERON IS ON THIS BUT JUST
FROM THE BIG PICTURE AND HAVING
SERVED ON THIS COMMITTEE FOR IT
AT THE NUMBER OF YEARS. JUST
LIKE AND I RESPECT WHAT MISTER
MATHIS TALKED ABOUT THAT THE
FRAGILE ECONOMICS OF THE OF THE
AG INDUSTRY THE SAME THING WITH
THE SOLID WASTE INDUSTRY IN
THESE FRANCHISE AGREEMENTS ARE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT AND
TEARING TO MAKE IN PENCIL OUT
OR NOT BEEN SOUGHT SPECIALLY
CUTE WHO COME FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. NO THAT AND THESE
PIECES ARE IMPORTANT FOR THEM
TO CANCEL OUT BUT ALSO FOR US
TO ACHIEVE OUR DIVERSION-
POLICIES WHICH WE'VE BEEN.
WORKING REALLY HARD TO ACHIEVE-
LAST TEN YEARS AFTER THE- CHEST
FOR A BILL SO- WITH THAT- BACK
CERTAINLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE AND
I'M CERTAIN THAT MISTER
CALDERON WILL TAKE YOU UP ON
YOUR SUGGESTION SOMEONE MEMBER
EGGMAN AND TRY TO FIND. A
BETTER BALANCE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU- I WILL SAY WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH THE I'M AUTHOR ON
THIS BILL AND WE BELIEVE THAT-
WE APPRECIATE THE CONCERNS OF
THE OPPOSITION BUT WE BELIEVE
THAT IT ACTUALLY DOES NOT
CHANGE. OF THE- HANDLING FROM
THE INDUSTRIAL SOURCES LIKE
FOOD PRODUCTION- I DO THINK
THERE'S A LOT MORE- COMMON
GROUND. BETWEEN THE OPPOSITION
AND THE SUPPORTERS. THEN THEY
SEEM TO THINK THERE IS AND I
HOPE THAT THEY CONTINUE TO
WORK- ON THIS BILL AS IT MOVES
TO THE SENATE. TO THE
OPPOSITION CAN BE REMOVED. WE
HAVE A MOTION ON THIS BILL THE
SECOND. WITH A MOTION TO HAVE A
SECOND. YOUR MOTION AND A
SECOND ROLL CALL PLEASE. AB
TWENTY NINE FIFTY NINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS. FRIEDMAN HI
ALL RIGHT FRIEDMAN I FLORA.
FLORA NO CHAO. JOE HI EGGMAN
HOW VOTING EGGMAN NOT VOTING
GARCIA GARCIA HI. RAMON MATHIS
THE OFFICE NO MCCARTY PARTY HI.
BRO ROAD NOT VOTING HERE TO
CHECK- TO GI. STONE STONE ARE.
SIXTY TWO SIXTY TWO THE BILL IS
OUT THANK YOU NEXT WE HAVE AB
THIRTY THIRTY BY MISTER KALRA.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
FOR ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT SOME
BILL THIRTY THIRTY- AND I'D
LIKE TO OPEN BY BRIEFLY
ADDRESSING RECENT AMENDMENTS TO
THE BILL- THE LANGUAGE THAT WAS
SUBMITTED TO A LEGISLATIVE
COUNSEL. WAS INADVERTENTLY
CHANGE BEFORE THE COMMITTEE
DEADLINE THE INCLUSION OF THE
WORD SHALL. AND HOW THE THIRTY
BY THIRTY GOAL BE IMPLEMENTED
AS CRITICISM CONCERNS OF THIS
BILL IS CREATING A GREATER
MANDATE THEM WITH THE BILL'S
SPONSORS AND I INTENDED. AB
THREE THIRTY WAS CRAFTED TO
ALIGN WITH EXISTING
REQUIREMENTS AND AGENCY
PROCESSES SUCH AS THE CURRENT
BY DIVERSITY INITIATIVE AND I
WANT TO MAKE CLEAR THAT WILL
WORK WITH CONCERNED PARTIES TO
ADDRESS. THAT ISSUE AND AMEND
THE LANGUAGE A PROPERLY IN
APPROPRIATIONS- AB THIRTY
THIRTY CREATES A SET OF GOALS
AND PRINCIPLES FOR CALIFORNIA
TO DO ITS PART IN REVERSING THE
WORLD WIDE BIODIVERSITY IN
CHINA CRISES BY. ADOPTING THE
GOAL PROTECTING 30% OF OUR
LANDS WATERS AND OCEANS FOR
CONSERVATION BY TWENTY THIRTY.
THIRTY BY THIRTY. BY DOING SO
CALIFORNIA WILL BE JOINING
FACILITATED COURTED A GLOBAL
CALLED ACTION NOT ONLY AMONG
GOVERNMENTS BUT ALSO. AMONG
COMPANIES CITIES AND CITIZENS.
THIS BILL PLACES AND A STATE
POLICY COMMITMENT TO WORKING
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
LOCAL COMMUNITIES NOTED NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBES AND PRIVATE
LANDOWNERS TO CONSERVE NATURAL
PLACES AND RESOURCES.
PROTECTING 30% DOESN'T JUST
MEAN MAKING MORE PARKS IN
REMOTE CORNERS OF OUR STATE. IT
ALSO MEANS IMPROVING ACCESS TO
NATURE. FOR ALL PEOPLE IN THE
STATE INCLUDING FOR COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR AND ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AND
THIS BILL COMMITS THE STATE TO
DO JUST THAT. AND WE CANNOT
WAIT UNTIL NEXT YEAR OR THE
YEAR AFTER- AFTER THAT TO MAKE
THESE COMMITMENTS. THIS ISSUE
AS WE ALL KNOW IS PRESSING IN
FACT THE CURRENT CRISIS
EXACERBATES THE NEED FOR US TO
MOVE QUICKLY. IN PRESERVING OUR
LANDS AND WATERS. LEADING
SCIENTISTS HAVE CONCLUDED THAT
PROTECTING 30% OF ALL LANDS
WATERS AND OCEAN HABITATS IS
THE BARE MINIMUM. NEEDED IN
ORDER FOR US TO SAFEGUARD CLEAN
AIR. CLEAN DRINKING WATER AND
FOOD CHAINS THE SUPPORT ALL
LIFE ON EARTH. BY PURSUING
THESE AMBITIOUS BUT ACHIEVABLE
CONSERVATION GOALS WE CAN STILL
PREVENTIVA JORDIE OF ANIMALS
AND PLANTS FROM GOING EXTINCT.
AND CUT BIODIVERSITY LOSS IN
HALF. WHICH WILL INCREASE THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT WE CAN PRESERVE
THE INTEGRITY OF EXISTING
ECOSYSTEMS. WITHOUT ENOUGH OF
NATURE PROTECTED WE WILL LOSE
MANY OF THE SERVICES THAT
PROVIDE THE FOUNDATION FOR OUR
SOCIETY. AND RISK THE LOSS OR
DETERIORATION OF OUR FINITE
RESOURCES AND STABLE CLIMATE.
AS CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH AND
ECONOMIC SYSTEMS ARE CHALLENGED
BY THE CLOVER NINETEEN GLOBAL
PANDEMIC. WHICH LIKELY WAS
SPREAD FROM ANIMALS TO HUMANS
AS A RESULT OF HABITAT LOSS OF
OVER EXPLOITATION. THE EFFECT
OF THE BIODIVERSITY CRISIS IN
PEOPLE IS MORE PRONOUNCED THAN
EVER. WE NEED TO PROTECT MORE
OF NATURE AND THE MOST
IMPORTANT TOOL AT OUR DISPOSAL
IS CREATING PROTECTED AREAS.
BUILDING ON PASS LEADERSHIP THE
STATUTORY COMMITMENT FROM
CALIFORNIA PROTECTORATE
PRESENTED OF 30% OF OUR LANDS
AND WATERS IN THE NEXT DECADE.
WILL HELP ENSURE THAT WILDLIFE
COTRIVED THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
CAN ENJOY THE BENEFITS AN H.
PROVIDES. AND THAT WILD AREAS
CONTINUE TO ENHANCE THE
STRENGTH INVOLVED BILLING
BEING. OF OUR STATE AND THE
PLANET. BUT MADAM SURE VOTE
WITH ME- VIRTUALLY UP TO
PRESENT TESTIMONY ANSWER
QUESTIONS. OR PAMELA FLICK THE
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE AND MARCY
GOOD HERE IS GRODIN'S OF AS
SOON. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- I
WOULD ASK THE MODERATOR TO
PLEASE KEEP THE WITNESSES SOME
WITNESSES TWO MINUTES A PIECE.
WHEN THE LINES ARE OPEN. THANK
YOU GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS PAMELA FLICK AND THE
CALIFORNIA PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE WHICH IS
THE NATIONAL CONSERVATION
ORGANIZATION DEDICATED TO THE
PROTECTION A CALL BY A
DIVERSITY WE HAVE MORE THAN ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION MEMBERS WHO
ORDERS NATIONWIDE INCLUDING TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY NINE
THOUSAND HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
DEFENDER STRONGLY SUPPORT AT
THIRTY THIRTY BECAUSE IT WOULD
INCREASE PROTECTION OF
CALIFORNIA'S UNPARALLELED
BIODIVERSITY WITH THE CREATION
OF A THIRTY BY THIRTY STATE
POLICY THE BILL COMES AT A
CRITICAL TIME MAKE YOUR AROUND
THE WORLD IS IN A STATE OF
CRISIS WHICH THREATENS OUR
PLANET IN HUMANITY.
APPROXIMATELY ONE MILLION PLANT
AND ANIMAL SPECIES ARE
THREATENED WITH EXTINCTION OVER
THE COMING DECADES AT THE
GLOBALLY SIGNIFICANT
BIODIVERSITY HOTSPOTS WITH AN
EXCEPTIONAL CONCENTRATION OF
PHOEBE FOUND NOWHERE ELSE ON
EARTH CALIFORNIA HAS MUCH TO
WITH. AT LEAST SIX HUNDRED IN
EACH OF OUR SPECIES ARE AT RISK
THE RISK OF EXTINCTION AND TWO
THIRDS OF THE STATE NEED A PLAN
WILL BE TO LOOK AT THEIR RANGE.
WITHIN THE NEXT CENTURY. THE
CURRENT PANDEMIC UNDERS. THAT
PROTECTION OF PRICE IN. BECAUSE
THE TEN IT COULD BE CRITICAL
TO. HEALTH IS EITHER THANK YOU
HOPE IT NOW. RESULT HUMAN
WILDLIFE INTERACTION AND FROM
HUMAN ENCROACHMENT ON WILDLIFE
HABITAT. THE PICNIC WE CAN'T
BODY OF SCIENTIFIC RESEARCH
THAT SHOWS PROMOTING. PEOPLE
PROTECTING MORE OPEN SPACE AND
PRESERVING BIODIVERSITY PROTECT
THAT BY REDUCING THE SPREAD OF
THESE KINDS OF DISEASES.
FOLLOWING THE IMPACT OF CLIMATE
CHANGE AND IMPROVING AIR AND
WATER QUALITY. EIGHTY THIRTY
THIRTY BUILT ON AN IMPORTANT
MOVEMENT FOR GLOBAL ACTION.
FIND HIS INTERNATIONAL AND
NATIONAL LEADERS ARE CALLING
FOR A WORLDWIDE GOAL TO PROTECT
AT LEAST 30% OF THE PLANET BY
TWENTY THIRTY. AND ARE WORKING
TOWARDS HAVING ONE HUNDRED
COUNTRIES THE COURT THE THIRTY
BY THIRTY GOAL BY THE TIME YOU
AND ME AT THE CONVENTION ON
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY NEXT YEAR.
CALIFORNIA IS ALREADY A LEADER
IN PROTECTING BIODIVERSITY WITH
APPROXIMATELY 22% OF THE PLANS.
LAND AREA IN PROTECTED STATUS.
BUT SOME OF OUR MOST DIVERSE
AREAS WHICH PROVIDE ECOSYSTEM
SERVICES LIKE IF YOU'D
BUFFERING POLLINATION WATER
FILTRATION AND CARBON
SEQUESTRATION CRITICAL TO
CALIFORNIANS REMAIN
UNPROTECTED. WE MUST SET A GOAL
OF THIRTY BY THIRTY WHICH WE
CAN ACHIEVE THREE WEEKS THE
THING LITTLE. TO PROTECT
BIODIVERSITY AND ALL THAT IT
PROVIDES US. WITH EIGHTY THIRTY
THIRTY CALIFORNIA WILL CONTINUE
TO LEAD THE WAY TOWARD MEETING
IT'S IMPORTANT CONSERVATION
GOAL AND SET AN EXAMPLE FOR THE
REST OF THE COUNTRY AND INDEED
THE WORLD. FOR THESE REASONS. I
THANK YOU. THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYBODY. IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
WE SHOULD TO THE VOICE SUPPORT
FOR THIS BILL IF SO PLEASE
RAISE YOUR HAND IN. HELLO YES
HELLO. I MIGHT GET A GALLON IT
WAS NOT I'M SORRY WAS THERE
ANOTHER WITNESS ON THE PHONE GO
GO RIGHT AHEAD I'M SORRY YEAH
PARDON. IF YOU. ARE ONE OF THE
OTHER MANCHAIR- COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY NAME MATCH THAN GET
A VALENTINE THE FOUNDER AND
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE SUIT
FOR AN ORGANIZATION WORKING
WITH UNIX COMMUNITY OUR SERVER
COSTS AND NOTION BEFORE THAT. I
WAS THE OPERATIONS MANAGER FOR
THE NBA GO COMMERCIAL SEE COULD
NOT QUIT YOUR COMPANY. THAT
EXACT AREAS ACTUALLY PROMPTED
ME TO JOIN THE CONSERVATION
MOVE IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHT.
BECAUSE THE CHANGES THAT I
THOUGHT FIRSTHAND SPECIFICALLY
IN OVERFISHING AND POLLUTION.
LET ME TO THEIR THINK THAT AS
USUAL WAS OF PEOPLE. FORWARD
FROM EITHER IN INDUSTRY ARE
CONSERVATION. I TOLD TO
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB THIRTY
THIRTY IN A THANKFUL TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA FOR CARE
UNITS FOR LEGISLATION. AS WE
COME BACK WITH MODIFIED HEARING
IT IS IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER
THAT WE ARE ALSO IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE CRISIS IN NATURE WITH
FIVE DIVERSITY LOBBY FIND
CHANGE. THE SAME BECAUSE OF
SOMETHING BEING THERE'S A
TENSION ARE CRITICAL HUMAN
HEALTH AND PRESERVING THEM. MAY
HELP PREVENT FUTURE STORE NOT A
PANDEMIC. THIS ADULT. JUST HOW
MUCH SPENDING TIME IN NATURE
POSITIVELY IMPACT OUR HEALTH
THE WILL BE. AN THROUGH THESE
YOUR GRAPHICAL NECESSARY TO
PRACTICAL CONSTRAINTS IT'S
EASIER TO SEE HOW ENACT. ON
EQUITABLE ARE ACCESS IN THE
TRUTH. MAJORS NOT ON MONDAY IT
IS ESSENTIAL TO OUR WILL BE.
FOR TOO LONG COST AND IMPACT OF
NATURAL RESOURCES EXTRACTION
AND POLLUTION HAVE FALLEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY YOUNG LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES AND
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR IN THE U.
S. THE PURSUIT OF A THIRTY BY
THIRTY GOAL MUST ADDRESS WITH
LEGACY IN YOGA MORE EQUITABLE
DISTRIBUTION OF NATURE'S
BENEFITS. TO ALL PEOPLE. SHE
THIS CALL IS A FEASIBLE MORE
THE ALL FOR CALIFORNIA IN ONE
THAT WORK REINFORCERS. OF THE
GLOBAL CONTRIBUTION LEADER AND
PROVIDE AN IMPORTANT EXAMPLE TO
THE WORLD AS WE MOVE ON TO THE
U. ONE BIODIVERSITY CONFERENCE
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE. BERNIE
OUR OCEANS ARE QUITE THAT
OTHERS ALTER CLIMATE CHANGE THE
OCEAN IS NOW HIGHER WARMER MORE
ACIDIC WHAT MORE HEAT WAVE.
LIKE OXYGEN LESS PRODUCTIVE AND
LESS PREDICT THE- IN SOME WAYS
OCEANS ARE BEING AFFECT BY CON
THE CHANGE. AFTER THAN
PERESTROIKA TO. PROTECTING
AREAS WILL HELP THE MOUTH WILL
HELP MAKE WATERS NOTIONS
MORTALITY IN THE CLIMATE CHANGE
BY REMOVING OTHER EAGER
INSTRUCTORS LIKE EXPLOITATION.
AND POLLUTION. CALIFORNIA HAS
BEEN A LEADER IN TURNING THE
WORLD'S ATTENTION THE CRITICAL
IMPORTANT ROLE OCEANS PLAY IN
RESPONDING I'M- AB THIRTY
THIRTY CONTINUES CALIFORNIA'S
LEGACY OF THE GLOBAL LEADER
CONSERVATION AND INNOVATION.
FOR THE TREATMENT HIGHER CHEER
I THOUGHT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
AND NOW A META MODERATOR IF YOU
COULD PLEASE OPEN THE LINE FOR
SUPPORTERS. YOU ARE AT THE POOR
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME AND
SUPPORTERS PLEASE MAKE SURE
THAT YOU ARE JUST STATING YOUR
NAME AND ANY ORGANIZATION AND
THAT YOU'RE IN SUPPORT. I
ORDERED ONLINE EIGHTY TWO. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
RECALL MONSTER TO NOT A WITH
THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND IN
SUPPORT. TAX WILL BE A LINE A
ONE THIRTY SEVEN. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR NUMBERS NINE AND
IT'S BEEN SQUARE A MANAGER WITH
THE LIGHTNING GROUP HERE ON
BEHALF OF NEXT AND CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT. SO ABOUT ONLINE ONE
THIRTY FIVE. MY NAME IS NATALIE
MARK THEM UP HERE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA HABITAT CONSERVATION
PLANNING SUPPORT. NEXT WE WILL
BOTTOM LINE ONE HUNDRED. HI
THIS IS DEANNA WOLFE THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
UNITED PARKS AND I AM JUST-
ISSUING MY SUPPORT GREAT GREAT
BILL. NEXT BILL BUT A LINE ONE
THIRTY SIX. CHENEY GO HERE TO
REGISTER IF THE PARK RIGHT
NUMBER OF ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING A LOT OF ON
CALIFORNIA AT THE CALIFORNIA
NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY CALIFORNIA
REALLY ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE
FUND CALIFORNIA LEGAL
CONSERVATION VOTERS THREE
FIFTIES ALL KIND OF ALLEY HERE
BOB MOUNTAIN LION FOUNDATION
MONO LAKE MAYBE CLEAN WATER
ACTION PLANNING CONSERVATION
LEAGUE. ENVIRONMENT HEAL THE
BAY FIND IT CENTER NATIONAL
PARK ON PROBATION INVESTIGATION
PLASTIC POLLUTION COALITION THE
CENTER FOR THE ATTIC AWARENESS
AND RESEARCH AND EDUCATION FIVE
TIRED IF YOU SEVENTH GENERATION
ADVISORS. CALIFORNIA COASTAL
PROTECTION AT WORK LOOKING AT
AT AND FRIENDS NINETY ON
LEGISLATION THANK YOU. NEXT WE
WILL BOTH A LINE OF ONE FORTY
ONE. FOR MONTHS. BEFORE THE
PLAN FOR. WHEN IS YOUR ON YOUR
ON THE LINE. EIGHTEEN A
GALLAGHER FOR THREE FIFTY
SACRAMENTO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THERE'S NO ONE ELSE
IN THE QUEUE AT THE TIME. THANK
YOU WILL NOW MOVE TO WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. TO A MODERATOR
FOR THE PLEASE KILL BOSSES IN
OPPOSITION. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS STILL BE OVER
HERE ON BEHALF THAT CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION-
I'D LIKE TO START BY THANKING
THE COMMENT OF THE AUTHOR ABOUT
THE USE OF THE TERM SHALL THAT-
IN THE BILL- LOOK FORWARD TO
HAVING THAT CONVERSATION- AS A-
BILL POTENTIALLY MOVES FORWARD.
UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE OPPOSED TO
THE BILL AS IT CURRENTLY IS A
BRAND BUT I THINK WE NEED TO BE
REALLY CLEAR THAT- CB I AS ARE
NOT A POEM IN A FOXHOLE LAND
CONSERVATION PROTECTIONS IT'S
ACTUALLY QUITE THE OPPOSITE.
OUR MEMBERS HAVE MASTER PLAN
PROJECTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THAT CONCERT IN MANY CASES AN
UPWARDS OF NINETY PLUS PERCENT
OF THE LAND ASSOCIATED WITH
THEIR PROJECTS. OUR MEMBERS ARE
OFTEN THE FOUNDERS OF PARKS AND
OPEN SPACE THROUGHOUT THEIR
PROJECTS AND IT MANY TIMES FAR
BEYOND THE BORDERS OF THEIR
PROJECTS. WE WORK REGULARLY
WITH CONSERVATION GROUPS ACROSS
THE STATE ON REGIONAL
CONSERVATION BASSMAN STRATEGIES
AND FEES AND PEAS WILDLIFE
CORRIDORS HABITAT CONNECTIVITY
PROJECT. NAME A FEW WHAT IS
CONSERVING DOUBTS ABOUT THE
BILL IS REALLY IT'S BROADNESS
AND THE PRACTICAL IMPACT THAT
GOLD HAVE IMPLICATIONS. AND
SETTING UNDEFINED AND AMBIGUOUS
GOALS HAVE IMPLICATIONS FOR
MAKING THE DEVELOPMENT OF
HOUSING EVEN MORE LIKE HINGES
THAN IT ALREADY IS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND IN THE MIDST
OF THE HOUSING CRISIS THAT WE
FIND OURSELVES IN TODAY. WE
SIMPLY CANNOT AFFORD TO GIVE
RISE TO MORE LITIGATION. THIS
BILL PROVIDES REALLY NO GUY HOW
THESE GOAL SHOULD BE APPLIED TO
STATE REGULATORY EFFORT.
WITHOUT THAT CLEAR AND
UNDERSTANDABLE GUIDANCE WE ALL.
KNOW BUT IT. GROUPS AND- THAT
WILL TURN TO THE CORE TO THE
QUESTIONS AND THE OTHER DAY WE
BELIEVE IMPACT OF THE BILL IS
TO BE TO THROW BADLY CROTCH
INTO THE COURTS DRIVING UP
THERE COST OR IT WORST CASE
DAHLE IN THEM ALL TOGETHER THE
BILL ALSO PROVIDES NO INSIGHT
AS TO HOW PRIVATE PROPERTY WILL
BE CONSIDERED IN CONTEXT OF
THIS BILL HOW WILL IT BE
LOCATED WHERE WILL IT BE
LOCATED LIKE PROPERTY OWNER BE
MADE AWARE OF AND HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WEIGH IN AND
DISCUSS IT. SO REALLY THE IN
THE DAY OUR CONCERN IS THAT
EIGHTY THIRTY THIRTY BECOMES A
TOOL TO TAKE APPROPRIATELY
PLACED LAND OFF THE TABLE
FUTURE DEVELOPMENT FURTHER
RESTRICTING BADLY NEEDED
HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES AND FOR
THEIR DRIVING UP HOUSING PRICES
IN CALIFORNIA THE CURRENTLY
EXIST IN MERRY ADAM
CONSERVATION TOWARDS THAT
CATCHING THE GOLD A. B.
THIRTEEN THIRTY WITHOUT THE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES SO
CLOSE REALLY WERE OPPOSED TO
THIRTY THIRTY- BUT DO LOOK
FORWARD TO FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYBODY IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
WHO WANTS. TO VOICE OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL. IT'S ARE AERICAN
WE NOT HAVE ENOUGH WITNESSES
THAT CORRECT. NO I THINK THAT'S
CORRECT OKAY- AND AS THE
MODERATOR THAN TO OPEN THE LINE
FOR OPPOSITION. YOU'RE IN
OPPOSITION PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THERE IS NO ONE IN
Q. OKAY THANK YOU I WILL THEN
MOVE TO THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
LIKE PARTY WITH THEM RIGHT WING
UP RIGHT NOW OKAY THANK YOU.
WELL THEIR QUEUE ENOUGH I'LL
JUST TAKE A MMENT TO THINK THE
MODERATOR WHO WE DON'T KNOW FOR
HER EXCELLENT WORK TODAY HELP.
WELCOME.
I WOULD WATER LINE OF
ONE TWENTY. OKAY WITNESS IF YOU
CAN GIVE US YOUR NAME AND WHERE
YOU'RE CALLING FROM. LINE ONE
TWENTY YOU MIGHT HAVE TO HIT
STAR SIXTY ON YOURSELF. YEAH
THAT I HAD TO DO THAT. THE
MORNING I'M SURE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MY CALL RIGHT THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
PACIFIC COAST FEDERATION OF
FISHERMEN'S ASSOCIATIONS. ALL
ENGLISH ON BEHALF OF OUR MEMBER
ORGANIZATIONS AND A NUMBER OF
NON PIECE GFA MEMBER
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING
STANDING UP FOR HUMANS WORKING
GROUP. THE ALLIANCE OF
COMMUNITIES FOR SUSTAINABLE
FISHERIES AND THE CALIFORNIA
ELECTORS PETITIONS
ASSOCIATIONS. WE VOICE OUR
OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTY THIRTY
UNLESS AMENDED TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS UP THE BILL THEN THE
DUTIES. AND WE THANK THE BILL'S
SPONSORS FOR CAN CHANGE TO
ENGAGE JUST ON THIS BILL AND
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
AMENDMENTS THE AUTHOR MENTIONED
IN HIS OPENING. THANK YOU. NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. AND THEY DROP
THEIR LINE THERE'S NO ONE OUT
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU
WITHOUT WILL MOVE TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE IF ANYBODY HAS ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. FOR THE
AUTHOR. SEEING NONE MISTER
COLOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANKS THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MADAM CHAIR AND I WHAT I DO
WANT TO THANK THOSE A SPOKEN
OPPOSITION AS WELL AS THOSE THE
SPONSORS AND- TO THE FISHING
INDUSTRY WE RECEIVE SOME- AS OF
LATE SOME CONCERNS AND- THAT'S
NOT THE INTENT. OF BUT AB
THIRTY THIRTY TO HAVE THIS
TAKEN MEASURES TO PREVENT SUCH
GENERAL MANAGEMENT CONFERENCE
FISHERIES I LOOK FORWARD. TO
GETTING IN THAT CONVERSATION
WITH THEM IN THE AND OUR
SPONSORS. AND I ALSO APPRECIATE
C. B. I. EIGHT- I KNOW THE
BUILDERS PLAY A CRITICAL ROLE
OTHERS LAND BANKING IN MOVIES
OR LAND DEDICATION- IN TERMS OF
MEETING. BOTH LOCAL. AND MORE
GENERAL. OF OPEN SPACE GOALS
WORKING WITH THEM AS WELL JUST
SAY THAT. THE THERE ARE
CURRENTLY- THE AMOUNT OF LAND
THAT'S CURRENTLY OWNED- BY
PRIVATE. OWNERSHIP IS- THIRTY
SEVEN MILLION ACRES AND- OF
THAT ONLY FIVE MILLION- ARE
ACTUALLY. DEVELOPED OR IN THAT
URBAN FOOTPRINTS THERE'S PLENTY
OF LAND. TO GO AROUND TO BUILD
HOUSING AS WELL AS- RESERVE-
30% OF OUR AND KEEPING IN MIND
OR WERE ALREADY OUT TWENTY TWO
PERCENT. SERRANO BECAUSE OF A
CONSTRUCTIVIST. AND WITH THAT
AS WANT TO THANK OUR SPONSORS
OUT ON CALIFORNIA'S OLD
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE AND ARE
YOU SEE. AS WELL AS A CO
AUTHORS SUMMERS BLOOM REYES AND
ROBERT RIVAS. AND MADAM CHAIR
OF YOUR LEADERSHIP. AS WELL AS
A SIXTY FIVE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
ARE FORMALLY SIGNED ON IN
SUPPORT. AND ALMOST THREE
THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS AROUND.
CALIFORNIA'S WITH I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I BOUGHT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH TO HAVE A
MOTION. FACT WE WERE MOTION A
SECOND ROLL CALL PLEASE. AB
VERY THIRTY FOUR AB THIRTY
THIRTY THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN
HI FLORA. FLORA NO CHOW CHOW I
EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE GARCIA III
THE MON MATHIS. MATHIS NO
MCCARTY RTI BRO. HERE TO CHEAT.
AT SUSHI AYE STONE. STONE I.
VOTERS SEVEN TO TWO THANK YOU
WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS NEXT WE ARE
MOVING TO AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY
THREE MR SALAS WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. THE BILL. WE HAVE A
MOTION AND THE SECOND PART
THANK YOU OUT OF HER THANK YOU
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE SIXTY
THREE TO THE COMMITTEE TODAY
THIS BILLS CRITICAL TO BE
CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN ENERGY GOALS
AND CREATING MORE WOULD YOU
DON'T RENEWABLE ENERGY FOR
GRIP. SB THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE
WILL EXPAND THE DEFINITION OF
PIPELINE BIO METHANE FROM WAIST
TO THOSE CONVERTED FROM
ANAEROBIC DIGESTION TO
CELLULOSIC WASTE LIKE DEAD
TREES AND AGRICULTURAL WASTE
WHICH IS CONVERTED THROUGH A
DIFFERENT PROCESS CALLED
THERMAL CONVERSION. WITHOUT THE
EXPANSION OF THIS DEFINITION-
WASTE LIKE DEAD TREES OR SOME
OF THE STUFF WE'RE DOING WITH
FIRE PREVENTION MITIGATION
EFFORTS- TREE TRIMMINGS AG
WASTE SUCH AS THE CHILLS WAY
EITHER BE PUT INTO A LANDFILL
OR IF YOU DRIVE UP AND DOWN THE
HIGHWAY FIVE HIGHWAY NINETY
NINE YOU'LL SEE THESE OPEN
FILLED BERNIE. WHICH IS
DETRIMENTAL TO THE PUBLIC
HEALTH OF. EVERYONE THAT
TRAVELS AND LIVES IN THAT.
PARTICULAR PART OF THE STATE. I
WOULD THAT I JUST RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE AB THIRTY
ONE SIXTY THREE WHILE
CALIFORNIA REDUCE MORE CLEAN
ENERGY. AND WILL REDUCE THE
HARMFUL EMISSIONS. I WITH ME
TODAY TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT BY
TELECONFERENCE IS JULIA ELEVEN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE BIO
ENERGY ASSOCIATION OF.
CALIFORNIAN ERIC WHITE HEAD OF
THE PLASTER COUNTY. AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT WILL
BE CALLING AND BY PHONE.
TRAFFIC OKAY IF WE CAN PLEASE
HAVE THE WITNESSES. SHE GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
JULIE ON THAT END AND I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE BIO
ENERGY ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
WE REPRESENT MORE THAN SEVENTY
FIVE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ENVIRONMENTAL AND COMMUNITY
GROUPS AND PRIVATE COMPANIES
AROUND THE STATE THAT ARE
WORKING TO CONVERT ORGANIC
WASTE TO SUSTAINABLE BIO ENERGY
DEVELOPMENT. AB THREE ONE SIX
THREE IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
TO HELP CALIFORNIA MEET ITS
CLIMATE CHANGE POLICIES.
ESPECIALLY THE REQUIREMENT TO
REDUCE SHORT LIVED CLIMATE
POLLUTANTS 40% BY TWENTY THIRTY.
THE BIGGEST SOURCE OF THE SUPER
CLIMATE POLLUTANTS ARE BLACK
CARBON FROM WILDFIRES IN OPEN
BURNING A FORCE AGRICULTURAL
WASTE. AS WELL AS THE METHANE
EMISSIONS FROM LANDFILLS
LIVESTOCK AND ORGANIC WASTE
LIKE NOT SHELLS AND OTHER
ORCHARD AND VINEYARD PROTEINS
THAT ARE LEFT IN PILES TO DECAY
THESE ARE ALL LARGE SOURCES OF
METHANE EMISSIONS. ACCORDING TO
THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD CONVERTING THIS BIOMASS
TO ENERGY CUTS BLACK CARBON AND
METHANE EMISSIONS BY 98%
COMPARED TO AN OPEN BAR.
CONVERTING BIOMASS ENERGY IS
ALSO THE SINGLE LARGEST
OPPORTUNITY WE HAVE IS A STATE
TO GENERATE CARBON NEGATIVE
EMISSIONS. ACCORDING TO A
RECENT REPORT BY LAWRENCE
LIVERMORE NATIONAL LAB
BIOENERGY CAN PROVIDE MORE THAN
TWO THIRDS OF ALL THE NEGATIVE
CARBON EMISSIONS WE NEED TO
REACH CARBON NEUTRALITY BY MID
CENTURY. AB THREE ONE SIX THREE
WILL REDUCE SHORT LIVED CLIMATE
POLLUTANTS EMISSIONS AND
GENERATE CARBON NEGATIVE
EMISSIONS Y PROVIDING A
BENEFICIAL ALTERNATIVE TO LAND
FEELING OR OPEN BURNING OF WHAT
WASTE. AND OTHER CELLULOSIC
WASTE THAT IS OT SUITABLE FOR
COMPOST OR ANAEROBIC DIGESTION.
EXPANDED THE DEFINITION OF
PIPELINE BY AMASSING INCREASE
THE IN STATE PRODUCTION AND USE
A BY AMASSING. GENERATED FROM
NON COMBUSTION TECHNOLOGIES.
AND UP I AM I THINK AND THEN BE
USED TO REPLACE DIESEL AND
HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS OR BACKUP
GENERATORS. IT CAN BE USED TO
PRODUCE RENEWABLE HYDROGEN AND
IT CAN BE USED TO REPLACE ALSO
FEEL GAS FOR HARD TO ELECTRIFY
AND USES. FOR ALL THESE REASONS
WE OWE TO THE COMMITTEE TO PASS
AB THREE ONE SIX THREE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ERIC WHITE
MEN THE DIRECTOR OF THE AFTER
COUNTY FAIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT THE DISTRICT OF THE
LOCAL AGENCY RESPONSIBLE FOR
OBTAINING AND MAINTAINING
AMBIENT AIR QUALITY STANDARD
THE PLASTER COUNTY. THE
DISTRICT STRONG SUPPORT AB
THIRTY ONE FIFTY GREAT BECAUSE
THEY WILL PROVIDE SUBSTANTIAL
AIR QUALITY BENEFITS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA. AND PARTICULARLY IN
THE WORLD COUNTY FETCHES BY
AFTER. AFTER COUNTY LIKE ME
WORLD BUT HELEN HERE COUNTY
THAT HEAVILY FORESTED. AFTER
COUNTY NEARLY FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND ACRES REPORTS THAT
COMPRISE NEARLY HALF OF THE
COUNTY PLAN MAN. WITH IT COMES
CHALLENGES WHICH REDUCING AIR
QUALITY AND PASS A WILDFIRE
RISKS FOR MANY RESIDENTS THAT
LIVE IN THE WILD LAND URBAN
NFC. LIKE TO THIS ATTACK COMES
BUT WHAT THE WILD FIRES A
CONTROLLED BURN TO FORCE WAIT
AND OTHER VEGETATION. IN FACT
THE SINGLE LARGE FIRE CAN COST
MILLIONS PERSON DATA UNHEALTHY
AND DANGEROUS LEVELS OF AIR
POLLUTION. A THOMAS CAR
CAMPFIRE THAT MADE THAT ALL TOO
WELL KNOWN. IN ADDITION THE
OPEN BURNING OF AGRICULTURAL
WAIT WHICH HAD INCREASED
SIGNIFICANTLY ACROSS THE STATE
AT THE EXISTING FILE MAPS WITH
30% DOWN. IS WHAT THE GAME
BECOMING A MAJOR SOURCE OF AIR
POLLUTION IN MANY REGIONS. SO
THE DISTRICT AND THE CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD HAVE FOUND
THAT CONVERTING BUT WASTING
ENERGY CAN CAP PARTICULAR
MATTER EMISSIONS BY NINETY
EIGHT NINETY NINE PERCENT.
COMPARED OPEN BURNING. WE ARE
PLEASED THAT THE STATE HAS
RECOGNIZED IN ELECTRICAL FACTOR
THAT THE ELECTRICAL INSPECTOR
AND PUT PROGRAMS IN PLACE TO
SUPPORT IT. BUT MORE NEEDS TO
BE DONE. AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY
THREE OFFERS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
EXPAND THE USE OF WHAT HE FILE
MATH. TO REDUCE SMOG FORMING
AND CRIME THAT POLLUTION
EMISSIONS. WHILE PROVIDING
IMPORTANT ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY
AND WHILE COMMUNITY. FOR
OBVIOUS REASONS THE DISTRICT'S
STRONG SUPPORT THE BILL AND
URGE THE COMMITTEE TO PASS AB
THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. CAN WE PLEASE
OPEN UP THE TELEPHONE LINES FOR
SUPPORT. WITNESSES AND IMPORT
YOUR AT THE PARK. I FEAR AND
SUPPORT PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WELL THE LINE ONE FORTY
THREE. OKAY WITNESSES MAKE SURE
YOU HIT STAR SIX TIME YOU
YOURSELF AND THEN NAME AND
ORGANIZATION. FORTY THREE ARE
YOU ONE YET. WE NEED TO HIT
STAR SIX TO AMUSE YOURSELF
CALLER. OKAY LET'S MOVE TO THE
NEXT CALL. NEXT RIVER BOTTOM
LINE THIRTY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS USUALLY
MALINOWSKI BALL REPRESENTING A
CALIFORNIA BIOMASS ENERGY
ALLIANCE. SO THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER. NINE FIFTY
THREE. COALITION REMEMBER TO
HIT STAR SIXTY ON YOURSELF. I'M
NOT LINE FIFTY THREE. OKAY
LET'S MOVE TO THE NEXT CALLER.
PART OF THE LINE ONE FORTY
SEVEN. RENDON CHEWING ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL OFFICERS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT COLOR.
LINE ONE THIRTY. HI THIS IS
LAURA PERON K. ON BEHALF OF THE
RESEARCH RECOVERY COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. LINE ONE
FORTY EIGHT. WELL THE LINE ONE
FORTY NINE. GOOD MORNING CHAIR-
NUMBER YOU COMMITTEE BRANDING
RC ON BEHALF OF YARN OUR
LARGEST SERVICES IN SUPPORT.
NINE SEVENTY. EACH OF MIND
SEVEN ZERO. YEAH BUT I'M UNIT.
PLEASE HIT STAR SIX TO ON MUTE
CALLER. HEY NEXT COLOR. MODEL
LINE ONE FIFTY ONE. LINE ONE
FIFTY ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PRODUCTION ON
BEHALF OF FOLLY THE STATION OF
NORTH AMERICA'S LEGISLATIVE
TASK FORCE. AND WHAT ABOUT
THEIR WEIGHT MANAGEMENT
AUTHORITY IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ARE THERE
OTHER CALLERS ON THE LINE. YEAH
NEXT WELL THAT ONLINE. SEVENTY
SEVEN ZERO. ALLERGY TRAIL WHY
GOOD ENERGY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WAS AT OUR LAST
CALLER. THAT WHAT THE LAST
CALLER OKAY WILL GO TO ANYBODY
IN THE ASSEMBLY ROOM IN THE-
COMMITTEE ROOM WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY. IN SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON JOSIAH YOUNG ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
NATURAL GAS VEHICLES COALITION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARKUP PREY ON BEHALF
REPUBLIC SERVICES WE WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS FOR
AMENDING THE BILL AND WE
SUPPORT THE MEASURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE WISHING
TO VOICE SUPPORT EITHER IN
PERSON OR ON THE PHONE. OKAY
SEEING AND HEARING NINE WILL
NOW MOVE TO OPPOSITION I
BELIEVE WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION IF WE CAN PLEASE.
HEAR FROM THE WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK ABOUT HIS KNOCKED OFF
BOTH I'M A STAFF ATTORNEY EARTH
JUSTICE. I JUST OPPOSE IT AB
THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE. AB
THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE CREATE A
COSTLY PATHWAY TO MANUFACTURE
METHANE METHANE IS A POTENT
GREENHOUSE GAS WHAT IT ENTERED
THE ATMOSPHERE WHICH HAPPENS
WHAT LEAGUE FROM GOT PIPELINES
OR WHEN GAS STORAGE FACILITIES
LIKE A LEASE- CANYON RUPTURE.
IT WORKED AND THE CLIMATE
CRISIS. BOTTOM OUT DOES NOT
ORDINARILY GENERATE SIGNIFICANT
QUANTITIES OF METHANE WHAT IT
DECOMPOSES. THERMAL CONVERSION
OF BIOMASS TO METHANE IS NOT
PART OF THE STATE TO BE SHORT
LIVED CIMATE POLLUTANTS
STRATEGY. IN FACT ANALYSES OF
CONVERSION OF BIOMASS TO
METHANE HAVE CAUTIONED THAT
THIS PROCESS CAN ACTUALLY
INCREASE GREENHOUSE GAS
POLLUTION ONE METHANE LEAKAGE
IS ACCOUNTED FOR. ON TOP OF
THAT WHEN YOU BURN METHANE LIKE
WE DO IN OUR GOT PLANTS IN JEFF
POWERED APPLIANCES YOU GET
KNOCKED AND OTHER AIR
POLLUTANTS. CALIFORNIA POLICY
SHOULD RETAIN ITS FOCUS ON
REDUCING SOURCES OF METHANE AND
RELIANCE ON GOD. NOT LIKE A. B.
THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE PROPOSES.
ENABLING NEWMAN COSTLY WAY TO
MAKE IT. BUT CRITICS AB THIRTY
ONE FIFTY THREE IS INTENDED TO
PROVIDE A USED FOR AGRICULTURAL
WASTE THAT WOULD OTHERWISE BE
OPEN BURNED. I AM FOR WHICH
THERE IS NO OTHER BENEFICIAL
USE THE AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY
THREE IS NOT TAILORED TO THE
BEACH DOCTOR NOR IS IT MAKING
MAPPING- THE CARBONIZATION
STUDIES LIKE THE LONG LIVERMORE
LAB I SAY THAT WAS REFERENCED.
BY THE ONE THE PROJECT BUT A
BILL SPONSORED CONCLUDES BY ONE
SHOULD BE YOU TO MAKE HIGH. WE
DOES NOT HAVE A IN A POLLUTION
OF METHANE. OTHER STUDIES POINT
TO LIQUID FUEL WHICH CAN
DISPLAY CARBON INTENSIVE AND
DEFER TO ALLOW I. LIKE EIGHTY.
IN FACT PROJECT TO CONVERT
OUTWEIGHS HIDE ALL ALREADY
MOVING FOR IN THE SENSE VALLEY.
AND ALLOW CONVERSION TO MAP. AB
ONE SIXTY. SETS OF OUR THE
WRONG. AND DIVERT NEEDED FOCUS
FROM THE SUPERIOR YOU. WE URGE
YOU TO VOTE NO ON A THIRTY ONE
SIX THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT WOULD AN OFFICE PLEASE.
THANK YOU ARE AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M I KNOW WHAT YOU
WITH CENTER FOR DIVERSITY AND
I'M A SPEAKS TO THE FOR ASKED
OF THE. UNLIKE BY A DERIVED
FROM ANAEROBE BECOME. OF WORK
MATERIAL FROM SUCH AS LANDFILLS
AND WASTE TREATMENT PLANT.
WOULD WASTE PRODUCES MUCH
SMALLER. IN LOWER DENT OF MY-
FROM NOW THE CAMPUS. SPREAD
OVER MANY YEARS DECADES. AS
MUCH OF THE BIO MAT COME OVER.
OR CORPORATE TO INTO THE SOIL.
THE OF AB THREE ONE SIX THREE.
WOULD LIKE US TO BELIEVE THE
THIS BILL ACCOUNT FIRE EFFORTS
INTO THE DISPOSAL OF FOR WAYS.
THIS IS NOW WHAT THE BILL DOES
AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY X. ALLOWS
FOR THE USE OF ANY WOOD WOOD
CHIPS AND WOOD WASTE WITH NO
REQUIREMENT THAT THE WOULD
WOULD OTHERWISE BE BURNED IN
THE OPEN NOR ANY REQUIREMENT
THAT THIS WOULD COME FROM KILLS
REDUCTION PROJECTS. AS A RESULT
THE CHEAPEST AND MOST LIKELY
FEEDSTOCK AS WE ALREADY SEE AN
BIOMASS FACILITIES IS RESIDUE
FROM COMMERCIAL TIMBER
OPERATION AND MALES. AND
MULTIPLE STUDIES HAVE SHOWN
THAT FORCED SOURCED WOULD BE
BOMBING IS A SIGNIFICANT IN
THAT CARBONI MATTER ONCE YOU
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT ALL OF THE
ENFORCED IMPACTS AND EMISSIONS.
AND EVEN IF THIS WERE FOR THE
SAKE OF ACT. DEALING ON WITH
EXISTING OF FORCED WASTE PRISON
AVAILABLE FOR. FOREST TREES ARE
EXPENSIVE TO CUT AND TRANSPORT
AND PROCESS RECENT STUDY HAVE
FOUND THAT NOTHING PRODUCE THE
SAN CATHOLIC. WOULD BE EIGHT
TIMES MORE EXPENSIVE THAN
NATURAL GAS AND IF USED FOR
ELECTRICITY GENERATION ALL
EVIDENCE INDICATES THAT BIOMASS
GASIFICATION WOULD BE MANY
TIMES THE COST OF SOLAR PLUS
STORAGE. I PRE THE AUTHORS
INTEREST AND IT. CALLUM'S ARE
NO ENERGY. BUT THIS BILL MRS
THE MARK AND WOULD BALLFORCED
MANAGE AND INVEST IN. ENERGY WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU TO VOTE NO
ON AB THREE ONE SIX THREE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MODERATOR WOULD
YOU PLEASE OPEN THE LINE FOR
ANY OTHER OPPONENTS OF THE BILL.
CAN WE PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE
LINES FOR ANY OPPONENTS OF THE
BILL. IF THERE ARE ANY OPPONENT
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
ONLINE FIFTY THREE. YEAH GOOD
MORNING THE PLANE INTHE CLEAN
ENERGY I WE ARE FOR THE BUCK
WITH A CAT ISSUE WE WANT CALLED
THE YOUR CLIMATE THAT ALL ARE
GOING TO BE BACK ON FROM THAT
WHAT. MAKES YOU THANK YOU ANY
OTHER COLORS THE LINE IN
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT. ONE ZERO
THE TIME BUT ONLINE. ONE
THIRTY. THEY TOOK THEM OUT OF
THE QUEUE IF YOU TO CUBA UP AT
ONE ZERO. BUT ONLINE THIRTY
SIX. HI THIS IS. CHENEY SO.
THANK NATURAL RESOURCES AS HOW
COOL. I DON'T THINK. CENTER
EIGHT AND THE CALL. FOR AND
FIND SET. AND A FULL SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA LEADERSHIP
PROJECT AND ACCOUNTABILITY
THANKS FOR. OKAY WE'VE LOST YOU.
HELLO ARE YOU STILL THERE. OKAY
YES HELLO YEAH WE LOST YOU ARE
YOU IN SUPPORTER OPPOSITION OF.
OPPOSITION OKAY I JUST WANTED
TO GET THAT ON TO THE RECORD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT YEAR
NEXT COLOR. OUR NEXT WELL THAT
A LINE ONE FIFTY FIVE. HI HELLO
YES HELLO. HI MORTGAGE HE
MEANT- APOLOGY THAT MAN I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
ONE FIFTY THREE TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTY THAT CAN GET THROUGH
THE FIRST TIME ON BEHALF OF SO
CAL GAS. WE ARE SUPPORTING.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COLORS IT.
MAXWELL THAT ALIGN ONE FIFTY
THREE. HELLO THIS IS THE ARM ON
THE FLOORS BUT THE VALLEY
NATION COMMERCE WITH A PATIENT
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
ONE SIX THREE. WELL THAT ALIVE.
ONE SEVENTEEN. HELLO MY AND ONE
SEVENTEEN. HI OUR CARLA I JUST
WANTED TO MENTION THAT-
ORGANIZATIONS BY AND WE WERE
NOT ABLE TO HEAR EARLIER TODAY-
AND CLOSE WHERE- IN OPPOSITION
OF THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE AB
WHICH IS UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL YOUR CLUB
CALIFORNIA'S LEADERS
ACCOUNTABLE FOR JUSTIN
ACCOUNTABILITY INTERVIEWS WITH
EIGHTEEN CALIFORNIA BARBELLS UP.
THE BLIND THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT COLOR. THERE'S NO ONE OUT
THANK YOU AT THAT TIME THANK
YOU IS THERE ANYBODY IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM WISHING TO VOICE
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT. SEEING
NONE WILL TAKE IT TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
HAVE COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS. YES
MISTER MURATSUCHI. THANK YOU
MISTER CELIS OHIO. I'M FOCUSING
ON THE ISSUE OF THEIR THERE
SEEMS TO BE A DISAGREEMENT IN
TERMS OF WHETHER OR THIS. WHAT
IS THIS CALL TO THE SYNTHETIC
PROCESS THE THERMAL CONVERSION
OF BIOMASS. HAS A NET INCREASE
OR DECREASE OF METHANE. YOUR
WITNESS IN SUPPORT OF YOUR
BILL- TESTS FIVE THAT- THAT
SAID THERE WOULD BE A NET
REDUCTION. BUT I I'M AND
LOOKING AT THE LETTER FROM THE
SIERRA CLUB THAT NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL EARTH
JUSTICE THE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY- AND-
THEIR INDICATED THAT IN FACT A
BIO MASS LIKE WOULD. AN
AGRICULTURAL CROP RESIDUE
PRODUCE A MUCH SMALLER MORE
DISPERSED VOLUMES OF METHANE
OVER YEARS AND THAT THE
SYNTHETIC PROCESS SUCH AS
THERMAL CONVERSION OF BIOMASS
TO NOTHING- ACTUALLY INCREASES-
THE NET AMOUNT OF METHANE SO.
YOU KNOW IT'S A DOZEN MAKES
WELL- FIRST OF ALL COULD YOU
ADDRESS THAT CONTRADICTION- YES
THANK YOU WHEN ALL OUR- JULIA
FROM BIO ENERGY ASSOCIATION TO
ADDRESS THAT AS WELL MORE
SPECIFICALLY BUT- THIS ROAD
CITY LET ME JUST TELL YOU THAT.
LIVING IN THE VALLEY UC ALL OF
THIS WASTE- BEING PILED UP AND
FEEL THE BURN THEY PUT A MATCH
TO IT WHICH GOES OUT INTO THE
AIR IT'S A- PUBLIC HEALTH
DETRIMENT UTILITY ASPER RATES
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THIS IS SOMETHING WHERE WE
COULD DO SOMETHING POSITIVE
WITH ALL THAT WAY SUCH AS WITH
AGRICULTURE BUT THINK ABOUT ALL
THE BILLS WE VOTED ON HERE FOR
FIRE MITIGATION- THE CAMPFIRE
THE FIRE AND- THIS MODES
DISTRICT LAST YEAR FOR
INSTANCE. LIKE ALL OF THAT WE
SOMETHING NEEDS TO HAPPEN WITH
THAT WHAT I'M SAYING WITH THIS
BILL IS. LET'S DO SOMETHING
POSSIBLE LET'S CONVERT THAT
INTO GREEN ENERGY. AND FOR YOUR
VERY SPECIFIC QUESTION ALL OF
THE TO BEST FROM BY ON ALSO SEE.
THANK YOU. HOW AT THE THREE TWO
OKAY I THINK THAT WE HAVE BUT
ASK FOR A WITNESS TO RESPOND TO
THE QUESTION.
YEAH OKAY YEAH IS
THERE SOMEONE IN THE VIDEO ROOM
TO HELP THE WITNESS ANSWER THE
QUESTION. CAN SOMEONE TURN THIS
ON YES WHERE YOU'RE ON NOW-
GOOD OKAY SORRY. HI THIS IS
JULIE ELEVEN AGAIN WITH THE BIO
ENERGY ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA
SO THERE ARE A COUPLE OF
MISUNDERSTANDING IN THE
OPPOSITION ARGUMENTS ARE WHEN
IT COMES TO FOREST OR
AGRICULTURAL WASTE A LOT OF
THAT WASTE IS BEING
MECHANICALLY SENT PURSUANT TO
STATE LAW SB NINE A ONE WHICH
REQUIRES A DOUBLING OF FORCE
YOU'LL REMOVE ALL. THE REALLY
ONLY A FEW OPTIONS WITH IT CAN
BE PILED AND LEFT TO ROT IN
WHICH CASE IT IS A SIGNIFICANT
SOURCE OF METHANE. BUT ACTUALLY
THE FAR MORE DAMAGING
ALTERNATIVE USE IS TO PILOT UP
AND BURN IT OR TO DO PRESCRIBE
FIRE IN THE FOREST BOTH OF
WHICH ARE MAJOR SOURCES OF
BLACK CARBON EMISSIONS. BLACK
CARBON IS FORTY THREE TOP IS
MORE DAMAGING TO THE CLIMATE
EVEN THE NOTHING WHICH IS
SEVENTY FOUR TIMES WERE
DAMAGING CARBON DIOXIDE. SO THE
OPPONENTS ARE IGNORING THE VERY
SIGNIFICANT BLACK CARBON
EMISSIONS FROM BURNING A FORCE
WASTE OR WILD FIRES WERE
BURNING OF AGRICULTURAL WASTE.
THEIR FIRE WEATHER CONTROL OVER
OF OURS DO ALL THESE NOTHING
AND SO IS THIS PURPOSE
MATERIALIZE LEFT FILE STRIP.
THE OPPONENTS ARE ALSO. URBAN
WOULD. THE MAJORITY OF THE
ORGANIC. ORGANIC WASTE IS
CURRENTLY TO LANDFILLS WHICH
HAS TO BE DIVERTED BY TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE THE VAST MAJORITY
IS CELLULOSIC WASTE. WHEN IT
GOES TO A LANDFILL WHETHER
THAT'S URBAN WOULD WASTE OUR
YARD TRêN MEANS OR
CONSTRUCTION DEBRIS. IN A
LANDFILL IT ALSO RELEASES
METHANE LEAKAGE THE CALIFORNIA
RESOURCES WERE LEAKAGE FROM
LANDFILLS IS MUCH HIGHER. THAN
LEAKAGE FROM PIPELINES. SO IF
YOU RELY ON THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD OR THE ENTIRE
STATEWIDE ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
AIR DISTRICTS. THEIR ASSESSMENT
IS THAT THE NET REDUCTION IS
98299% AND NOTHING AND BLACK
CARBON EMISSIONS. FROM BIOMASS
CONVERSION. THANK YOU I UP IF I
MAY I WOULD JUST LIKE TO. COM
AND I AND I WANT TO GET INTO A
BACK AND FORTH BUT- THE LETTER
OF OPPOSITION DOES DISTINGUISH
BETWEEN THE BY A METHANE DERIVE
FROM. THE ANAEROBIC
DECOMPOSITION- IN FROM
LANDFILLS AND WASTEWATER
TREATMENT PLANTS. YOU KNOW I
I'VE BEEN ON SEVERAL TOWARDS
SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
FORESTRY FOUNDATION I KNOW THAT
THERE IS A REAL DILEMMA IN
TERMS OF WHAT TO DO WITH. WITH
THE WHAT PRODUCTS- THAT WET
WEATHER FROM FOREST THINNING
OR- OR FOREST MANAGEMENT OF
OVER OR OTHER SOURCES- BUT IT
IT JUST. SEEMS CONTRADICTORY TO
ME THAT THAT WE'RE SPENDING ALL
THIS EFFORT AND MONEY TO TRY TO
CUT DOWN ON GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS AND ACCORDING TO THE
AUTHORS OWN STATEMENT THAT.
METHANE EMISSIONS IS ONE OF THE
MOST DAMAGING SHORT LIVED
CLIMATE POLLUTANTS AND YOU KNOW
AND SO I'M CONCERNED THAT WE'RE
CREATING THIS- THIS PRESIDENT
OF WITH THE POTENTIAL OF
ACTUALLY INCREASING- METHANE
PRODUCTION RATHER THAN
DECREASING FOR THAT REASON I'LL
BE OPPOSING THE BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS EGGMAN. THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER SOLACE. BUT
I'M GONNA I'M SUPPORTING THE
BILL TODAY AND I JUST AT IT I
THINK WE ALL WANT TO MOVE TO A
PLACE WHERE WE HAVE ALL CLEAN
ENERGY BUT THE FACT REMAINS WE
CURRENTLY HAVE BY PRODUCTS FROM
OUR ARE CURRENTLY LIVING IN
LESS WE'RE NOT GONNA HAVE TREES
ANYMORE. I CAN HAVE ORCHARDS
CHERRY SEASON RIGHT NOW ON A
FEW DRIVEN AROUND ON THE EAST
SIDE OF US I'M LOOKING COUNTY
HELLO CHERRY TREES GOING ON
RIGHT NOW THAT NEED TO BE
PRUNED AND THEN SOMETHING DON'T
THAT WASTE AND IF YOU'RE
DRIVING AROUND AFTER PRUNING
TIME AND THERE'S AN OPEN BURN
GOING ON AND IT'S FOGGY
OUTSIDE. IT IS SO HARD TO BREED
IT IS HARD TO BREATHE A WORD TO
MASK INSIDE- SAID THAT'S I
THINK WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO STAY
AWAY FROM IS WHAT WE HAVE WE'RE
DEALING ITH REALITY RIGHT NOW
AND REALITY RIGHT NOW IS OPEN
BURNS OCCUR PLEASE HOLD ME
THINK AND HAVE TERRIBLE IMPACTS
ON SPECIALLY IN OUR IN OUR
VALLEY. ON ON AIR SO I WOULD
PUTTING HIS BILL TO. I'M WITH
RESPECT TO MY AT. MY COLLEAGUES
OBJECTIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OTHER MANY MEMBERS MATHIS.
THANK YOU MAY CHAIR- COUPLE OF
QUICK THINGS MISTER SALAS- I
JUST WANNA WANNA CONFIRM MOM
WITH YOU THERE'S SOME CONCERNS
THAT THIS BILL MIGHT BE CAUGHT-
MANDATE- FOR PROCUREMENT AND I
JUST WANNA YOU TO ADDRESS THAT-
IT AND I ALSO WANT TO COMMENT.
BACK AGAINST IT SOME OF THESE
OPPOSITION LETTERS TO THE BILL
I THINK THERE'S SOME PEOPLE OUT
THERE THAT FORGET THAT WERE ALL
CARBON BASED LIFE FORMS- AND
CARBON IS NOT GOING AWAY IN
THIS IDEAL OF CARBON ZERO IS.
TOBY IN FAIRY TALE IN THE BEST
WE CAN SHOOT FOR IS A CARBON
NEUTRAL- STANDARD AND WE HAVE
TO DO SOMETHING WITH THESE
PRODUCTS AND WITH THIS WASTE.
THAT IS OTHERWISE GOING TO HARM
US IN OTHER WAYS- IN AGAIN-
BEING YOUR NEIGHBOR THE VALLEY
WE SEE THIS. EVERY SINGLE FIRE
SEASON WE SEE THIS THROUGH ACT
PRODUCT WASTE THROUGH OPEN BURN
PITS- THERE'S DEFINITELY A WAY
TO HARNESS THIS ENERGY THAT IS
OTHERWISE BEING WASTED- THROUGH
THE PROCESS AND TURN IT INTO
SOMETHING THAT'S VALUABLE THAT
HELPS GO TOWARDS- OUR GOALS OF
RENEWABLE ENERGY AND I THINK
THIS BILL DOES THAT. AND FOR
THOSE REASONS I'D LIKE TO JUMP
IS A JOINT AUTHORED WITH YOU AS
LONG AS IT'S NOT GONNA BE A
MANDATE. FOR THE PROCUREMENTS
AND- HELP YOU MOVE THIS THING
FOR THANK. THANK YOU JUST WRAP
THE ELEMENT FIRST ADDRESS YOUR
FIRST POINT THAT NOW IT'S NOT A
MANDATE. AND SECONDLY I THINK
THIS IS WHY- TO YOUR SECOND ONE
I THINK THIS IS WHY YOU SEE
EVERYBODY FROM THE CLEAN ENERGY
GROUPS TO THE- AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICTS TO THE
PREFERRED POLLUTION CONTROL
OFFICERS WHO TESTIFIED. AND
ALSO THE WASTE MANAGEMENT
GROUPS I THINK THEY ALL SEE
THIS AS A WAY TO TACKLE- THIS
POLLUTION A AND LET'S TURN IT
INTO SOMETHING POSITIVE IT TO
CLEAN ENERGY AND SO I THINK
THAT'S WHY YOU SEE THE BROAD
SUPPORT AS WELL. THANK YOU FOR
COMMENTS. THANK YOU OTHER
COMMENTS OTHER COME ALIVE MANY.
MR SO WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
HI THIS RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE THERE'S OVER YOU KNOW
I THINK ABOUT TWENTY
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE I SAY
RANGING FROM THE AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT TO WASTE
MANAGEMENT TO CLEAN ENERGY
GROUPS THAT ALL SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S
POSITIVE LEADS US INTO- IT TO
THE GOALS OF THE LEGISLATURE
SET OUT IN TERMS OF ACTUALLY
PROVDING. ADDITIONAL CLEAN
ENERGY AND SO RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR LIVE OF. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WE HAVE A MOTION. I THINK
WE'VE A MOTION AND A SECOND
ROLL CALL PLEASE. AB THIRTY ONE
SIXTY THREE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
FRIEDMAN HI. FRIEDMAN AYE
FLORA. FLORA ALL RIGHT CHAO.
CHAO ALL RIGHT EGGMAN. EGGMAN
HIGH GARCIA. LOW MOAN. MATHIS
MATHIS ALL RIGHT MCCARTY RTI
BRO BRO FIVE YEAR TUCCI AND C.
G. NOTE STONE STONE NOW. A VOTE
OF SEVEN TO TWO SEVENTY TWO
WILL BE THE ROLE OPEN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THINK ABOUT IT SURE
THANK YOU DEAR COMMITTEE STAFF
TO FOR THE WORK ON THE BILL
THANK YOU NEXT WE HAVE AB
THIRTY TO FIFTY SIX BY EDUARDO
GARCIA. AND BY KEVIN MULLIN I
BELIEVE THEY'RE BOTH HERE TO
TESTIFY. AND. FOR BILL FOR I
THINK THAT WE'RE TO GO WE HAVE
TO DO YOU WANT TO BE ADDED ON.
AS AN AUTHOR I THINK YOU NEED
TO MAYBE THEY'LL ASK FOR THE-
AUTHOR FIRST. OKAY WITH WITHIN
AMEND THE BILL BUT THERE'S A
PROCEDURE FOR ADDING AUTHORS
WILL COVER THAT. LOOK WE'LL GET
TO THANK YOU. OKAY WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY MISTER OKAY THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND A COLLEAGUE
SO ONE OF BEGIN BY THINKING.
NUMBER OF FOLKS IN THIS ROOM
HAVE BEEN WORKING ON THIS BILL
INCLUDING YOURSELF- AND CHAIRED
JAMAL WHO SPEAK AFTER ME SOME
MEMBERSHIP GARCIA WHO IS ALSO A
CO AUTHOR. TO THE BILL. AND
SEVERAL OTHERS WHO HAVE A-
SHOWN INTEREST IN SUPPORTING
THIS EFFORT. LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF IN THE CHAIR
FOR YOUR CONTRIBUTION ON THE
BILL EXCEPT THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS TO WHAT IS NOW THE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY WHILE FIRE
PREVENTION SAFE DRINKING WATER
ACT OF TWENTY TWENTY. POLICY
CALIFORNIA'S FACING A PIVOTAL
MOMENT IN HISTORY AS MANY
EXPERTS ARE SUGGESTING THAT THE
STATE IS EXPECTED TO ENTER.
DEVASTATING EFFECTS TO OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH DUE TO THE
CLIMATE CHANGE CRISIS- IN OUR
COUNTRY IN OUR STATE AND
CERTAINLY IN OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES AND WE'VE SEEN
THOSE IMPACTS- DIRECTLY IN OUR
OWN COMMUNITIES- WHETHER IT BE
DIRECTLY ON FORESTRY ISSUES-
DRINKING WATER ISSUES
AGRICULTURE SHOES AND THAT
CERTAINLY. ARE THE OVERALL
IMPACT PUBLIC OUT THERE WILL BE.
IN THE CITY CALIFORNIA. FOR
INSTANCE ACCORDING TO THE
CALIFORNIA'S FOR CLIMATE CHANGE
ASSESSMENT BY TWENTY FIFTY HEAT
WAVES ARE SPECULATED TO
POTENTIALLY BECAUSE TWO TO
THREE MORE HEAT RELATED DEATHS
ARE THE NORMAL THIS INCREASE IN
HE COULD ALSO LEAD TO A LOSS OF
MOISTURE AND FALL WITH AN
AGRICULTURE. AND BY MID CENTURY
PORTION OF THE STATE'S
AGRICULTURE PRODUCTION MAY FACE
WATER SHORTAGES OF UP 216%
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD ALL BE
VERY CONCERNED WITH AS IT
RELATES TO AGRICULTURE. THE
IMPACTS IT HAS TO CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY AND CERTAINLY TO THE
OVERALL FOOD SUPPLY- OF THE
WORLD WATER SHORTAGES
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS PEOPLE OF
COLOR IN COMMUNITIES ALREADY
BURDENED BY. BERMAN POLLUTION
AS A AND- RISING COSTS A WATER
SHORTAGE OF WATER SUPPLY-
THAT'S CERTAINLY SECRET TO
ANYONE HERE SINCE NINETEEN
EIGHTY THERE'S BEEN AN INCREASE
IN INTENSITY AND SIZE OF
WILDFIRES. WITH FIFTEEN OF
TWENTY LARGEST FIRES IN THE
STATE'S HISTORY OCCURRENCES
200-020-0019 ALONE THERE WERE
NEARLY TWO HUNDRED SIXTY ACRES
OF LAND BURNING CAL ACCORDING.
CAL FIRE WE NOW HAVE THE
RESPONSE TO THAT DEMONSTRATES
THE CLIMATE CHANGE IN ITS
STATED ACOSTA EFFECT RAPID
APPROACH WITHIN THE NEXT
DECADE. WE MUST ASK QUICKLY AND
ENSURE CALIFORNIANS ARE
PROTECTING CALIFORNIANS. AGAIN
THE RIVER SYSTEM WOULD CLAP
CHANGE TO CREATE A CLEAN AND
GREEN UPS MOVING FOR. OTHERS
RECENT STUDY THAT CAME OUT
AGAIN I'VE UP ABOUT THE
INFORMATION. ACCORDING TO THE-
STUDY BY THE BAY CON LIKE GETS
IT A PACKAGE OF CLIMATE. SIX
AND CAL. THE BUTTON SUPPORT
NEARLY HUNDRED POINT FULL TIME
EQUIVALNT JOBS. WITH
INVESTMENT OF EIGHT BILLION-
BEING SPENT HERE. IN CALIFORNIA
WITH A FIVE BILLION DOLLAR
PACKAGE AROUND SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND JOBS CAN BE. GENERALLY
PRODUCED- FOR OUR STATE JOBS
THAT COULD RANGE FROM
CONSTRUCTION EQUIPMENT
OPERATORS TO. ENGINEERS AND
PUTTING MANY PEOPLE TO WORK TO
PUT THIS INTO PERSPECTIVE WE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY. TO CREATE
SIX POINT TWO. MILLION JOBS PER
WHAT EVERY SIX POINT SIXTEEN
POINT TWO JOBS FOR EVERY
MILLION DOLLARS TO PROTECT OUR
WATER. FIFTEEN POINT NINETY
JOBS FOR EVERYONE MILLION
PROTECTING OUR CALLS AND TWELVE
POINT FOUR. FIVE FOR JOBS A PER
MILLION AND REGIONAL RESILIENCY
ALL WHICH ARE FULL TIME
EQUIVALENT JOBS. AB THIRTY TO
FIFTY SIX PUTS BEFORE THE
VOTERS A GENERAL OBLIGATION
BOND THAT SEEKS TO PROVIDE
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE THE TOOLS NECESSARY TO
COMBAT CLIMATE CHANGE TO
MITIGATE ITS EFFECTS AND
PROVIDE COMMUNITIES GREEN JOBS.
AS WE CONTINUE TO COMBAT THE
ECONOMIC REPORT OF COURSE
NINETEEN. WILL NOT ASK YOU SOME
REMOTE TO PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY- TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY AS WELL. THANK YOU MR
GARCIA MANAGER MEMBERS AS MY
COLLEAGUE ALLUDED TO WE ARE
LIVING IN UNPRECEDENTED TIMES
IS A GLOBAL HEALTH CRISIS
ENDANGERS THE LIVES AND
LIVELIHOODS OF CALIFORNIANS
EVERY DAY. TO COVER NINETEEN
AND SUBSEQUENT SHELTER PLACE
ORDERS CALIFORNIA IS
EXPERIENCING AN ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN. IN UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
THAT EXCEEDS WHAT WE
EXPERIENCED DURING THE GREAT
RECESSION. THESE THESE FACTS
ARE NOTHING NEW TO ALL OF YOU
ON THAT. DAY YES CALIFORNIA
WILL NEED TO REBUILD AND IN A
WAY THAT WILL PROTECT OUR STATE
AGAINST FUTURE DISASTERS THAT
UNLIKE KOBE NINETEEN WE KNOW
ARE COMING THESE DISASTERS AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA SPOKE
TO. ARE DIRECTLY RELATED TO
CLIMATE CHANGE AND CAN BE
MITIGATED IF WE ACT QUICKLY AND
INVEST ACCORDINGLY. AB THIRTY
TO FIFTY SIX SIX TO HELP
REBUILD OUR CALIFORNIA ECONOMY
WILL ALSO PREPARING FOR CLIMATE
CHANGE IMPACTS. BY PLACING A
SEVEN BILLION DOLLAR BOND ON
THE NOVEMBER BALLOT TO FINANCE
VARIOUS CLIMATE ADAPTATION
ACTIVITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. THESE ACTIVITIES WILL
NOT JUST CREATE NEW JOBS FOR
CALIFORNIANS WITH GREEN JOBS
WHICH ARE OFTEN LONG TERM. AND
HELP US REACH OUR CLIMATE GOALS
AREA COUNCIL INSTITUTE
INDICATES 752-002-0000 A JOBS
CAN BE CREATED STATEWIDE. WITH
THE BOND OF THIS MAGNITUDE AS
THE NEED FOR EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS EFFORTS RISE IT IS
ESSENTIAL THAT WE INVEST IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE NECESSARY TO
PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES
ENVIRONMENT AND ECONOMY FROM
CLIMATE CHANGE IMPACTS. MEMBERS
THE PUBLIC HEALTH AND ECONOMIC
CRISIS WITH CURRENTLY FACE
PROVIDE A UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY TO
RETHINK. RESHAPE HOW WE LIVE
TOGETHER. ON THIS EARTH LET'S
NOT LET THAT OPPORTUNITY
OPPORTUNITY PASSES BY IN
WITHOUT I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU- I DON'T SEE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES LISTED IN
SUPPORT- SO IF THERE ARE NO
WITNESSES I'LL ASK THE
MODERATOR TO PLEASE OPEN THE
PHONE LINES FOR ANYONE WISHING
TO- OFFER SUPPORT. IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND OUR
FIRST COMMENT COMES FROM LINE
ONE SIXTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO GOOD MORNING CARE
FRIEDMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE-
ALEXANDER ON BEHALF OF CAL
START MAKING SURE YOU CAN HEAR
ME. YES WE CAN HEAR NARAL.
THANK YOU WE ACTUALLY HAVE A
RECORD OF AMENDED PETITION FOR
THE FELLOW AND WE THINK IT'S
COLD ARE INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
AND WE'RE ASKING UP LOW CARBON
TRANSPORTATION PROGRAM.
INCLUDED A ELIGIBLE IF AT THE
END OF THE BOND. AND ABOUT
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION%
DOLLARS ANNUALLY FOR THE NEXT
THREE YEARS. EVEN THE STATE'S
TOP CLEAN AIR PROGRAM WITH
STRONG LINKS REDUCE PAYING.
MATTER AND KNOCK. AND THE
INDUSTRY HOW GROWN JOB OVER
FIFTY THOUSAND JOBS. ALL IN
CALIFORNIA. THAT WE COULD
ACTUALLY LOSE ON IF WE DON'T
FOCUS ON NOT ONLY RECOVERY FOR
THE INDUSTRY BUT AND ENSURING
THAT IT CAN CONTINUE TO GROW
AND THAT THE EIGHT ARE
GREENHOUSE GAS GOAL AND ALSO
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT BATTING CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION AND- EVERY
DOLLAR PUBLIC INVESTMENT
LEVERAGES ABOUT SIX DOLLARS AND
PRIVATE CAPITAL SO WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR. I'M AT.
THANK YOU AND JUST TO REMIND
THOSE WHO ARE- GIVING THEIR
SUPPORT THAT WE ARE JUST
CHECKING NAME AND ORGANIZATION
THE NEXT CALLER. LINE EIGHTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY EIGHTY TO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AND RELATING EXT COLOR.
AND COLOR FIND ME BUT IT HAD
STAR SIX TO AMUSE YOURSELVES I
CAN GET THEM OKAY NEVER MIND
EIGHT YEAH OKAY LINE ONE SIXTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY MONTH
SIXTY THREE IF YOU STILL WISH
TO. MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RELEASING GOING TO THE
NEXT LINE AND THAT'S LINE ONE
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MADAM CHAIR MEMBER STEVE
BAKER WITH AIR AND RITA SO
SEATS FOR THE PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEERS IN CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT AS WELL AS THE
RESOURCES LEGACY FUNDED SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER. LINE ONE
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE
ONE THIRTY FIVE LINE IS OPEN
HELLO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS
IS WAR BONTA ã WITH THE
RESOURCE RECOVERY COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA- WE HAVE THAT THE
COURT A COMMENDED POSITION TO
INCLUDE ESSENTIAL RECYCLING AND
WASTE DIVERSION SERVICES. WHICH
ARE INTEGRAL TO CLIMATE
MITIGATION AND RESILIENCY IN
CALIFORNIA AND ALSO PROVIDE
ECONOMIC BENEFIT AND GREEN JOBS
THAT ARE SPECIALLY NEEDED
DURING THE TIME. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT COLOR. NINE ONE
SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS NATALIE MAX I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF A FRIEND OF THE LA
RIVER ASKING YOU TO CREATE
CONSERVANCY LA NEIGHBORHOOD
PLAN DRAFT NATURE FOR ALL IN
COMMUNITY NATURE CONNECTION WE
ARE TAKING A SUPPORT OF AMENDED
DIVISION. WE SUBMITTED LETTERS
TO THE COMMITTEE- AND ENCOURAGE
YOU TO REFER TO THOSE LETTERS
AND WE ARE OPEN TO SPEAKING TO
ALL OF YOU AND HOPE WE CAN DO
SO IN THE FUTURE. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER. EIGHT AND THAT'S
FROM. LINE ONE SIXTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. CABLE GOING TO LINE
ONE SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
REMEMBER WE SHIP PRIEGO ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN FOREST
FOUNDATION A CONSERVATION
ORGANIZATION IN SUPPORT. NEXT
CALL IT WILL GO TO LINE SURE
WILL GO TO NINE THIRTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YEAH SHE LIED
MALINOWSKI BALL ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA BIOMASS ENERGY
ALLIANCE- I'M SORRY THAT
CALIFORNIA ELECTRIC
TRANSPORTATION COALITION.
ALLERGIES THAT WE HAVE A
SUPPORT- IF AMENDED POSITION
CONSISTENT WITH MS ALEXANDER
PREVIOUSLY MENTIONED ABOUT
INCLUDING LOW CARBON
TRANSPORTATION. IN NEXT WE
THINK THAT THE INVESTMENT THE
STATE OF MAINE DOCK BAR AND
THANK YOU JUST OPEN AND
TRANSPARENT JUST NAME THE
AMERICANIZATION THANK YOU NEXT.
CALLER AND THAT FROM AT ONE.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CARL GARIBAY
EVERYTHING SUPPORT- THE AB
THIRTY TO FIFTY SIX ON BEHALF
OF AUTUMN ON CALIFORNIA TROUT
CALIFORNIA NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY
CINEMA ENTRANCE THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN TRACK LIMITED
THANKS. THANK YOU NEXT. OKAY
AND WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE A ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WARNED THE
LEGISLATURE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA FARED ALLIANCE. WITH
THE COURT. THANK YOU. OKAY IN
THE NEXT ONE IS FROM THE LINE
ONE SIXTY THREE PLEASE EXCUSE
THE LINE SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ATTIC UNITS
ON BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES WE
ARE ALSO. IN SAID HAVE A
SUPPORT IF AMENDED POSITION ON
THE BILL. FOR THE CONCEPT OF A
CLIMATE RESILIENCE BOND- BUT WE
HAVE AMENDMENTS THAT WE HAVE
PROVIDED TO THE COMMITTEE-
THERE IT WOULD INCREASE- THE
PROVISIONS OF THE OF THE BOND
RELATED TO WATER RESILIENCE
OKAY I THINK WE BELIEVE. THAT
I WILL WE WILL LOOK AT THE
LETTER THANK YOU NEXT CALLER.
OKAY AND THAT'S FROM. LINE ONE
SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I GOT ENSURING MEMBERS MICHELLE
RANTS ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PARK
FOUNDATION AND SUPPORT THANKS
VERY MUCH. WE JUST HAVE SEVERAL
PEOPLE THAT JUST CUED UP SO
GIVE THEM JUST A MOMENT. THANK.
WELL THEY'RE QUEUING UP WILL
TAKE ANYBODY IN THE ASSEMBLY-
COMMITTEE ROOM WHO WANTS TO
VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE BILL. IF
THERE'S ANYBODY HERE YOU CAN
COME TO THE MICROPHONE. OKAY
SIGNAL GO CONTINUE WITH THE
CALLS. IT WOULD BE JUST ANOTHER
MOMENT THANK YOU. IN OUR NEXT
COMES FROM A LINE ONE SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MYERS ON THE
HAPPY SAY THE REDWOODS LEAGUE
AND TO PROVIDE FUND WHICH
SUPPORTER COMMENDED FOR THE
REASONS EXPLAINED IN OUR
LETTERS TO THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. HEY AND THAT COMES FROM
LINE ONE SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS NATALIE
BURKE ARE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HABITAT CONSERVATION
PLANNING COALITION THE LAND
TRUST OF SANTA CRUZ COUNTY.
HELLO REGIONAL OPEN EXTRA AND
MARIN AVERAGE LAND TRUST WE
WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
SUPPORT IF AMENDED POSITION AT
THE TELL THEM SUBMIT TO THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU. OUR NEXT
QUESTION COMES OUR COMMENT
COMES TO MIND ONE SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE ONE
SEVENTY ONE. PLEASE GO AHEAD
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. OKAY MOVING
ON TO THE NEXT ONE ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. HEY WE DO HAVE ONE FROM
LINE ONE NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING NOT GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE GLENN
FERAL WHAT THE SAN DIEGO COUNTY
WATER AUTHORITY- WE ALSO LIKE
TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT IF
AMENDED- REALLY APPRECIATIVE OF
MR GARCIA'S LEADERSHIP AND THAT
THERE AND LOOK FORWARD TO
ENGAGING ON THAT. A GREAT
RESILIENCY AND THE ECONOMIC
STIMULUS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT COLOR. AND THE NEXT ONE IS
FROM LINE ONE NINETY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JOHN MOFFITT ON
BEHALF OF THE ALLIANCE FOR
AUTOMOTIVE NAVIGATION WITH THE
SUPPORT OF AMENDED POSITION
CONSISTENT WITH THE CALLIE T.
C. LETTER THANK YOU. OKAY IN
THE NEXT ONE COMES FROM MIND
EIGHTY TWO. YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR. WE COME UP WITH A
NOT A WHAT THE TRUST PUBLIC
LAND. WE SENT IN A LETTER OF
SUPPORT ACT THAT BEEN PLANNED-
AMENDMENT THE COMMITTEE AND TO
ALL THE AUTHOR OF THAT. THANK
YOU. THE NEXT LINE IS ONE SIXTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. MANY
MONTHS IN ON BEHALF OF THE
SANTA ANA WATERSHED PROJECT IS
ALREADY LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE ON
INCLUDING ONE BILLION DOLLARS
FOR INTEGRATED REGIONAL WATER
MANAGEMENT AND YOU TO BE OR
THANK YOU. THE NECKLINE OF ONE
SIXTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS SERRA CHRISTY
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COMMISSION IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL WE PARTICULARLY
APPRECIATE THE CALL OUT TO THE
COASTAL COMMISSION LCP
RESILIENCE PLANNING PROGRAM
THANK YOU. IN OUR NEXT LINE IS
LINE TWO OR FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
JUSTIN HIGHER WITH THIS BILL
CON BALLY LEADERSHIP GROUP AND
WE'RE PROUD TO SUPPORT THE
BILL. THANK YOU. AND WE DO HAVE
SEVERAL THAT- JUST CUED UP
AGAIN SO WE'LL GIVE THEM A FEW
MOMENTS. IN OUR NEXT ONE COMES
FROM NINE TWO ZERO ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY
INSURANCE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THAT THIS IS THE MONOLOGUE
BUSINESS ON BEHALF OF THE
IMPERIAL IRRIGATION DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND ITS
SUPPORT FOR OPPORTUNITIES- TO
HELP THE SALTON SEA. DOWN AND
IMPERIAL VALLEY THANK YOU. IN
THE NEXT ONE COMES FROM A LINE
ONE SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS WITH THE BEST A LOT
THOUGH ON BEHALF OF WATER THE
CALIFORNIA WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHORS IN THE
COMMITTEE TO INCREASE FUNDING
FOR WATER RECYCLING PROJECT
THAT CREATES JOBS AND HELP ME
WITH THE FINAL RESILIENCE GOAL.
THANK YOU. HEY AND OUR NEXT ONE
COMES FROM NINE TWO ZERO FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON- CHAMBERS OF
COMMITTEE BRANDING ARE HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE ALLEGED TO BE
ABLE CHARGING SENSATION AND
VALLEY CLEANER NOW WE HAVE A
SUPPORT OF MEDITATION THAT
LOOKS GOOD FOR THE OTHER WHILE
OUR TRANSPORTATION PROGRAMS.
THANKS. HE WILL GIVE THEM A FEW
MORE MOMENTS WE HAVE ABOUT FIVE
MORE PEOPLE THAT CUED UP. IN
OUR NEXT ONE COMES FROM. LINE
ONE FIVE TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE FIFTY
TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. NO RESPONSE FOR THE SAME.
AND THE NEXT ONE COMES FROM
NINE TWO ZERO EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WHAT
YOU'RE DOING THAT I'M PASSING
THE GAVEL TEMPORARILY. THANK
YOU. OKAY AND WE DO HAVE
ANOTHER QUESTION FROM OUR
EXCUSE IF YOU HAVE A COMMENT%
FROM LINE ONE EIGHTY SIX.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE
EIGHTY SIX IF YOU'D STILL LIKE
TO MAKE A COMMENT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. IN OUR NEXT ONE COMES
FROM LINE TWO TO THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. BY WHAT YOU GONZALEZ
ON BEHALF OF THE- AUTHORITY WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH ALL OF
YOU TO ENSURE THAT THE FINAL
BOND HAS THE ESOURCES
NECESSARY FOR THE STATE TO MEET
ITS MORAL AND LEGAL OBLIGATION
OF. THE REGION THANK YOU. AND
IT ACTUALLY COMES FROM A LINE
AT ONE SEVENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO TO THE MORE WORK
NEEDED BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
COAST AND KNOW WHAT OPERATE OR
AT A PRACTICE. SUPPORT MINDED
BUT THERE'S ABSOLUTE WITHIN OUR
LETTER. TO GIVE US JUST A FEW
MORE MOMENTS WE HAVE A COUPLE
MORE THAT HAVE CUED UP IN LINE
ONE FIFTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LINE ONE FIFTY TO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND WE
HAVE THEN FROM LINE TO ONE
SIXTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE
ARE THANKFUL FOR ORDERED
WORKING WITH ALL OF. I'M UP ON
THE REPORT. LINE ONE SIXTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE LINE. AND
THAT'S WHAT COMES FROM NINE TO
TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE TO
TEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RELEASING THE LINE THERE
ARE NO MORE IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
PROCEED. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MODERATE OR ANYBODY
ELSE IN SUPPORT OF IN THE
CHAMBER HER IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM CNN ANY OPPOSITION. IN THE
GREATER IN ANY OPPOSITION ON
THE LINE. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
OPPOSE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME. MY TO TWENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO AND
STILL BE A PHILLIES SHANTI
HAPLESS CITY OF LOS ANGELES
MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI I'M
ACTUALLY TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION. WE DO HAVE A MORE
THAT CUTE ABSOLUTE GIVEN JUST A
MOMENT.
IN OUR NEXT COMMENT
COMES FROM NINE TWO ZERO SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO
CONEY ON BEHALF OF AN INTO OPEN
SPACE TRUST SANTA CLARA VALLEY
OPEN FIFTY THIRTY WILD LANDS
CONSERVANCY AND CINEMA WATER I
APOLOGIZE WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OKAY IN OUR LAST ONE COMES FROM
LINE TO UP I APOLOGIZE ANOTHER
ONE JUST CUED UP WE HAVE TWO
MORE IN QUEUE AND THE NEXT ONE
COMES FROM LINE TO SIXTEEN.
WHICH I HAD. LINE SIXTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
RELEASING THE LINE. NEXT WE GO
TO THE LIGHT OF ONE EIGHTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE ONE
EIGHTY SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. RELEASING THE
LINE PLEASE PROCEED. OKAY WE
HAVE NO MORE COLORS WAS OR
ANYBODY HERE IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE MEASURE. OKAY
SEEING NONE WILL NOW COME BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE FOR COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS MR STONE. THANK
YOU I APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORTS
ON THIS BOTH. MR MULLIN MR
GARCIA I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN
TALKING IN THIS ONE FOR AWHILE.
I THINK THIS BOND IS GOING TO
BE ON AN INTERESTING JOURNEY
OVER THE NEXT COUPLE MONTHS
DEPENDING ON WHAT THE GENERAL
FUND IS GOING TO DO. WHAT THE
STATE BUDGET IS GOING TO LOOK
LIKE BUT I DO SEE THIS IS A
VERY GOOD OPPORTUNITY FOR
CALIFORNIA TO LIE TO LEVERAGE.
ITS GENERAL FUND INVESTMENTS IN
RESILIENCE AND TRADITION
ORIGINALLY THIS IS START OFF
WITH CLIMATE RESILIENCE BUT THE
ECONOMIC RESILIENCE IS GOING TO
BE AN IMPORTANT COMPONENT OF
THIS AND I THINK WE CAN
CERTAINLY DO BOTH. ONE OF THE
THINGS I WILL JUST THAT I HAD
BEEN TALKING AND TALKING AND
TALKING ABOUT QUITE A BIT
BEFORE WHEN WE'RE SOME OF THE
CLIMATE RESILIENCE PART OF WHEN
THIS WAS REALLY FOCUSED ON
RESILIENCE OF THE CLIMATE. BUT
I THINK IT'S ALSO TRUE FOR THE
ECONOMIC RESILIENCE IS WE HAVE
YET TO CREATE. REAL STANDARDS
AROUND WHAT THAT RESILIENCE
MEANS. AND MY FEAR FOR. JUST
COMING UP WITH ANOTHER POT OF
MONEY IS IT WILL GET SPENT ON
THINGS THAT ARE JUST AND
EVERYBODY'S Q. BECAUSE I THINK
A LOT OF. THE SUPPORT THE
SUPPORT AMEND IT IF AMENDED BY
THE CONCERNS RAMPS ARE PHOTO.
JUST LOOK FOR DOLLARS
APPROPRIATELY TO CONTINUE THE
PROJECTS THAT THEY HAVE HAD.
BUT IF WE DON'T ESTABLISH
APPROPRIATE STANDARDS FOR WHAT
RESILIENCE MEANS HOW WE PLAN
FOR THE APPROPRIATE PRODUCT
PROJECTS. UP IN THE COMMUNITIES
IN IT WITH THE AGENCIES THAT
WILL BE. TAKING ON THIS MONEY
THEN WE HAVE NO ASSURANCE THAT
ANY OF THE MONEY IS GOING TO BE
SPENT. FOR THE PURPOSES
OUTLINED. IN THE IN THE BOX SO
FOR GONNA SELL IT IS RESILIENCE
WHETHER CLIMATE RESILIENCE. OR
ECONOMIC RESILIENCE AND WHEN HE
GETS ON THE BALLOT THAT'S
PROBABLY HOW IT'S GOING TO GET
SPENT. WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE MECHANISMS IN
PLACE TO ENSURE THAT THE MONEY
GETS SPENT FOR THOSE PURPOSES.
SO ABSOLUTELY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
MONEY. BUT I AM ALSO HOPING
THAT IN THE BOND FOR THROUGH
OTHER MECHANISMS WE BUILD IN
AND FUND AND HELP OUT. LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ESPECIALLY WHO
ARE GOING TO BEAR THE BRUNT OF
THE- INS AND RECOVERY OVER THE
NEXT NUMBER OF YEARS. THAT
THESE INVESTMENTS THAT ALSO
COME WITH WAYS OF HELPING THOSE
JURISDICTIONS. DO THE PLANNING.
NECESSARY AND THAT WE STATE
APPROPRIATE STANDARDS SO THAT
WE HAVE SOMETHING AGAINST WHICH
TO MEASURE THOSE PROJECTS AND
THOSE INVESTMENTS AND THAT'S-
PARTLY THIS BOND IT'S PARTLY
OUTSIDE OF THIS BOND BECAUSE IT
NEEDS TO BE. A CONVERSATION
ABOUT HOW WE SEE THOSE. HELLO
JURISDICTIONS DO PLANNING. THEY
DIDN'T HAVE MY- IN THE OLD. TO
DO THAT PLANNING THERE
CERTAINLY COULD HAVE LESS OF
THAT NOW SO WE NEED TO BE
THINKING ABOUT HOW WE ADDRESS
THOSE ISSUES. AND WE'RE GONNA
PUT MONEY LIKE THIS ON THE
TABLE THAT IT MEETS. INSURE
THAT IT MEETS ALL OF THOSE.
OBLIGATIONS I THINK AND
OPPORTUNITIES THAT THIS MONEY
REPRESENTS. BUT I THINK YOU FOR
BRINGING IT FORWARD AND THAT'S
JUST AS AN ONGOING CONVERSATION
I KNOW WE WILL KICK TEN YOU'D
HAVE IT. IT IS AN ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS ONLY MEN AND-
CANDIDLY ADMIT I WEAR HEARING
AIDS AND I READ LIPS SO I
CALLED ABOUT 75% OF IT BOTH THE
SEPTEMBER SENATE CALL WAS WAS
EXCELLENT. AND I FULLY AGREE
AND COMPANION LEGISLATION THAT
WILL WRAP AROUND ANY KIND OF A
BONTA EFFORT. THAT WILL ADDRESS
THE REGIONAL PLANNING CONCERNS
I KNOW THAT CAR WITH. KILLER
GOING TOWARDS PEACE. BASE WITH.
THE REGIONAL INPUT AT
INCENTIVES BUILT IN HURT THE
ENCOURAGE REGION TO DO THE
APPROPRIATE PLANNING SO WE'RE
NOT JUST COME UP WITH A BUNCH
OF PORK PROJECTS. BASED ON
SCIENCE THAT. PULL SO AS AROUND.
REGIONAL PATIENT PROJECT EXCEL.
IT BUT I WHAT YOU'RE SAYING
LEAST MOST OF IT AND I MAKE I
WILL MAKE THAT INCORPORATE ALL
OF INTO THE AND WE'RE I JUST
WANT TO PUT THE CALM OUT THERE
AMERICAN TALK ABOUT IS I TALKED
AND OR ANY THESE OTHER. HOUSE
GIVE THAT THAT WARNING IF
THEY'RE EXPECT TO JUST OPEN UP
A PIPELINE TRADITIONAL MONEY
THEY SHOULD THINK AGAIN AND
THEY NEED TO BE OUR PARTNERS IN
ESTABLISHING THE RULES THOSE
HAITIANS AND HELPING.
COLLECTIVELY UNDERSTOOD HOW
INSURED. AS THAT MONEY GETS WE
GO BACK TO PUBLIC AND SAID WE
ASK YOU TO VOTE ON RESILIENCE
BONDS. WE GET WHETHER IT'S
CLIMATE OR ECONOMIC. WE ASK YOU
TO VOTE ON THOSE THIS IS HOW
WE'RE ASSURING THAT WE ARE
MEETING THOSE GOALS- IN THE IN
THE LONG RUN SO I THINK WE'RE-
DEFINITELY AGREEMENT ON IT I
JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE- WE'RE CLEAR IN THIS
HEARING THAT. OF THAT
ADDITIONAL NEED. THANK YOU
DOCTOR EGGMAN. YEAH I. MICHAEL
ABOUT THE LINE. NO LONGER
READING ABOUT ALL WATCHED. ALSO
SCHOOL. YEAH OUR. SO THAT'S YOU
GO INTO. WE ARE IN THE I. HOW
TO SELECT. TAX AND THIS. OUR
REALLY WITH. REALLY SB WITH ME
ASSESSING. RIGHT EVERYTHING
THAT WE KNOW SO OURSELVES MY
WISELY AREA OR WE NEED TO FIND.
TO YEAH MAKE SURE. THAT FOR
THOSE. THIS IS NOT NORMAL
PRODUCTION. EVERYTHING ELSE IS
COMMITTEE MEASURE MEMBER I'M
SORRY. SO I JUST LIKE TO
KIDDING TO PLEASE BE SURE YOU
SPEAK INTO THE MICROPHONE THINK
THEY'RE HAVING SOME TROUBLE A
HEARING SUCH TO. TRY TO CATCH
IT SO. SIX YEAH. THANK YOU. FOR
I'M MISS GARCIA. AT THE YOU I'M
A DRAIN ON THERE ON ON THIS
BOMB AND WITH REALLY ENTHUSIAST
ABOUT IT. CREATE ARE COULD BE
THE CAUSE IN NINETEEN REALITY
THAT WERE AND B. I FELT THERE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO WORK NOT JUST
WITH THE BOND BUT WITH ALL
OTHER FUNDING AND I GENERAL
FUND THEN OUR GHGS TO ELEVATE
THE CLEAN THEIR WORK THAT IS
NEEDED IN MY DISTRICT THERE'S A
PIECE IN HERE THAT ADDRESSES
HEAT ISLANDS. NOT ENOUGH I FEEL
FOR MY DISTRICT TO GET ITS FAIR
SHARE OF THE PIE AFTER A PACE
AND FOR THE WORKING CLASS
DISTRICT THAT THAT I'M THAT I'M
IN BUT I AN OPPORTUNITY- AND
THAT ABILITY IN OUR NEW REALITY
DO NOT CLEAR WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN THE BUT WITH THE GO.
THERE'S BEEN RUMORS OF GIGI
MONIES COMPLETELY. FOR OTHER
DAY BEYOND THEN AND YOU KNOW
BEING THAT LEFT THERE. CLEANER
INITIATIVE NOR ON AND PROBABLY
NOT. I LOOK AT AT THE F. I DE
THINK THAT SEVERE PRIORITY AND
RESEARCH PORTER BUT WHEN I LOOK
AT THERE IS STILL IN THE PAR
THE WATER PARK ADAPTATION PART.
THAT IS. WE ARE COMING TO
FRUITION. ALONG THE WAY SOME A
I'M REALLY UNCOMFORTABLE
SITUATION BECAUSE IF I'M GOING
TO BE TAKEN AWAY GENERAL FUND
DOLLARS- FOR THIS SPACE I WANT
TO MAKE SURE MY DISTRICT TO
THAT IS IN DIRE NEED IS GETTING
THAT'S FOR SURE THE PIE THAT MY
LOOK SMALLER CITIES. THAT ARE
BEING HIT- ARE GONNA BE ARE NOT
GOING TO BE SAFE MORE ON LAND
SO I ASSUME. YOU TODAY. ABOUT
THAT I'M CURRY SEE WHAT BECAUSE
I OF THE MAYBE TO. I DE. YOU
KNOW MY COMMITMENT HI CHANGE ON
TO FIGHTING THAT HAS AND NOT
HAS NO WAVERED. BUT I THINK I
NEED TO SEE THINGS A DIFFERENT
REALITY MOVING. MOVING FORWARD
I REALLY IF YOU SEE A WIRE
BUDGET IS AT NINE SO JUST IN A
REALLY UNCOMFORTABLE SITUATION
AT THIS POINT. TO VOTE ON
SOMETHING THAT SO MANY AND SO
MANY UNKNOWNS. AND A LOT OF
FEAR THAT I'M GOING TO REVERT
TO SPACE WE WERE AT BEFORE I
GOT TO THE LEGISLATURE. WHERE
COMMUNITIES LIKE MINE WERE
ALWAYS THE- END OF THE LINE AND
WE SEE LITTLE TO NOTHING FROM A
LOT OF THESE BONDS- ALONG THE
LAND SO. I APOLOGIZE THAT I
HAVE A BETTER SOLUTION FOR YOU
KNOW I HAVE A LITTLE BIT TIME
PASSED TODAY TO TRY TO THINK
ABOUT. I'LL BUT A LOT HAS
ADDITION TO WITH WITH LOWER
WITH THIS. ONE THANK YOU ANY
OTHER COMMENTS. WELL ALL THE
SAD- WANNA THINK MISTER MULLIN
MR GARCIA. THEY'RE VERY HARD
WORK ON THIS- AS A PROUD TO AN
AUTHOR OF THE MEASURE I CAN
FIRST OF ALL TELL MY COLLEAGUES
AND SOME OF HEM BEEN IN A LOT
OF THOSE METINGS- THAT THESE
ARE ALL EVERYTHING THAT'S BEEN
BROUGHT UP IN THE TOPICS THAT
WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING AND WILL
CONTINUE TO DISCUSS. I'D SAY
ABOUT A MONTH AGO I WAS A
LITTLE BIT SKEPTICAL ABOUT THE
CHANCES FOR THIS FARM GOING
FORWARD GIVEN THE IMPACT ON THE
GENERAL FUND. BUT WE'VE BEEN
HAVING ALL OF A LOT OF US KIND
OF ON THE SIDE TALKS WITH
ECONOMISTS AND- OTHERS WHO
POINT OUT THAT WE'RE GONNA NEED.
A CUSTOM. TO REALLY FOSTER
FASTER RECOVERY I'M OUT OF THIS
RECESSION THIS CODE AND BECAUSE
RECESSION. AND RIGHT NOW.
INTEREST RATES ARE AT HISTORIC
LOWS. AND SO GIVEN THAT THERE
ARE CO BENEFITS BESIDES
STIMULUS FOR STIMULUS THE SAKE
AND JOB CREATION FOR JOB
CREATION SICK WHICH IS
IMPORTANT. BUT IF WE CAN ALSO
HAVE THE CO BENEFITS OF.
INCREASING OUR WATER
RESILIENCY. OF INCREASING OUR
WORK ON WILD FIRE PREVENTION
AND MITIGATION. ON INCREASING
OF OUR RESILIENCY FROM THE
EFFECTS OF GLOBAL WARMING WHICH
IS THE NEXT COMING CRISIS. THEN
WE ALSO CAN MAKE FOR. A SAFER
STATE WELL WE STIMULATE OUR
ECONOMY- SO I DO THINK THAT
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO CONTINUE
TO THE DISCUSSION. ON THIS BOND
AGAIN I. IN THE THAT'S BEEN
DONE WHEN I YOU. AND THAT WE
HAVE A MOTION WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CALL IT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
MADAM CHAIR I THINK YOU'VE DONE
AN EXCELLENT JOB AND REALLY
POINT OUT. YOU KNOW WHAT. THE
DISCUSSIONS HAVE BEEN BOB
BETWEEN THE WORK GROUP AND-
WHAT LIES AHEAD IN THE COMING.
DAYS AND WEEKS AND MONTHS AS
WAS MENTIONED BY. FOR CALLING
FROM SANTA CRUZ. THE FACT THAT
MATTERS IS THAT THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO. RE
PRIORITIZE. AT NOT JUST THE
OBJECTIVES THAT WE'VE SET
FORWARD IN OUR CLIMATE CHANGE
POLICIES. BUT HOW WE TRULY NED
BILLS- OPPORTUNITIES- DOWN ON
THE GROUND IN THE AREAS THAT
ARE. DISPROPORTIONATELY ALSO
IMPACTED. AND HELP GENERATE
BILLS. GOOD JEAN CLEAN JOBS AS
WE WILL MOVE THE NEEDLE FORWARD
AND- EMISSION REDUCTIONS IN
GREATER RESILIENCY ARE TO
CALIFORNIA'S INFRASTRUCTURE.
I'M HOPEFUL THAT- AS WAS IN THE
MAKE IN THE JANUARY.
PRESENTATION THE BUDGET THAT
THE GOVERNOR PUT FORWARD THERE
WERE ALREADY A LOT OF-
COMMITMENTS THAT WERE BEING
FORESEEN- TO BE FUNDED. BY
SOMETHING LIKE THIS PARTICULAR
BOND WE'LL FIND OUT THE-
FRIDAY. WHETHER OR NOT THEY'RE
STILL AN INCLINATION TO MOVE IN
THAT DIRECTION- BUT- WE'VE BEEN
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE ECONOMIC
TASK FORCE THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
PUT FORWARD. WE ALSO TALKED
ABOUT THIS AS A CENTERPIECE TO
WHATEVER MASTER PLAN THEY COME
UP WITH FOR SHORT TERM AND LONG
TERM ECONOMIC RECOVERY-
PATHWAYS WE'RE GONNA KEEP
WORKING UNTIL WE'RE TOLD THE-
NOT TO. AND RESPECTFULLY- WOULD
ASK THAT YOU GIVE US A YOUR
SUPPORT SO THAT WE HAVE- THE
VEHICLE AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO
AT THE RIGHT MOMENT- BE ABLE TO
MOVE THIS TO. OF LAWS THE END
GOAL BE THE- TO HELP
CALIFORNIANS GET BACK ON THE
PATH OF ECONOMIC RECOVERY SO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR APPLE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE A
MOTION. HEY WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND ROLL CALL PLEASE.
K. A. B. THIRTY TWO FIFTY SIX
THE MOTION IS- THAT THE URGENCY
CLAUSE BE ADOPTED. THE BILL BE
AMENDED AND DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
BANKING FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN
HIGH FLORA FLORA NOT VOTING
CHOW CHOW HIGH EGGMAN EGGMAN
HIGH CRISTINA GARCIA. LIMóN
LOW MOAN HI MATHIS. MATHIS NOT
VOTING MCCARTY. BRO. BROWN NO
MERE TUCCI. READ SUSHI AYE
STONE STONE HI. SIX TO ONE SIX
TWO ONE LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT WE
HAVE AB TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED BY
MISTER CLARK AND I BELIEVE IT'S
BEING PRESENTED BY MR CHOW.
WELL BACKGROUND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH YEAH THANK YOU. MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- PRESENTING
AB TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK.
AB TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED REMOVES
A SUNSET PROVISION TO ENSURE
THAT STATE AGENCIES WILL
CONTINUE TO ACCOUNT FOR CURRENT
AND FUTURE IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE WHEN PLANNING BUILDING
AND INVESTING IN STATE
INFRASTRUCTURE. IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN THE ORIGINAL AB TWENTY
EIGHT HUNDRED CREATED THE
CLIMATE SAFE INFRASTRUCTURE
WORKING GROUP COMPOSED OF
SCIENTISTS ENGINEERS AND
ARCHITECTS TO EXAMINE HOW TO
BEST INTEGRATE CLIMB
INFORMATION. WITH THE STATE'S
INFRASTRUCTURE DESIGN PLANNING
AND IMPLEMENTATION. THE WORKING
GROUP RELEASED THEIR REPORT TO
THE LEGISLATURE IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN LAYING OUT A NUMBER OF
RECOMMENDATIONS TO MAKE. UP THE
STATE INFRASTRUCTURE. AND
SUSTAINABLE TO WITHSTAND A WIDE
RANGE OF CLIMATE IMPACTS BY
REMOVING THE SUNSET AB TWENTY
EIGHT HUNDRED WILL ALLOW THE
STATE TO FOLLOW RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR INFRASTRUCTURE PLANNING
ALREADY DEVELOPED BY THE
WORKING GROUP IN ORDER TO MAKE
INFRASTRUCTURE SAY. AS SAVE
LIVES ON THE PHONE TODAY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE OUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK. AND JASON FOR BOSE
WESTERN STATE SENIOR POLICY
MANAGER FOR THE UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS. THANK YOU
WE HAVE THE WITNESSES PLEASE.
THE BILL QUIRK. THANK YOU CHAIR
AND MEMBERS. HELLO MISTER QUIRK
ARE YOUR TESTIMONY IF YOU'D
LIKE TO OFFER A PLEASE. YEAH
YEAH BILL QUIRK THANK YOU TURN
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY MEMBER. BEFORE
ANY AB TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED ON
MY BEHALF. THAT THE WORKING
GROUP BROUGHT TOGETHER EXPERTS
ACROSS SECTORS AB TWENTY EIGHT
HUNDRED WILL MAKE THE WORKING
GROUP'S BERMAN AT SUCH
GUARANTEEING THAT STATE
AGENCIES CONTINUE ACCOUNT FOR
CURRENT AND FUTURE IMPACT THAT
FIND. STATE AND BERKSHIRE IN
ORDER WORK A CLIMB JAY FUTURE.
ONE THANK STAY BUT WORK ON THE
BALLOT. I APPRECIATE THE
RECOMMENDATION TO UPDATE THE
ROLE OF THE WORKING GROUP MOST
CERTAINLY CONSIDER THAT
RECOMMENDATION AS THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD. THANK YOU ARE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU ARRIVE
ABOUT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
QUIRK NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. WE
HAVE ANOTHER WITNESS NOON CHAIR.
YES CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE HEAR
YOU. RIGHT GOOD AFTERNOON GEN
MEMBERS THIS IS JASON BARBODES
WITH THE UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS- ADD ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS CHALLENGE QUIRK AT-
EXPLAINED THIS IS A VERY SIMPLE
BILL TO- ADDRESS THE SUNSET
PROVISIONS STATE LAW- I'M
HOPING TO REMIND THE COMMITTEE
THAT WHILE THE BILL IS. IS
QUITE SIMPLE THE ISSUE IT OF
COURSE INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
THAT WE ARE FACING A NEW NORMAL
OF EVER INCREASING VARIABILITY
AND EXTREME IN CLIMATE ASIAN.
THAT IS EXPECTED WORKING
OVERTIME. AND ADD WE'VE SEEN
MANY TIMES IN RECENT MEMORY-
EXTREME WEATHER AND OTHER
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE HAVE
BIG IMPACTS. ON OUR STATE AGING
INFRASTRUCTURE ON OUR ON OUR
ROADS ON ELECTRICITY GRID OUR
RESERVOIRS- AMONG OTHERS AND-
OF COURSE INFRASTRUCTURE PLAYED
CRITICAL ROLE IN OUR LIVES AND
LIVELIHOOD. AND THEIR BAND
PUBLIC FUNDS WHAT WE THAT. AND
YOU TO FIND. AND FOR MANY
DECADES DESPITE CHANGING
CLIMATIC CONDITION FELT IT AB
TWENTY WILL HELP THE STATE CAN
CAN TO FIND AT THE PROTEGER THE
BUILDING MAINTAINING PUSHED. TO
WITH THE INTO OF CLIMATE CHANGE
IN I HOPE YOU ALSO PART OF THE
DAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND AS A REMINDER IF YOU
WOULD WISH TO SUPPORT. PRESS
ONE THEN FOLLOWED BY ZERO ALSO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU ONLY PRESS
ONE ZERO ONE BECAUSE IF YOU
PRESS IT AGAIN. YOU WILL REMOVE
YOURSELF FROM THE QUEUE. WE'LL
GET IN JUST A MOMENT TO QUEUE
UP. OKAY IN OUR FIRST ONE COMES
FROM LINE ONE EIGHTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LINE ONE EIGHT EIGHTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. NO RESPONSE FOR THE
SAME WE GO ON TO THE NEXT LINE
AND THAT'S ONE SEVENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
HERE NUMBERS ERIN RODRIGUEZ FOR
THE UC HERE TO READ TO THE ON
OF. CAL THE KIND OF CENTER YOUR
CALL CALIFORNIA POLICY LINK
AMERICAN RIVERS HEALTH WE GET
CAUGHT THE AND WE HOW FOR JEFF
OPENING. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
THAT'S CALLER. AND WE HAVE NO
CALLERS IN THE PLEASE THANK YOU
AS OR ANYBODY IN THE COMMITTEE
WHO WOULD TO SEE ON BE OF THE
BILL. SUPPORT OF THE- DO A
ANYONE IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM
LIKE TO SEE IN OP. TO THE- CAN
WE PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE LINE
FOR A OFFICE. IF YOU WISH TO
OPPOSE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. WE HAVE NO
ONE CUED UP SO FAR PLEASE
PROCEED. THANK YOU IS THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. SIX NINE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE ABSOLUTELY
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- DO WE HAVE A MOTION
AND SECOND. OKAY WE WERE MOTION
A SECOND CAN WE PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE. AB TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFER
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
FRIEDMAN. HI FRIEDMAN HIGH
FLORA. FLORA NO CHAO HI JOE ALL
RIGHT EGGMAN. EGGMAN AYE GARCIA
GARCIA ALL RIGHT LIMóN. MON
ALL RIGHT MATHIS MATH NO BUT-
BRO. ROW NO YOUR TWO G. STONE.
SIX TO THREE THANK YOU SIXTY
THREE WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN- FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. THE
BILL IS OUT NEXT WE ARE MOVING
TO AB TWENTY SIX NINETEEN BY
MARK STONE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB TWENTY SIX
NINETEEN ESTABLISHES A PROGRAM
FOR COASTAL RESILIENCE
ADAPTATION ACCESS. TO PLAN AND
IMPLEMENT ACTIONS TO ADDRESS
SEALEVEL RISE AND. BECAUSE OF
CLIMATE CHANGE A NUMBER OF
YEARS AGO THE STATE HAS PUT
TOGETHER A PROGRAM. THAT WAS
COLLECTING MONEY FROM THE
HIGHLANDS WILL RESUME REVENUES
AND WAS SUPPOSED TO HAVE BEEN
PUT TO NATURAL RESOURCES
PROTECTION EFFORTS THAT MONEY
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND AND SIX
WAS SWEPT INTO THE STATE'S
GENERAL FUND AND LAST YEAR WE
TRIED TO TAKE A PIECE OF THAT
AGAIN THIS YEAR THIS BILL DOES
THE SAME THING TAKES A PIECE
OF. MONEY THAT WAS IT TENDED
FOR COASTAL RESOURCES AND TO
MAKE THAT AVAILABLE FLEXIBLE
MONEY TO MAKE THAT AVAILABLE TO
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO BE ABLE
TO ADDRESS SEA LEVEL RISE IN
OTHER CLIMATE CHANGE ISSUES
ALONG THE COAST OF CALIFORNIA
THAT'S WHERE THAT MONEY WAS
INTENDED SO WE ARE AGAIN ASKING
THAT WE TAKE SOME OF THAT
THAILAND WILL REVENUES COMING
TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
MAKE THAT AVAILABLE TO LOOK
RESTRICTIONS SO THAT THEY HAVE
THE CAPACITY TO BE ABLE TO DO
THE PLANTING NECESSARY BEFORE
WHAT WE KNOW IS. AND WAS THAT
WHEN YOU OUT ABOUT AND I KNOW
YOU'RE CAN. ABOUT IMPACT ON
STATE GENERAL FUND BECAUSE THIS
IS WILL TAKE MONEY OUT OF STATE
GENERAL FUND. BUT THIS IS GOING
TO BE VERY NECESSARY NOW UNDER
THE CURRENT SITUATION THEY ARE
MONIES THAT ARE BEING ALLOCATED
NOW AND THE BOND WE JUST TALKED
ABOUT SHOULD THAT BOND MOVE
FORWARD. THERE WILL BE MONIES
BEING DISTRIBUTED DOWN TO THE
LOCAL AGENCIES AND THE BILL'S
LOCAL AGENCIES ARE BEING
STARVED TO AN EVEN GREATER
EXTENT. THAN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA IS AND WE ARE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO ASK THEM TO
BUILD RESILIENCE AND RESILIENT
TYPE PROGRAMS INTO. THEIR
FUTURE PLANNING AND YET THEY
HAVE NO MONEY TO DO SO AND
THERE'S- REALLY VERY RARELY ARE
THERE MONIES. ALLOCATED TO
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO BE ABLE
TO DO THAT KIND OF PLANNING.
THAT'S WHAT THIS MONEY IS
DESIGNED FOR IT WILL BE FAIRLY
BROADLY AVAILABLE. BUT
ESPECIALLY TO LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO DO THE
PLANNING AND TO DO THE
MECHANISMS THAT WE KNOW THEY'RE
GOING TO BE SPENDING THE MONEY
ON. OR THAT WE ARE AS A STATE
ASKING THEM TO SPEND MONEY ON.
ACTUALLY GIVING THEM GRANT TO
THE ON OTHER MECHANISM THAT ARE
AVAILABLE NOW. THAT THIS IS
TIMELY AND IT IS IMPORTANT
BECAUSE THESE ARE EFFORTS THAT
NEED TO BE ONGOING EVEN AS WE
DEAL WITH. THE COVERED CRISIS
THE PANDEMIC IN AS WE COME OUT
OUT OF IT. THE BOND MONEY AND
OTHER PROJECTS THAT ARE GOING
TO BE PUT TO USE OUR WILL BE
PART OF. ECONOMIC RECOVERY
ACROSS EIGHT OF CALIFORNIA BUT
IF WE'RE NOT CAREFUL AND ITS
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS DO NOT HAVE
MONEY TO DO. PLANET AND BE ABLE
TO INSURE. THAT THE PROJECTS
THAT WE THEN GIVE THE MONEY FOR
FIT INTO RESILIENCE STRATEGIES
FOR CALIFORNIA. WILL BE
THROWING GOOD MONEY AFTER BAD.
SO YES THIS IS PROPOSING TAKING
MONEY OUT OF THE STATE'S
GENEAL FUND. WILL FIGHT THAT
FIGHT AND APPROPRIATIONS WE
LOST HIS LAST YEAR. IN SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS I THINK OVER
BECAUSE OF OBJECTIONS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WILL
CONTINUE TO PUSH. BERMAN
FINANCING CONTINUE TO ASK THE
ADMINISTRATION. IF NOT THIS.
THEN WHAT HOW DO WE HELP LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS. ASSIST OF MONEY
TO DO. THE GRANT WRITING THEY
TO DO. TO DO THE PLANNING THEY
NEED TODO SO THAT THEY CAN
BUILD TOWARD RESILIENCE AND
THAT THAT WE ARE EXPECTING THEM
TO DO AND THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE
TO DO IN ORDER TO SURVIVE. SO
WE I DO HAVE A WITNESS AND
SUPPORT FROM THE AUDUBON
SOCIETY. AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. DO
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. HELLO HI MY NAME IS
ONE I'LL TELL ME DONALD ON THE
CIRCUIT DIRECTOR POLICIES
WITHOUT OF ON CALIFORNIA AND
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT- OF AB
TWENTY SIX NINETEEN WE WOULD
LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
STONE AND THE COMMITTEE FOR
THREE TO HEAR THIS BILL. AB
TWENTY SIX NINETEEN IS A BILL
THAT WILL CREATE A FUND TO MOVE
I CRIME DEDICATION PROJECT IN
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL OR BY
CREATING THE COASTLINE TATIAN
ACCESS AND RESILIENCE. THIS
BILL IS IN IMPORTANT THAT WILL
HELP ADDRESS FUND GAPS SHE
LEVEL RIGHT. WE THAT SEA LEVEL
RISE TO OTHER CRIME RELATED
THREATS. ACT TO CLOSE BUT IN IN
THAT. MEASURES COASTAL CAN.
HOUSE RESILIENCE OF NOW RE.
THIS MEASURE HELP. WITH HEALTH
PREPAREDNESS IN THE-
INVESTIGATING THE TWO LEVEL
RIGHT. AT THE WITH. ELEVEN
RIGHTS RANGING FROM WHAT A FOOT
LIKE WHEN THIRTY UP TO. HAVE
FEET BY TWENTY ONE. INCLUDING
EVENTS LIKE. AND HIGH TECH WILL
EVEN WATER LEVELS AND INCREASE
THE RISK WRITING HE'S WELCOME.
IT ROAD CLIFFS TO AND BE WELL
WHICH WERE AFFECT SHORE FRONT.
I'VE UP NOR ANYTHING THAT IS
HAPPENING AROUND US AND IT IS
FOR THESE REASONS THAT WE ASK
FOR I HOPE. PORT MEASURE THANK
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DO WE HAVE
ANYONE IN THE- COMMITTEE ROOM
WISHING TO VOICE THEIR SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL. CAN WE PLEASE
OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT. IF YOU WISH
TO SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO WE DO HAVE A FEW PEOPLE
THAT CUED UP FOR WILL GIVE HIM
JUST A MOMENT. OKAY AND THE
FIRST ONE IS FROM LINE. TO
FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. IT
COUNTY IN SUPPORT. IN NINETEEN
FORTY SEVEN WE GET GET HERE THE
FIRST PART COULD YOU PLEASE.
REPEAT YEAH AT THE MORTGAGE
NEED ON BEHALF OF PENINSULA
REACH OPEN SPACE THE AND
BLANCHE THE CENTER COULD CAL IN.
THANK YOU. IN OUR NEXT COMES
FROM LINE TO PAY SIX PLEASE GO
A- GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR.
I'D BE PRETTY WITH THE SANDY
COUNTY AUTHORITY IN. AND I WHEN
COME FROM MY TO TWENTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI IS JEANNIE GO
BEHALF OF AND OF OR A AND- THE
WALL THE NO LAND THE CALIFORNIA
LEGAL CONSERVATION VOTERS STEP
BACK. LIKE WRITER. WATER ACTION
ONLY EIGHT TWO O. ENVIRONMENT
HOW. FEAR BUT CAL. PLASTIC
POLLUTION COLD. BUT OCEANICA
RESEARCH AND HAD. BUT JARS IF
YOU SEVENTH GENERATION ADVISER
AND THE PLANNING AND CON LEAGUE
ALRIGHT BUT. THANK YOU IS THERE
ANYONE I ON THE WISHING TO
TESTIFY AGAINST. ARE THERE ANY
WOULD ENOUGH. THREE ONE IN THE
CA ROOM WISHING TO SPEAK IN A
TO BILL CAN WE THE PHONE LINES
FOR ANY OP BY. AND IF YOU WISH
TO OPPOSE PLEASE. ONE ZERO. WE
HAVE NO ONE CUED UP AT THIS
TIME PLEASE PROCEED OKAY ANYWAY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- EGGMAN
FRIEDMAN BELIEVE YOU HAD A
COMMENT YEAH I JUST IT WHAT
BROUGHT UP MR AT MR STONE AYE
AYE AM NOT JUST THE DATA
BECAUSE I ACT. I JUST DON'T
THINK WE SHOULD BE TAKEN FROM
FUND I AYE. INTO SEE WHAT'S
GOING TO COMEOUT MAYBE ON THE
FLOORS CAN DIFFERENT IF YOU
MAKE A BUT I CANCEL MY ENTIRE
COMMITTEE JUST BE I THOUGHT WE
BE FOR ON BUT THAT ARE. RIGHT
NOW THAT ARE NOT GOING TO COST
TO ANY MONEY COME TO JUST BE. I
BE SUPPORTING TODAY I KNOW
LIVING ON THE COAST C. LEVEL IS
AND IMPORTANT BECAUSE I PIECE.
WITHOUT EVEN PLANNING IF WE
DON'T TAKE CARE OF THE PLAN BUT
SOME OF THIS WILL BE DONE IN
THE AND BOND AND I WAS
ENCOURAGED TO WORK AS HARD AS
YOU CAN I KNOW MOST OF MY- I
FELT. ON ISSUES RUNCIE LONG OF.
AND WE HAVE NO GUARANTEES THAT
WHATEVER MONEY WE HAVE CUED UP
OR IS CURRENTLY BEING. BEING
SPENT. WILL MEET OUR GOALS OF
RESILIENCE AND WHETHER IT'S
WILD FIRES. WERE SEALEVEL RISE
OR ANY OTHER ASPECTS OF IT WE
HAVE NOT BUILT INTO ANY OF THE
MECHANISM PLANNING MECHANISMS.
IN CALIFORNIA TO HELP LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS. MEET THEIR GOALS
THAT WE ARE EXPECTING OF THAT
SO YEAH I UNDERSTAND THE
CONCERN ABOUT. HITS TO THE
GENERAL FUND BUT IF WE'RE NOT
CAREFUL THEN MONEY WILL BE
BEING SPENT AND WE HAVE NO
IDEA. WHETHER R NOT THAT MONEY
WILL BE HELPING TO MEET THE
GOALS OF RESILIENCE ACROSS
CALIFORNIA THAT'S THE POINT OF
THIS BILL THIS IS MONEY THAT'S
NECESSARY IT'S TYPICALLY NOT
PUT INVOLVED. WE HAVE NOT
HISTORICALLY BEEN WILLING TO
FIND PLACES FOR MONEY TO HELP
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS MEET THIS
GOAL THAT'S WHY WE'RE CONTINUE
TO DO THIS AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT EVEN IN THIS
ENVIRONMENT. OTHER COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. SEEING THE
MISTER STONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I ASK FOR YOUR EITHER
THANK YOU DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
THE MOTION TO HAVE A SECOND.
OKAY A MOTION AND A SECOND AND
WE HAVE ROLL CALL PLEASE. AB
TWENTY X. AB TWENTY SIX
NINETEEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN
HIGH FLORA. FLORA NO CHAO.
EGGMAN GARCIA. EGGMAN NOT-VOTING GARCIA HI THE MOAN. MON
ALL RIGHT. MATHIS I OFFICE NO
MCCARTY MCCARTY I BROKE. BRO NO
MERE TUCCI. STONE STONE ALL
RIGHT. VOTERS FIVE TO THREE
FIVE THREE WILL BE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS NEXT UP
IS AB THIRTY TWO FOURTEEN WHEN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMóN. THANK
YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS ON MAY
NINETEENTH TWENTY FIFTEEN SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY SAW THE LARGEST
OIL SPILL IN CALIFORNIA NUMBER
TWENTY FIVE YEARS THIS BILL
SEVERELY DAMAGED COSTA GO
SYSTEMS AND OUR LOCAL ECONOMY
IS SANTA BARBARA COUNTY JURY
FOUND IN THE ALL AMERICAN FLANK
SEE OF FELONY FOR FAILING TO
PROPERLY. PAIN IT'S INTEREST HI
AFTER I. WHICH DIRECTLY LED THE
OIL. DESPITE THE SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY AND
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY GENERAL
ASKING FOR OVER ONE BILLION
DOLLARS IN CRIMINAL PENALTIES
THE COMPANY ESCAPED WITH THE
PENALTY OF. A LITTLE OVER THREE
MILLION DOLLARS. CRIMINAL
PENALTIES FOR OIL SPILLS HAVE
NOT BEEN UPDATED SINCE THE
EARLY NINETEEN NINETIES AND
MAJOR OIL SPILLS CONTINUE TO
HAPPEN ACROSS CALIFORNIA. IT IS
THE CENTRAL TO MAKE YOU HAVE
MEANINGFUL DETERRENCE FOR
SPECIAL THAT ACTORS THESE
CRIMINAL PENALTIES ARE ONLY
AVAILABLE IN A VIOLENT NO.
POSIT OR REASONABLY. KNOWN THAT
ACTIONS WOULD LEAD TO AN- THE
STATE. SECONDLY THIS BILL
DOUBLES. THE CERTIFICATE OF
FINANCE RESPONSIBILITY FOR TANK
AND NON TANK VESSELS TO MAKE
SURE THEY HAVE THE ADEQUATE
FINANCIAL RESOURCES PLAY
CLEANUP AND DAMAGE COST FOR AN
EVENTUAL OIL SPILL. THESE
AMOUNTS HAVE ALSO NOT RACE IN
THE LAP NINETEEN TO TWENTY
YEARS. KOBE NINETEEN HAS CAUSED
KLEIN INTO OIL. ONLY IF THERE
ARE OIL TANKERS CARRYING CRUDE
TO SATISFY 20% OF THE WORLD'S
CONSUMPTION GATHERED OFF OF
CALIFORNIA'S COAST. THE SHIPS
COULD BE OFF COAST FOR
PROLONGED PERIODS OF TIME ONLY
INCREASING THE LIKELIHOOD OF AN
OIL SPILL. ON THE PHONE TWO IT
IS VICTORIA WRONG THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL AND-
I FELT IT ON THE MUSCLE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GET IN CARE PAID MILLION
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I MY
NAME IS NOT A PROBLEM THOUGH
AND I'M REPRESENTING THE DAY
AFTER LEARNING ON BEHALF
LAWSUIT IN ORGANIZATION
DEDICATED TO DEVELOPING. AND
PERSPECTIVES ON OCEAN
CONSERVATION COASTAL PROTECTION
AND COASTAL LACK THE ACIDIC
HAPPY TO PROVIDE CORD FROM THE
NUMBER LIMON BABY THIRTY TWO
FOURTEEN A BILL THAT WILL HOPE
HELP TO PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES
AND STATE FROM ACROSS THE STATE
OWES BILLS. AT THE ALL. THE
REST. TWENTY WHAT WILL BE NOT
AND THAT HAVE BEEN WRAPPED BY A
AT THE ARNOLD CENTER LOOKING IN
SANTA BARBARA THE JUDGE IN THE
CASE ACTUALLY COMPLY BUT
STATUTORY PENALTIES WERE TOO
LOW AND NEEDED TO BE UPDATED
AND THE FINER POINTS ON AND
MAKE AN IN RELATION SOME OF THE
COMMENTS HAVE BEEN MADE ABOUT
THE GENERAL FUND I'D LIKE TO
MENTION THAT THE RECENT EVENTS
THAT LED TO THE STATE HAVING TO
FOOT THE BILL OF OVER EIGHT
MILLION DOLLARS THE COMMISSION
FROM EIGHT AM THE WELL. AND IN
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY. WHEN WE
IT'S ALL. ONE DIRECTLY GENERAL
FUND AND AS WE KNOW MOVE FOR
DURING THE SECOND RECESSION THE
STATE WILL NOT BE IN A POSITION
TO BAIL OUT MORE OR- FROM THE
ABU WILL OILS BUT MAY HAPPEN IN
FUTURE AND ALL THE COMING UP
TAXPAYERS. THE AND THE AMERICAN
IN THE DOING FOLLOW FROM HOME
HOW ARE BRING LETTER TO THE FOR
AT PENALTY TOO BAD THAT ARE
FOUND LAW FOR THE OILS BILLS
WHEN THEY DO OCCUR FOR THESE
REASONS THAT ONLY A STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB THREE TWO ONE
FOUR AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR- VOTE. YOUR NEXT WITNESS.
HI VICTORIA WRONG CAN YOU HEAR
ME YES WE CAN HEAR YOU. OKAY
GREAT THANK- I'M WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
TWO FOURTEEN FIRST THANK YOU
FOR YOUR HARD WORK TO ENSURE
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION WHILE
YOU'RE CONDUCTING THIS
IMPORTANT STATE AS MATH. ENERGY
EVEN SUPPORT OF AB. TEEN
BECAUSE IT WOULD A STAB A MORE
DETERRENT TO COMPANIES THAT
KNOWINGLY SPILLED OIL INTO
STATE WATERS. ALL THESE CASES-
HOPEFULLY RARE IN CIRCUMSTANCES
WHERE A COMPANY IS NOT
TRANSPARENT WITH THE STATE OR
THE PUBLIC ABOUT ITS BILL
INCREASED PENALTIES ARE VERY
APPROPRIATE. IN ADDITION THE
BILL INCREASES THE AMOUNT
REQUIRED IN ORDER TO RECEIVE A
CERTIFICATE OF FINANCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY THIS HELPS TO
ENSURE THAT STATE TAX PAYER
COSTS FOR CLEANUP AND DAMAGE
ARE MINIMIZED- YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE PLEASE
OPEN THE PHONE LINES FOR ANY.
OUR THIRTY MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WANTING TO VOICE THEIR
SUPPORT. AND WHILE WE AND OUR
FIRST ONE COME FROM I'LL GO
AHEAD NO GO AHEAD PLEASE THANK
YOU. OKAY THANK YOU AND OUR
FIRST ONE COMES FROM LINE ONE.
TO BE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ALL. SEVENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NO RESPONSE FOR THE SAME AND
WE'LL GO TO THE LINE OF TWO
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. I JAMIE
BELL ON BEHALF OF- EXTRACTED
AND THE PORT. THANK YOUNG. IT
WILL GO TO THE NEXT LINE AND
THAT IS TWO FORTY FIVE PLEASE
GO. WHAT OTHER POLLUTANTS THAT
ALSO MUST BEAR ALL THE REST OF
THEM WELL AND THE CONCERN ABOUT
THE FISHER VERY VALUABLE. FROM
SOME THIS BILL. OKAY THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. OKAY AND
LINE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY TO BE SEEN ONLINE
WE HAVE NO MORE IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU IS
THERE ANYBODY IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM WOULD LIKE SUPPORT THE
BILL. SEEING NONE PLEASE HAVE
THE WITNESSES AN AWFUL. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS THIS IS THE
LEGACY OF THE WESTERN STATES
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION CAN YOU
HEAR ME OK YES WE HEAR YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AGAIN YOU
ARE GIVEN THE WEAPONS BASED
UPON ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION
AS WE CAN TELL THAT OUR
POSITION WHETHER WE HAVE.
CONCERNS WITH TWO DISTINCT
SECTIONS OF THE BILL. FIRST THE
BILL- DOUBLING THE FINANCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY REQUIREMENTS MAY
RESULT IN A TRANSPORTATION
FUELS BY SORTED. BY BOTH A
LEVEL OF FINANCE TERMS TANK
VOCALS THAT WILL BE IMPOSSIBLE
TO THE- THE EXISTING LEVEL OF
FINANCIAL TERMS CONSTRUCTION
ALLIANCE WITH INTERNATIONAL
STANDARDS. AND IS THE MAXIMUM
LEVEL OF INSURANCE POLICY
AVAILABLE ON THE GLOBAL MARKET.
TO DATE NEARLY 70% OF THE CRUDE
OIL DEMAND IS IMPORTED BY CáC
OF THE- IMPOSING A FINANCIAL
INSURANCE STANDARD THAT CAN NOT
BE MET. MAY RESULT IN SHORT
TERM FUEL SUPPLY IN FACT. AND
POSSIBLY A LONGER TERM SHIFT TO
CRUDE OIL IMPORTS BY TRUCK AND
RAIL. WE ARE GETTING CONSIDER
THE POSSIBLE IMPACTS. BECAUSE
AGAIN FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE
THERE ARE TWO TAX- THAT
TOGETHER SHOULD BE A CONCERN.
ONE THE UNAVAILABILITY OF THE
LEVEL OF FINANCIAL CURRENT ON
THE GLOBAL MARKET. THANK
FACTORED 70% OF THE CRUISE.
HOLDEN BY TANK OF THIS. OUR
SECOND CONCERN IS WITH THE
PENALTIES AND FINES AMENDMENTS
THAT WILL DOUBLE IN LISTING
PENALTIES. AND PROVIDE THE
COURT IS. TO ADD ADDITIONAL BUT
THE CAN DOWN DOLLARS A GALLON
SPILLED. OUT WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THE AUTHOR'S INTENT THAT CAN BE
INCREASED HEALTHY LEVEL TO
SERVE AS A DETERRENT. COMPUTERS
BILLS. BUT THE PENALTY THAT'S
PROPOSED WOULD FAR EXCEED THE
PRESIDENT OF MY LAW OR- SIX. IN
FACT SO CONSENSUALLY BECAUSE
THEY MAY AND FACT SERVE IN THE
NOT JUST A FUTURE SPILLED BUT
ALSO MAY SERVE AS A DETERRENT
TO IMPORT AND TRANSPORTATION.
I'M NOT. SURPRISED SO YOU KNOW
WE UNDERSTAND UNDERSTAND AND
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE
AUTHORS IN INTENT HERE BUT- THE
US. BECAUSE THE LANGUAGE CAN BE.
THE INCREASE LOS. A HAVE AN
ADVERSE IMPACT ON YOUR FOR THE
STATE GO FOR THOSE REASONS WE
ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL AND WE
DO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR US OUR
OPPOSITION TODAY. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS FEEL PALES BUT BUT IN
THE CALIFORNIA. INDEPENDENT
pCOMMENTS ARE RELATIVE TO THE
SPELL FOR PROVISIONS FOR ON
SHORE SPELLS. BECAUSE OUT WE DO
NOT WE DO NOT TRANSPORT FUEL
ACROSS WATERS OF THE STATE BUT
WE DO HAVE. PRODUCTION CLOSE TO
IN LAND WATER SOURCES AND DO
GET PULLED UP THIS BILL. AND I
WOULD JUST LIKE THE COMMITTEE
TO CONSIDER THAT NOT WELL
WELCOME THE SAME. MY OUR SMALL.
CURRENT PENALTIES IN LAW FAR
MORE THAN ENOUGH TO CENTER. WHY
SHOULD SAY MORE GRANT UP TO BE
AS CAREFUL AS POSSIBLE.
ADDITIONALLY ALL OF THE OTHER
COSTS THAT ARE RELATED TO A
SPELL NOT JUST THE REPUTATIONAL
LOSS FOR A LOT OF THESE ALL
PRODUCERS THAT LIVE IN THE- BUT
THE COMMERCIAL. A LOT OF COMING
BACK. WITH THE LAW DAMAGES THAT
MIGHT BE- TO THIRD PARTIES AND
RESTITUTION TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
OR OTHER JURISDICTIONS ARE ALL
HUGE INCENTIVES TO ENSURE THAT
YOU'RE NOT INVOLVED IN THIS
BILL. BOB I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
POINT OUT RELATIVE TO THE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN'S PRESENTATION
OUGHT NOT NECESSARILY RELATED
TO OUR OPPOSITION HERE IS THOSE
TWENTY THREE OR SO TANKERS ARE
FLOATING AWFUL LOS ANGELES
BECAUSE- REALLY. REALLY BURNING.
THAT ARE MEMBER SOMEONE TO SO
YOU KNOW NOT ONLY IS THE MAN
DOWN MADAM CHAIR CHECK THE
SUPPLY ALL SUPPLY TAKES A FULL
AND WE HAVE LITERALLY A
FLOTILLA FLOATING OFF THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA COAST WHICH
IS OUT OF THE MARKET WHICH WE
SHALL INTO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WE HAVE ANYBODY IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM WISHING YOU
CAN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING NONE COME PLEASE OPEN
THE PHONE LINE FOR OPPOSITION.
IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO. AND OUR FIRST
ONE COMES FROM MINE TO FIFTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MANY MEMBERS AND SHARE THE MAN
I MET MY NAME BALTIMORE
MARYLAND HELP ME TO
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN COURT AT
THE DEL QUALITY I'M ALSO GOING
TO REGISTER THE COURT FOR A
POINT OF THE PROGRESS.
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA AUTUMN
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
WORKING GROUP. CALLED
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA COULD.
PROTECTION NETWORK. RIGHT.
THREE ALLOCATE THREE FIFTY BAY
AREA NOT PARK CONSERVATION AT
THE AFTER POLLUTION CHOLISH
CENTER FOR SHE AND AWARENESS
SEARCH ENGINE THE FIVE DIRE IN
YOU AND THEN I BY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. AND THE NEXT ONE
COMES FROM NINE TWO FIFTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIRTEEN A
GALLAGHER ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY OF SANTA BARBARA IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY TWO
FOURTEEN. IF YOU WOULD STILL
LIKE TO OPPOSE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND THAT
COMES FROM NINE TO FIFTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I GALLAGHER ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF SANTA
BARBARA IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
FOURTEEN. OKAY AND WE HAVE NO
ONE ELSE IN THE KEY RIGHT NOW
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU WE'LL
TAKE IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SIR I'M SORRY I DO SEE A.
NO NO WE DON'T HAVE A MOTION.
WE WERE MOTION OR SEX ROLL CALL
US. SHE A- AB THIRTY TWO
FOURTEEN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AND REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN
HI FLORA FLORA NO CHAO. EGGMAN
RIGHT EGGMAN AYE GARCIA GARCIA
BY THE MON HI MON I MATHIS
MATHIS NO MCCARTY. MCCARTY
ALRIGHT BRO THROW NO YEAR TUCCI.
STONE STONE HI. SIX TO THREE
SIXTY THREE WE WILL LEAVE THE
BILL- THE REAL OPEN ACROSS THE
NUMBERS I'M GOING TO PASS THE
GAVEL TO MY VICE CHAIR MISTER
FLORA AND COME DOWN 2% MY BILLS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR READY
WHEN YOU ARE. THEY WILL BE
PRESENTING AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY THREE IS THAT CORRECT.
WE'LL START WITH AB TWENTY
TWENTY THREE THANK YOU MISTER
VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO FACE AN
UNPRECEDENTED HOUSING CRISIS IN
THE STATE TO CONSTRUCT NEW
HOUSING UNITS. OVER THE YEARS
THE STATE IS CREATED MANY TYPES
OF SECRET EXEMPTION FOR HOW
PROJECTS. YOU DIFFERENT
CONDITIONS AND REQUIREMENTS
THESE INCONSISTENCIES OF CREATE
YOUR TO THE STRAW OF NEW BEEN
SAYS A LOT OF TIMES. THERE CAN.
USED ABOUT THE DIFFERENT LAYERS
OF EXEMPTIONS AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY THREE WILL MAKE EXIST
HOUSING EXAMS MORE CONSISTENT
OBJECTIVE AND ALIGN WITH THE
STATE'S CLIMATE AND HOUSING
GOALS THIS BILL WILL ENSURE
THAT WELL PLAN HOUSING PROJECT
NEAR TRANSIT. I'M NOT BE
UNNECESSARY. IT MEETS THE IN
SUPPORT BY TELEPHONE I BELIEVE
IS MY JOIN AUTHOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DAVID CHIU. AFTER YOU
CAN HEAR ME YEAH WE DON'T HEAR
YOU. GREAT I RECALLING SIDE
IT'S DAVID CHIU I'M HONORED TO
BE WORKING WITH THE CHAIR ON
THIS BILL- THIS IS A TOP I WAS
PLAYING AROUND A BILL ON AND I
WAS DELIGHTED TO DISCOVER- THAT
ARE NATURAL RESOURCES CHAIR WAS
ALSO INTERESTED AND THAT'S WE
WANT TO PARTNER ON THIS BILL
BECAUSE WE KNOW IT'S ALL CLEAN
IS. SOLUTION AND OUR HOUSING
COURT. IT WE ARE HAVE MANY
SECRETS ON THAT HOW IN THE
PLACE BUT WE NEED TO HELP MAKE
THEM WORK BETTER AND THAT THIS
BILL IS IMPORTANT STARTING
POINT FOR THAT CONVERSATION ASK
YOUR SUPPORT TODAY SO THAT WE
CAN KEEP TALKING WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS I WISH THAT I
WOULD REALLY. IS THAT RIGHT
WORK ON THIS. COME OUT OF THIS
PANDEMIC IN GIVE ECONOMIC
PERIOD WE CAN HAVE A BRIGHTER
FUTURE BOTH FOR HOUSING AND FOR
A BIRD THAT THANKS. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AS A MEMBER CHIU
ANYONE ELSE ON THE PHONE IN
SUPPORT. YOU WISH TO SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE INFO WE HAVE
OUR WE HAVE OUR TWO WITNESSES-
OF FIRST YES YES. SORT OF AN
OFFICE AMERICAN TO JESUS.
BECAUSE MERITAGE WITH THE
OFFICE OF MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
OTTOMAN MEMBERS IN HEARING YES.
AMERICAN DICTIONARY JOINING YOU
ON BEHALF OF. OUR CITY TO
EXPRESS WORKFORCE IN THE BILL
TO BE TWENTY THREE AND
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE MY COMMENTS WITH YOU
TODAY CURRENTLY MANY INFILL
DEVELOPMENT SITE ARE
DISQUALIFIED OR DETERRED FROM
USING CERTAIN SEAQUEST
STREAMLINING TOOLS IT CONFUSING
AND GARDEN LANGUAGE INTAKE
CODE. AB TWENTY THREE ARE YOU
WITH BY THE APPLICATION OF THE
SEQUEL PROVISIONS. THERE WILL
BE SHOULD BUILD HI BUT IF I.
WILL MEDIATION AND ELLEN TO
CLICK COPY IN ALLEN THAT THE
BILL WOULD CLARIFY QUALITY FOR
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF EXEMPTION
UNDER SPEAKER FOR TRANSIT
PRIORITY PROJECT WITH CANNIBAL
COMMUNITY STRATEGY SHOULD THE
CRITICAL MEANS LOCAL JR THE
BUILDING TO ENCOURAGE MORE
PAINFUL PATTERNS. INCLUDING A
JOB FOR HOUSING AFTER.
SIGNIFICANTLY CHANGED THIS BILL
ENSURE THAT CAPRI AND COMMUTER
PLAN AT EIGHT WILLOW PAUL
PROJECT YOU PMR AT ALL NOW THAT
ARE CONDUCTED BY THE NUMBER WE
DON'T THAT. I AM THE PARCEL
PART. FOR FUTURE DEVELOPMENT
AND THEIR GARCETTI HAD WAITED
HIGH PRIORITY ON AT THE ALL
THEIR FIVE O'CLOCK AND THE
COMMUNITY PLAN. AS PART OF
PROBLEM THAT THE CITY IS
WORKING TO ALIGN THE LAND USE
POLICY NOT PLAN THE STATE AND
LOCAL THAT THE PARK. THREE AND
WE DO. YEAH MISSION. VIDEO NONE
OF THE DAY ANNUALLY ON THESE
EFFORTS AND COMPLETE THAT
ENVIRONMENTAL UNDER SPEAKER
ELIMINATE OF TWO IN A REVIEW IT
LEVEL HELP HOW DEVELOP IN
ENABLE LIKE LAS ANGELES DELIVER
CRITICAL HOUSING YOU NEED IT
SHOULD THE STATE QUITE. FOR
THESE REASONS GARCETTI SUPPORT.
AB TWENTY TWENTY THREE WE THANK
YOU FOR CONSIDER BACK. THANK
YOU NICHOLAS ANYONE ELSE ON THE
PHONE FROM THE ASSOCIATION OF
OUR MIDDLE PROFESSIONALS. I'M
HERE IN THE- THE ROOM MY NAME
IS MATT CLUB AND STAYED HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION AND
RUN A PROFESSIONALS. PERFECT
THANK HOPE EVERYBODY CAN YOU
HEAR ME ALRIGHT. COOL SO- HERE
WITH CALIFORNIA VISORS ON
BEHALF OF EIGHTY P. EIGHTY PSI
ORGANIZATION REPRESENTING ABOUT
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED SECRET
PRACTITIONERS IN THE STATE
EVERYTHING FROM THE LAWYERS AND
PLANNERS BIOLOGISTS CETERA- ARE
MADE IN IS REALLY EDUCATION AND
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE TO OUR
MEMBERS AND ENSURING THAT THE
INDUSTRY CAN APPROPRIATELY AND
EFFECTIVELY IMPLEMENT THE
STATUTES AND GOALS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE PUTS FOR. WE DON'T
OFTEN- WAIT IN ON LEGISLATION
TO TAKE POSITIONS ON THE POLICY
SIDE BUT THIS IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT- BY OUR COUNT THERE
THE DOZEN STREAMLINING MEASURES
THAT CURRENTLY ARE AVAILABLE
FOR LEAD AGENCIES WHO ARE
TRYING TO IMPLEMENT AND PUT
FORWARD INFILL HOUSING. AND
FORTUNATELY OFF AS MANY OF
THOSE- EXEMPTIONS AND
STREAMLINING MEASURES USE VERY
DIFFERENT CRITERIA USE VERY
DIFFERENT DEFINITIONS AND IT'S
OFTEN VERY DIFFICULT AND WHAT-
PROPOSAL- WILL PROPOSE PROJECT
COULD APPLY WHAT STREAMLINED
MEASURE. THIS BILL AND WE GIVE
ENORMOUS THE AUTHORS AND THE
STAFF OF BOTH COMMITTEES- IS A
GREAT EFFORT TO SEE HOW WE CAN
MAKE MORE CONSISTENT MAKE MORE
YOUR FRIENDLY. PLEASE TELL.
ALSO OF. I THINK CLIMATE CHANGE
ANY WHILE ALSO SIMULTANEOUSLY
ADDRESSING THE STATE'S HOUSING
CRISIS SO LOW THAT WE STRONG
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MAN ANYONE
IN THE BUILDING- IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY THREE.
YEAH RIGHT OR- MARKS I RESERVE
THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
PARTNERSHIP WE ARE A STATE
CHARTER NONPROFIT- IS ARE YOU
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL OR NOT
WE HAVE A COMMENT THAT THAT'S
OKAY. IS CONTINUE TO HELP. YEAH
WE ARE DOING WE ARE HOPING WE
BELIEVE CALIFORNIA'S MAKE BOLD
STROKES TO INCREASE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AND THAT THIS BILL SO
FAR HAS SOMEWHAT MARGINAL
CHANGES WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE
STAFF OVER THE NEXT COUPLE
WEEKS TO. VERY CLEAR EXACT IN
FOR SUPPORT OF HOUSING AND
EMERGENCY SHELTERS. AND TO-
IMPROVE UPON THE EXISTING
CATEGORICAL INFILL EXEMPTION
WITH RESPECT TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
COMMENTS OR- ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION BY PHONE. WE HAVEN'T
HAD BY PHONE BUT WE HAVEN'T HAD
THE SUPPORT BY PHONE AT ARMS
OR- ANYBODY IN SUPPORT BY PHONE.
THE FIRST ONE COMES FROM NINE
ONE FORTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
LINE ONE FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. NO
RESPONSE FOR THE SCENE GOING TO
THE NEXT LINE TWO FIFTY EIGHT
YOUR MIND IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON AGAIN
SHERRIN MEMBERS MOLECULAR ABOUT
THE CALIFORNIA LEAVE
CONSERVATION BETTER IMPORTED
EIGHTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY
THREE. I WILL GO TO THE
NECKLINE AND THAT IS SIXTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE SIXTY SIX
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI OF. HIS QUEUE UP
AGAIN NINE SIXTY SIX PRESS ONE
THAT FOLLOWED BY ZERO WILL GO
TO THE NEXT LINE AND THAT'S
LINE ONE EIGHTY FIVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS STILL BE A
FERRARI ON BEHALF CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. YOU KNOW
WHAT THE NEXT LINE SIXTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
LOUIS MANTE ARE A CALLING ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA U. M. B.
AND THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
URBAN PLANNING AND RESEARCH
GROUP OTHERWISE KNOWN AS BURKE
A BOAT INTO PORT THANK YOU. AND
ABOUT THE NECKLINE AND THAT'S-
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI KIM STONE
OF STONE ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF
ASSOCIATED BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. AND
WE'LL GO TO THE NEXT LINE AND
THAT IS TWO SIXTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE BAY AREA HELPING
ADVOCACY COALITION IN SUPPORT.
AND WE'LL GO TO THE NEXT LINE
OF ONE ZERO EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. RIGHT AT THE BAR AND
ABLE AND GET REPRESENTING THE
AMERICAN PLANNING ASSOCIATION
AND SUPPORT. AND WILL BE THE
LINE OF TWO THIRTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI MARINO BY AT THE
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM-
WE DO NOT HAVE A POSITION ON
THE BELL AND I WOULD ECHO THE
REMARKS FROM MY COLLEAGUES JUST
DIVERT BUT THE CALIFORNIA HOW
THE PARTNERSHIP. AND WE'LL GO
TO THE LINE TO SIXTY. YES GO
AHEAD. SIXTY THREE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD HI THIS IS
THE MODEL COULD NOT ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNCIL AND YOUR SUPPORT.
AND THE LAST LINE COMES FROM
LINE TWO ZERO FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LIKE TO THE RIGHT AT OUR-
HI THIS IS THE HIGHER THE
SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP GROUP
AND WILL PROBABLY SUPPORT AB
TWENTY THREE TWENTY THREE FOR
ALL THE- COMMENTED THE QUEUE AT
THIS TIME PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU THANK YOU VERY ANYONE HAD
IN OPPOSITION BY PHONE. YOU
WOULD LIKE TO OPPOSE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
HEY WE HAVE ONE AND THAT COMES
FROM MIND ONE FORTY TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI GOOD AFTERNOON-
VICE CHAIR MEMBERS THE NATURAL
TRUST THE COMMITTEE THAT THE
TIME UTILITARIAN ON BEHALF OF
THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
ACCOUNT. I'M ABOUT COULD TURN
HAVE WITH YOU TO TREAT TWO
THREE FOR THE DAY I'D LIKE TO
ASSEMBLY TREATMENT INTO
RECOGNIZE AND ARE CONCERNED AND
OFFERING TO WORK WITH THAT. GET
OUT THREE NINE. WE HAVE A BELT.
FIRST THE BILL WOULD PROVIDE
HOUSING AT THE EXPENSE TO HELP
SAFETY OF WORKERS CONSTRUCTION
PROJECT AND CONTAMINATED SITE
AND WORKING FAMILIES RIGHT I
THINK IT IS VERY HELPING
DEVELOP. SECOND IN. THE BILL
WOULD ALLOW IT THE PRESUMPTION
BASED ON OFTEN DECADES OLD AND
UNCLEAR RECORDS REGARDING
WHETHER IT'S BY AND KLAY EACH
TO RESIDENTIAL STANDARD.
TYPICALLY THAT DOCUMENT THAT.
THE AT THE EXPENSE OF THE
CONTAMINATION IT DOESN'T
EXPLAIN. INDEFINITE WHY IT'S
BEEN TOOK PARTICULAR STAND YOU
KNOW CALL OUT RIGHT VERSUS
COMMERCIAL OR INDUSTRIAL. THE
DOCUMENTATION IS ALSO NOT
READILY AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC
AND REQUIRES A SIGNIFICANT
PERCENTAGE. WHAT THE LAST TRAIN
HONDA BY THE FACT THAT THE
QUAKE PENSIONS DO NOT INVOLVE
RIGOROUS DOCUMENTATION AND ARE
NOT CIRCULATED FOR PUBLIC
REVIEW AND COMMENT AS YOU FELT
THE PUBLIC DEPRIVED THE ABILITY
TO TIMELY OBTAIN THE- FIND PLAN
AT THE- OLYMPIC THE TIME TO
APPEAL. OR CHALLENGE AND
ALREADY APPROVED EXEMPTION
WITHOUT THE NEXT NECESSARY
DOCUMENTATION. WE CAN HELP THE
RESULT IN UNNECESSARY
LITIGATION IN ORDER TO PRESERVE
PUBLIC RIGHT THE CLASS. FIND
BUT BUILT IN GAPS AB I AM A LOT
ABOUT WITH YOU THERE WOULD BE A
CLOSE OF THE OR ATTACK PRIOR.
THERE WOULD BE NO ANALYSIS AND
BREAK RISK TO WORKERS AND
PUBLIC FROM NEARBY- EXPOSURE
THERE WOULD BE AN ANALYSIS
IMPACT THE SURROUNDING
ENVIRONMENT FROM MOBILIZATION
OF. CAPTION THE IMPACT FROM
TRANCE HOW SUBSTANCES YOUR
COMMUNITIES AND NO ANALYSIS OF
CONTAMINATED PAPER INTRUSION
INTO BUILDINGS THE ONLY SPEAKER
REQUIRES THAT BALLOT THAT
IMPORTANTLY IT POTENTIAL RISKS
BACKGROUND IT IDENTIFIED
REQUIRES IDENTIFICATION OF
MEDICATION TO REDUCE THE THREAT.
FOR THE REASONS THAT WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE TWO THREE
TWO THREE AND WE URGE OTHER AT
VOTE NO WERE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
DOCTORS TO ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS
FOR THE BILL TURN THIS
COMMITTEE YEAH. THANK YOU. THE
YOU VERY MUCH ANYWAY BUT-
ANYONE ELSE OPPOSITION BY PHONE.
WE DO HAVE ONE MORE AND THAT
COMES FROM LINE TO FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS THIS IS
SCOTT WHAT SHALL BE AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PATRIOTS
COUNCIL. THE STATE ASSOCIATION
OF ELECTRICAL WORKERS THE WEST
UC'S COUNCIL OF SHEET METAL
WORKERS THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION OF UTILITY EMPLOYEES.
AND THE ELEVATOR CONSTRUCTORS
UNION I'D LIKE TO SO SHE- MIGHT
ONCE WITH THE COMMENTS JUST
MADE A MOMENT AGO BY THE CAL
CUP WHICH THE BUILDING TRADES.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT.
SEEK THAT THIS BILL IS PREMISED
ON THE IDEA TO SEEK WITH
SOMEHOW HAS BEEN A PRINCIPAL
IMPEDIMENT TO THE CONSTRUCTION
HOUSING INSTEAD OF CALIFORNIA.
AND IN REALITY THERE'S OTHER
FACTORS ARE FAR WAY FAR GREATER
ON- IN THE ABILITY TO GET
HOUSING BILLS LIKE AVAILABILITY
OF FINANCING IN LATE
SPECULATION THINGS OF THAT ONE
ONLY NEEDS TO LOOK AT. THE
THOUSANDS IF NOT THE THOUSANDS
OF BILL PERMITS FOR HOUSING IN
CALIFORNIA THAT HAVE BEEN
ISSUED. BUT YET NOT ACTED UPON.
YOUR PROJECT SHOULD HAVE
CLEARED SEEK WHAT THE CLEAR THE
LOCAL REGULATORY REVIEW PROCESS
THE BEING GIVEN A PERMIT. BUT
YET THEY HAVEN'T DESTRUCTION
FOR THOSE REASONS WE WERE WE
WORK WITH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION ON BY
PHONE. WE DO HAVE ONE MORE THAT
JUST TO THAT SO WE'LL GIVE THEM
JUST A MOM. SEVENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MANY CHAO
PICTURE AND I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CENTER ON RACE
POVERTY ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA
BERMAN ON JUSTICE I AND
COMMUNITY FOR A BETTER
ENVIRONMENT THE FISHING TRIP
BOB DYLAN THE- AND CAL. AND WE
HOPEFOR JUSTICE THE BILL WE DO
NOT HAVE A SUPPORTER OPPOSED
POSITION AT THIS MOMENT WHETHER
GROUP. WORK WITH LOW INCOME OF
COLOR LIVING IN THIS PORTION
COLLUDED AND- YOU CAN BOB BILL
HELLO HEARING WHAT BUILDING OF
FRESNO UNITS ON OF TOXIC SIDE.
WITHOUT AN ARM IF YOU. SHE
CC PROVIDE WILL LIKELY BRING
FOR ME FOR OF THE HARMS TO THE
WHOLE YOUR FAMILY'S WHO WILL BE
LIVING IN THE A DECADE AND WE
APPRECIATE THAT OPPORTUNITY
AFTER. THESE KIND WITH THE K.
WE HAVE CAN THESE. THE VERY
MUCH FOR YOUR COMMENTS ANYONE
IN OPPOSITION BY PHONE. YOU
HAVE WHAT ARE THAT YEAH AND
THAT FROM LINE TO SIXTY NINE
HE'S GOING. NOT FOR A MEMBER
THE PAULA I'M AWAY CALLING OUR
STORE WITH THROUGH SIXTY ON
BEHALF OF UPPER PROTECT HELD
FOR WE'RE AT IN. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MUCH ANYONE ELSE NOT
THE BY FOR. KERRY NOW NO ONE
ELSE IT. THE YOU VERY MUCH YOU
WANT TO SHOULD IN. WE'RE GONNA.
MICHAEL REPRESENTING THE PAIN
AND ALL I TRADES OPPOSITE. YOU
SO MUCH SIR. ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION THE BUILDING. SCENE
NINE ANY FROM THE- THIS MATHIS.
YOU SHARE. WE LIKE THIS AND I
WATER. AUTHORS TRYING TO DO
HERE AND I'D TO DO IS A ALL TO
SHOW BY PART WITH THIS MOVIE
FORWARD IF YOU TO HAVE A- THANK
YOU COMMENTS THANK. FOR THE
SUPPORT. THE VERY MUCH IN ANY
MEMBERS. CNN MATTER WHICH LIKE
THOSE. AIDS AND WE ALSO DO NOT
WANT TO BUILD ON TOXIC SITES
WITHOUT PROPER REMEDIATION AND
I'M CONFIDENT THAT THROUGH OUR
CONVERSATIONS WE CAN FIND A WAY
TO GIVE THE ASSURANCE THAT
EVERYBODY WANTS THAT'S GOING TO
EXPOSE COMMUTE IS TO TOXIC
MATERIALS AND WE'LL COMMIT OKAY
TILL WE HAVE NOT SECTION OF THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE IN. WE'LL
SEE. ALL RIGHT NOW WE CONCERNS
FROM THE BUILDING TRADES- ABOUT
THE TOXIC THE SITE PORTION WE
WERE IN CONVERSATIONS WITH I'M-
SURPRISED TO HAVE THAT INTO A-
A LONGER LIST OF OPPONENTS BUT
AGAIN WE ARE. SAME ALSO ON THE
SAME PAGE ABOUT PICTURE PLEASE
DON'T HAVE TO. CONTAMINATION
ISSUES AND- FOR THAT THAT
HAPPENS THE- UP WE REACHES
UNDERSTAFFED. BUT I WOULD. AND
I SO WE CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
WORK THANK YOU. THE MANAGER
PURPOSES SECRETARY PLEASE THE
ROLL IN THE SECOND. THE FIRST
TECH. MR MATHIS OUT OF MADE
MOST SIR THE- THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT PLEASE CALL ROLL AB
TWENTY THREE TWENTY THEM IS
PASS AND REFER TO A PRO BINS
COMMITTEE FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN.
FLORA LARA I CHAO. EGGMAN RIGHT
EGGMAN HI GARCIA. GARCIA NOT
VOTING LEMOND LIMóN ALL RIGHT
MATHIS MATHIS ALL RIGHT MCCARTY
MCCARTY ALRIGHT BRO. BRO NOT
VOTING YEAR TUCCI. AT SUSHI NOT
VOTING STONE. STONE NOW. SIX TO
ONE. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT UP IS AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY ONE. THANK YOU MISTER
VICE TURN MEMBERS. WE ALL
UNDERSTAND ABOUT THE IMPACT
THAT ARE COMING BECAUSE OF-
CLIMATE CHANGE WE'RE ALREADY
SEEING THE RESULTS OF
CATASTROPHIC WILD DROUGHTS AND
FLOODS. THERE BY SEE LOW PRICE.
TINA BUT STATUS ANY AS FAR AS
ABOUT THE PREPARING FOR CRISIS
IS THAT WE KNOW ARE COMING AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY ONE CREE
TO SIGN FIVE THREE TEAMS DIVIDE
SPACE RECOMMENDATIONS DECISION
MAKERS AS THEY AN IMPLEMENT
CLIMATE. AND HOW MITIGATE
IMPROV. AS WE SAW FROM THE
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE RESILIENCY%
BOND- IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT
WE HAVE METRICS TO PRIORITIZE-
AND AS LEE IN TIMES OF ECONOMIC
STRESS. WHAT EXCELLENT GIVE US
IS PAYING FOR IT WOULD PROJECTS
ONE COMES TO CLIMB BILLION SKI.
AT THE MOST AND ONCE. AND
THAT'S WHY. AB ONE TRIES TO DO.
TO TAKE THE PAUL OUT OF THE-
DECISIONS AND INSTEAD OF. SPACE
THE EVIDENCE. TO YOUR SHIP.
SOME OF THE ANSWERS ABOUT WERE
IN THIS GO. ME TO THE TEST IN
SUPPORT IS. FOR WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVE IN EVERY WERE AND I
VOTE. NUMBER OF THE COMMITTEE.
MANY IS THE FOURTH PART AND I
AM OF THE TRACTOR COFFEE FOR
THE MAJOR KERR. SUPPORT AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY ONE.
CALIFORNIA FOR THE MOST PART I
MEAN FOR BOTH THE NORTH AMERICA
WHILE FIRED STREAM HE QUOTED
YOU LEVEL RIGHT WITH THE
CLIMATE CHANGE RELATED IMPACT
CALIFORNIA GROWING LARGER. IN
THE IN MORE. BE CLIMATE CHANGE
AND REDUCE THE GROWING PART OF
THE PUBLIC SAFETY HEALTH AND
THE ENVIRONMENT THE MUCH
RESPONSE TIME EIGHT ACTION THAT
REFLECT THE MARKET. PROBLEM. AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY ONE AT THE
PORT THAT THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
THE CREATION OF AND BY FIVE AND
YOUR TEAM WELL HOW DETERMINE
HOW TO PRAY. THEIR RESPONSE
IMPACT. IF I. CAN ENSURE PRO
ARE DRESSED I'M- REGIONALLY.
BETTER IN A HAVE TO MITIGATE
PLANNING THE- AND MAKE BACK. ON
NATURE CLAN ADAPTATION PROJECT.
SIGN HELP US BETTER PREPARE THE
FUTURE. GIVEN CONSEQUENCES OF
THAT. IN THE IMPACT CLIMATE.
HOW WANT TO KNOW THAT WE ARE
MAKING. AND UNDER WHAT. THE
MARKET. IF I IN THE BUDGET
CREATED TWENTY. ONE HELP I
ALREADY AND MEASURE PROGRESS.
WE ONLY NUMBER FOR LEADERSHIP
ON THE WHICH. IF YOU LIKE TO
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
OUR FIRST ONE COMES FROM LINE
TO TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THINKING OUT ON BEHALF OF A
NUMBER OF ORGANIZATIONS AND
SUPPORT INCLUDING AUDUBON
CALIFORNIA THE CALIFORNIA
NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY CALIFORNIA
NINE IN AGRICULTURE NETWORK
CALIFORNIA DROUGHT. THE NORMAL
LAND. CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS SURFRIDER
FOUNDATION SIERRA CLUB UNION OF
MISTER AND FIND IT DEFENDERS OF
WHAT WILDLIFE AND THE KIND OF
CENTER THANK YOU. BUT WHAT A
CUTE ABSOLUTE WILL GIVE THEM
JUST A MOMENT. AND OUR NEXT ONE
COMES FROM A LINE TO SEVENTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
SEVENTY ONE IF YOU WANT TO ASK
A QUESTION. PRESS ONE THEN
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. YOUR LINE IS
NOW OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MORGAN MADE ON BEHALF OF SAVE
THE REDWOODS LEAGUE AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT BY PHONE. WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN THE QUEUE
RIGHT NOW PLEASE PROCEED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION. OPPOSITION BY PHONE.
IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
THERE'S NO ONE IN THE QUEUE AT
THIS TIME PLEASE PROCEED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ANY QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. SEEING
NONE. MADAM CHAIR WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE. RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE TODAY. WE
NEED A SECULAR MOTION IN THE
SECOND WEEK DO WE HAVE THAT
ALREADY IN MOTION. OKAY. OKAY
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY ONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
FRIEDMAN HI. FRIEDMAN HI FLORA.
FLORA NO CHAU EGGMAN EGGMAN
HIGH GARCIA GARCIA HI LOW MOAN
MON HI MATHIS. MATHIS NO
MCCARTY RT HI BRO ROW NO YOUR
TWO G. R. TO GI STONE. STONE
ARE. SEVEN TO THREE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR WE WILL
CONTINUE WITH AB THIRTY SEVENTY
FOUR THANK YOU MISTER VICE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS WE ALL KNOW
ABOUT THE EFFECTS OF
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES IN
CALIFORNIA- THIS BILL IS A
PARED DOWN VERSION OF THE BILL
THAT MANY OF YOU VOTED FOR THIS
COMMITTEE LAST YEAR DEALING
WITH THE CREATING A NEW MEMBER
RESISTANCE OWN AND CALIFORNIA.
DEFENSIBLE REQUIREMENT TO ZONE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE STRATEGY ZONE
ONE IS. WITHIN THIRTY FEET OF
THE HOME AND ZONE TO EXCESS
OUTWARDS FROM THIRTY TO A
HUNDRED FEET. AND THESE ARE
VERY IMPORTANT ZONES BUT WHAT
WE LEARN FROM THE MORE RECENT
WILD FIRES. IS THAT ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT ZONES WHICH
SHOULD BE TREATED DIFFERENTLY
FROM THOSE UP TO BONE ZONES.
ZERO TO FIVE FEET FROM THE HOME
ITSELF AND TING PLANT MATERIAL
THAT MIGHT BE THROWN ON THE
OUTSIDE OF THE HOME. THIS
CREATES A NEWS ON A NEW AMBER
RESISTANCE ON FOR THAT AREA. TO
GIVE MORE GUIDANCE TO
HOMEOWNERS AND PROPERTY OWNERS
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS ON
AND OFF. CREATE LANDSCAPING AND
BRAND. ACROSS CALIFORNIA. IT'S
IMPORTANT BECAUSE WHAT WORKS
TEN FOOT FIFTY FROM HOME IS
VERY DIFFERENT FROM WHAT WILL
PROTECT HOME. ZERO FIVE FEET.
US SO WE NUMBER WHY WOULD NOT
ENTERTAIN ANY QUESTIONS THAT
YOU HAVE THIS BILL HAS THE
SUPPORT OF THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY THIS YEAR CLUB
RESEARCH CONSERVATION DISTRICTS
FIRE SAFE COUNCILS FIRE CHIEFS
THE BUILDING INDUSTRY THE
INSURANCE INDUSTRY AN STD. EAT
I'D ON THE PHONE TO TESTIFY
TODAY IS LOSE FORMS BURKE WITH
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY AND
BOUGHT HER FROM THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION.
AND WITH THAT I WOULD REQUEST A
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WHO
GO TO LIZ BY PHONE FIRST. SHARE
A NUMBER OUR CRITIC AND I THINK
WE SUPPORT AB THIRTY SEVENTY
FOUR CALIFORNIA'S MAKE A FIRE
TREND CONTINUES TO WORK THEM
AND IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE MAKE
ALL COMMUNITIES THE FIRE CLAN
REACH. THANK YOU CAN BE THE
MEMBER OF THE FIRE COMMUNITIES
LEARNING NETWORK A NATIONAL
GROUP WORKING TO BUILD A SINGLE
WILDFIRE RESILIENT CAPACITY IN
FIRE PRO COMMUNITY. COALITION
HELP PEOPLE ON WILDLAND URBAN
INTERFACE ADAPTOR LIVING LIKE
WILDFIRE AND REDUCE THEIR RISK
FOR DAMAGE. FOR COMMUNITIES
THAT ARE PUBLISHING HIGH FIRE
WITH. WE MUST MAKE THEM MORE
RESILIENT TO FIRE STICK THE
STANDARD THE FEDERAL STATE
PROGRAM EVACUATION PLANNING.
AND PREVENTION OF HUMAN BECAUSE
TECHNICIAN. AB THIRTY SEVENTY
FOUR MAKE THE POINT CHANGES TO
APPROVED BY BOTH THE CAPITAL.
FIRST OR BOB WEIR HOME MISSION
BY DIRECT ADDING THE HOME
NINETY. ON HERE HOUSE. THE BILL
ESTABLISHES WITH YOUR BY NON.
DOWN SUCH A I'D RECOMMEND IT BY
FIRE QUESTION. ON DON'T
ADDRESSES THE MISSING PIECE AT
THE BUFFET PROTECTION. AND
CALLED FOR THE CURRENT CODE IS
NOT ADDRESS YOUR HOME EDUCATION
AB THIRTY SEVENTY FOUR WOULD
FIX. OFTEN WE THINK OF A
NUMBER. OF THEIR SHIPS AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU LIZ I WILL
GO TO BOB FROM THE CAPITAL.
THANK YOU MEMBERS ON BOB ROEMER
WITH THE CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION SPEAKING
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY
SEVENTY FOUR. I'M ALSO
REPRESENTING AN INDUSTRY
COALITION SUPPORTING THE
MEASURE THAT INCLUDES THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION THE CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION
THE CAL SO SEASON OF REALTORS
AND THE BUILDING OWNERS AND
MANAGERS ASSOCIATION. ONGOING
MAINTENANCE A DEFENSIBLE SPACE
AROUND THE HOME IS VITAL FOR
PROTECTING HOMES A COMMUNITIES
FROM WILDFIRE. HOMES COMPLYING
WITH THE NEWEST BUILDING
STANDARDS AND IGNITION
RESISTANT ONLY IF THE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE REQUIREMENTS
ARE MAINTAINED. BUT WHEN YOU DO
HAVE THE COMBINATION OF THE
FIRE ARDEN HOME AND DEFENSIBLE
SPACE THE RESULTS ARE
INCREDIBLE IN THE RECENT
PARADISE FIRE STORMS HOMES OF
MET THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL THE
BUILDINGS THERE'S AN AD. SPACE
HOW TO. THE RATE OF THREE.
COMPARED WITH ONLY 11% THAT DID
NOT. ESTABLISHING A FIVE FOOT
AMBER RESISTANCE OWN WILL
FURTHER REDUCE AMBER IGNITIONS
PROTECTING HOMES AND LIVES. AND
WHILE CALIFORNIA IS NOT
CURRENTLY EDUCATE RESIDENTS.
LIVING IN OUR HOUSE WE JONES
ABOUT THE FIVE FOOT ZONE AB
THIRTY SEVENTY FOUR- WILL HAVE
BOARD UPDATE THEIR DEFENSIBLE
SPACE GUIDANCE DOCUMENT TO
INCLUDE INFORMATION. ON HOW TO
CREATE MAINTAIN THAT CRITICAL
FIVE FOOT SO ONCE AGAIN THE END
THREE COALITION STRONGLY SIX
YOUR SUPPORT OF SPECIAL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU BOB ANYONE UP TO
SUPPORT BY PHONE. IF YOU TO
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. IN THE FIRST
ONE COMES FROM MIND TO SIXTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THE GOING THAT
MANDATES GOVERNMENT AFFAIRS
MANAGER BIRTH AND DIEGO GAS AND
ELECTRIC IN SUPPORT. AND THE
NEXT ONE COMES FROM LINE TO
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SHE GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
STACEY HIDDEN FROM THE WORLD
COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. AND THE
NEXT ONE COMES FROM NINE THIRTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IF YOU LEAVE
NOW AND OUT THE BALL ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION AND THE FIRE
DISTRICT ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. AND THE
NEXT ONE COMES FROM MIND FIFTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. A DANIEL BROAD
REGISTERING SUPPORT ON BEHALF
OF SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA THE
CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY. PACIFIC FORCE TRACK
TRY AND DEFEND WHILE BY THANK
YOU. AND THE NEXT ONE COMES
FROM MINE TWO EIGHTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS ERIN HAVE AND ON BEHALF FROM
THE TREE CARE INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT OF
THE IMPORTANT BELL THANK YOU.
AND I LAST WEEK I'M FROM MINE
TO SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO ALICIA PRIEGO ON BEHALF
OF PERIMETER SOLUTION IN
SUPPORT. AND THAT WAS THE LAST
ONE PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION BY PHONE.
IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
NO ONE IN OPPOSITION AT THIS
TIME PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANY QUESTIONS FROM
pCHAIR WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
ALL THE SAID THAT I HAD ONE
FIREFIGHTER TELL ME THAT IT'S
HARD ENOUGH TO. PROTECT
SOMEONE'S HOUSE FROM FIRE
COMING TOWARDS THEM BUT IF THEY
HAVE TO PROTECT FROM THE BACK
AND THE FRONT IT'S ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE SO WITH THAT I WOULD
URGE AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND ALL MOVED. TO THE
SECOND. THANK YOU. PETER WAS
CENTER PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AB
THIRTY SEVENTY FOUR. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN HI FLORA I
FLORA ALL RIGHT CHAU. EGGMAN
RIGHT EGGMAN ARE AYE GARCIA
GARCIA ALL RIGHT LOW MOAN. MOAN
ALL RIGHT MATHIS. MCCARTY
MCCARTY AHRI BRO. BRO NOT
VOTING MERE TUCCI RIGHT SAID
SHE AYE STONE STONE HI. EIGHT
TWO ZERO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM CHAIR TO GO TO YOUR LAST
BILL AB THIRTY TWO SEVENTY NINE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR VICE
CHAIR IN THAT OKAY. Q. ALL A
BACK TO CALIFORNIA'S ON
PRESIDENT HOUSING CRISIS IT'S A
VERY IMPORTANT THAT WELL PLAN
PROJECTS COULD MOVE QUICKLY
THROUGH THE APPROVAL PROCESS AB
THIRTY TWO SEVENTY NINE
ADDRESSES COMMON DELAYS IN
LITIGATION OVERSEE QUIRK TO
PROMOTE WIFTER AND MORE
EFFICIENT RESOLUTIONS OF
LAWSUITS REGARDING ALL PROJECTS
THE BILL CREATES A MEANINGFUL
CHANGE THE SEQUEL PROCESS BUT
STILL MAINTAINS THE ROBUST
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS.
WOULD BE TODAY TO FIND
SUPPORTER WRIGGLE FROM
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND LUIS MARATHI FROM
CALIFORNIA DMV AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANYWAY SUPPORT BY PHONE. IF YOU
WISH TO SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO SIR WE DID
DO THAT ARE DESIGNED SPENT STE
WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES- BEFORE
THAT JUST TO REMIND YOU BEFORE
THAT. LOUISE START WE HAVE A
TWO WITNESSES TO SPEAK YEAH.
YES THE LIST CAN. ADAM FROM CAL
CHAMBER YOU ON THE PHONE.
THEY'RE BOTH BY. ADAM FROM CAL
CHAMBER YOU ON THE PHONE. WE'LL
COME BACK TO ADAM LOUISE FROM
U. M. B. ARE YOU ON THE PHONE.
LOUISE FROM U. M. B. ARE YOU ON
THE PHONE. GRABBING AN ISSUE
WITH THE QUEUE OKAY FROM. HI MY
TAX- SUGGESTING WELL THEN WE
WILL BE PATIENT HAVING A LITTLE
BIT OF AN ISSUE WITH THE QUEUE
SO NO PROBLEM WE WILL BE
PATIENT FOR A FEW MOMENTS HERE
I DON'T THINK SO. HE WAS. ON ON
OUR BILL. YEAH SO IF EITHER OF
THOSE WITNESSES ARE ON THE
PHONE PLEASE PRESS STAR ZERO
FOR AN OPERATOR CAN ASSIST YOU.
OKAY WE DO HAVE A FEW PEOPLE
THAT JUST- PRESS STAR ZERO SO
WE'LL GIVE THEM JUST A MOMENT.
MATT A MODERATE WE HAVE A FEW
PEOPLE IN THE QUEUE. WE DO AND
WE DO HAVE- OPERATORS ASSISTING
THEM RIGHT NOW OKAY WE PATIENT
A PROBABILITY OF THEM WITH
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THAT
HOURS. THAT'S OKAY. MADAME
MODERATOR CAN WE GO TO OTHER
SUPPORT CALLS AND THEN COME
BACK TO THE WITNESSES. OKAY AND
CAN YOU GIVE ME THAT THE LINE
ARE EXCUSE ME THAT THE TWO
NAMES OF THE WITNESSES. WITHOUT
A REAL FROM CAL CHAMBER. AND
LOUISE. RANTING FROM UMB. OKAY
I GUESS NEITHER ONE OF THOSE
THERE ARE- THE WITNESSES THAT
CUED UP TO LOOK AHEAD AND GO TO
THE LINE TO SUPPORT IF THAT'S
OKAY WITH YOU THAT IS FINE WAS
JUST KEEP IF THEY IF THEY CALL
IN WAS GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY. CERTAINLY THANK YOU
OKAY AND SO OUR FIRST SUPPORT
LINE IS FROM LINE TWO ZERO FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS JUSTIN
HIERARCHICAL COME BY LEADERSHIP
GROUP IN WEREN'T STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTY TWO SEVENTY NINE
THANK YOU SO MUCH. IN OUR NEXT
ONE COMES FROM LINE ONE EIGHTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. IF GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS STILL BE FOR
OUR BEHALF CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND WE DO HAVE A
LUIS. ON THE LINE FOR LINE
SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
DELUDE CAN HEAR ME WE HAVE THE
LOUIS YES. HI HI GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CARE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
TAKING MY TESTIMONY MY NAME IS
LOUIS BRONTE I'M THE
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR
CALIFORNIA BE. I TELL YOU MY
COMMENTS BRIEF- BUT I'M HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT
HAVE A MY COLLEAGUE ADAM AGO
WILL COVER THE TECHNICAL
ASPECTS OF THE BILL AND I'M
GONNA FRIENDLY OVERALL HOW DO
COUNTY CALIFORNIA THAT MAKES US
FEEL THIS BILL MAKES.
SIGNIFICANT POSITIVE CHANGE.
CALIFORNIA FACES THAT YOU
PROBABLY KNOW A HISTORIC THREE
POINT FIVE MILLION HOME
SHORTAGE ONE RENDERED IN
PAINFUL CLARITY BY CO THE
NINETEEN. AT PEOPLE STRUGGLE TO
MAKE RENT SHELTER IN PLACE OR
DEAL WITH THE UNIQUE
INTERSECTION OF PUBLIC HEALTH
NEEDS HOME WITH. CALIFORNIA IS
UNIQUELY DIFFICULT TO BUILD
HOUSING IN AND PROCESS REFORM
THAT GET DEVELOPMENT CERTAINTY
ARE NEEDED TO ADDRESS OUR
HOUSING SHORTAGE. THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AT THE
MADE A 21% REDUCTION IN THE
HOUSING PERMITS FOR THIS YEAR
FROM PREVIOUS PRODUCTIONS- DOES
PROJECTIONS- I HAD SUGGESTED
THAT PRE CODE PRODUCTION FOR
THAT YEAR WITH ONLY GOING TO BE
ABOUT HALF. OF THE ANNUAL NEED
TO PREVENT PRICES FROM RISING
BEYOND INFLATION. AND WITH LESS
THAN ONE FIFTH OF THE NEED IF
WE WERE TO ACTUALLY RESOLVE OUR-
SHORTAGE BY TWENTY. THE
NINETEEN ALMOST CERTAINLY
CREATE CONSIDERABLE DEVELOPMENT
UNCERTAINTY FOR THE REMAINDER
OF THE YEAR NOT LONGER. I WHICH
COULD CAUSE A CATASTROPHIC
DECREASE IN HOME BUILDING A
COMMENSURATE INCREASE IN THE
COST OF HOUSING. ADJUSTED
COMPELLING IS THE NEED TO PUT
CALIFORNIA'S BACK TO WORK AND
RAISE REVENUE FOR LOCAL AND
STATE GOVERNMENTS. A RECENT
STUDY FINDS THAT BUILDING A
THOUSAND HOMES CREATE TWO
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED FULL TIME
JOBS. AND GENERATE ALMOST A
HUNDRED ELEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
IN TAXES AND FEES. FOR ALL
LEVELS OF GOVERNMENT TO SUPPORT
POLICE FIREFIGHTERS AND
SCHOOLS. CALIFORNIA NEEDS OF
HOUSING WITH ECONOMIC ACTIVITY
IS JOBS AND THAT'S REVENUE. OF
IT HE HAD MADE THE NEED FOR
HOUSING REFORM ALL THE MORE
CLEAR. FOR THAT REASON WE
SUPPORT BILLS AB THIRTY TO
SEVENTY NINE. THAT MAKE
HOMEBUILDING EITHER AND THE
THIRD IS. A COMMITTEE. THANK
YOU FOR MUCH. IS OUT OF THE
LINE. WE DO HAVE ANOTHER FROM
LINE TO NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
APOLOGIES VICE CHAIR AND MADAM
CHAIR I HELPED ALLEN THE
TELECONFERENCE- TORY- THIS IS
ADAM REGULARLY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AT DEFINE. IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. AB THREE TWO SEVEN NINE
PROPOSES INCREMENTAL CHANGES TO
THE PEOPLE PROCESS. IT WILL
ALLOW MORE HOUSING COULD BE
BUILT WITH LEFT DELAYS AND
LOWER COSTS. THE BILL STRIKE
IMPORTANT BALANCE OF DRAFTING
THE COMMODORES DISTILLATE FROM
PEOPLE EDUCATION. WITHOUT
COMPROMISING THE STATUTE'S
OBJECTIVE TO PROTECT
CALIFORNIA'S NATURAL
ENVIRONMENT. FOR EXAMPLE THE
BILL WOULD BE AT THE TIME FRAME
COURT OF APPEALS NEED TO HEAR A
SEQUEL CASE TO TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY DAYS. OF THE DATE OF
FILING THE APPEAL CHALLENGING A
PROJECT. I EXPEDITE THE TIME
FRAME COURT OF APPEALS MUCH
YOUR CHALLENGE. THE BILL ENSURE
THE MORE TIMELY RESOLUTION OF
PEOPLE LITIGATION AND THAT MORE
HOUSING PROJECT ANOTHER LAND
HE'S PROJECT TO MOVE FORWARD.
TO BE CRYSTAL CLEAR THIS BILL
DOES NOT CHANGE ANY THE
OBLIGATION BILLY AGENCY- HAVE
UNDER SEQUEL- TO IDENTIFY ALL
POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT IMPACT.
AND TO ADOPT ALL FEASIBLE
MITIGATION MEASURES THAT WOULD
ELIMINATE. OR SUBSTANTIALLY
REDUCE ANY OF THOSE SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT. WITH AN EXISTING
HOUSING CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA
FURTHER EXACERBATED BY THE CO
THE NINETEEN PANDEMIC. WE
BELIEVE THESE MODEST CHANGES
PROPOSED BY EIGHTY THREE TWO
SEVEN NINE WILL EXPEDITE MUCH
NEEDED HOUSING PROJECT IN
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT COMPLETING
THE PROTECTIONS THAT PEOPLE
PROVIDE. WE ASK HERE FIVE A
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I THINK WE ALL UNDERSTAND
TELECOM PURGATORY RIGHT NOW SO
WE APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE-
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT. WE DO
AND THAT COMES FROM NINE TO
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON- PREFER LIKE
YOU DON'T ON BEHALF OF LOS
ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI IN
SUPPORT OF AB AT THIRTY TWO
SEVENTY NINE THANK YOU. AND OUR
NEXT ONE COMES FROM A LINE ONE
FORTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE
ONE FORTY TWO YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NO RESPONSE
REALLY SEEN OUR NEXT ONE COMES
FROM LINE TO SIXTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MINE TOO SIXTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN TO GO AHEAD.
NO RESPONSE WOULD BE SEEN AT
OUR LAST ONE COMES FROM LINE
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD ACTORS DEFAULT FROM
BLIGHTED BY THERE'S A GAP THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PORTER FORTIES ALSO FOR THIS
MEASURE. THANKS WE DO HAVE A
FEW MORE THAT CUED UP IT LOOKS
LIKE ONE FORTY TWO HAVE CUED UP
AGAIN PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE ONE
FORTY TWO IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NO RESPONSE FOR THE SCENE AND
NINE TO SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOU'D STILL LIKE TO MAKE
A COMMENT PLEASE GO AHEAD YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NO RESPONSE FOR
THE SCENE WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE
IN THE QUEUE PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION. ANY I'M SORRY.
MISTER CHRIS IN SUPPORT YES MR
VICE CHAIR AND MANAGE YOUR
MEMBERS CHRIS MY KAYLEE ON THE
HAMMER HUMBLED REDWOOD COMPANY
IN SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CHRIS I
APOLOGIZE ANYONE IN OPPOSITION
BY PHONE. IF YOU WISH TO OPPOSE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THAT FOLLOWED
BY ZERO. HE WOULD YOU HAVE ONE
THAT CUED UP AND THAT'S FROM
ONLINE. TWO SIXTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS VERY
HELPFUL- ACTUALLY YOUR SUPPORT
AND EIGHTY THREE TWO SEVEN NINE.
OKAY AND WE DO HAVE ANOTHER ONE
THAT CUED UP LINE ONE FORTY TWO
HAVE CUED UP AGAIN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IT'S TIME TO GO UP RIGHT
NOW WITH A BY DID A LINE
MEMBERS. BUT I AM HERE TO
SPEAK- AND POLITENESS NOT
PROFESSIONS. SHALL I PROCEED.
YES OF YOUR OPPOSITION AB
THIRTY TWO SEVEN NINE YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
GOOD AFTERNOON VICE CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
TANYA COLLECTOR IN HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
OF CALIFORNIA. I WILL BE
SPEAKING ABOUT THREE MAJOR
CONCERNS WE HAVE WITH EIGHTY
THREE TWO SEVEN NINE. FIRST THE
BILL WOULD CREATE UNREASONABLY
SHORT WHEN THEY CATION TIMELINE
EVEN THOUGH LESS THAN 1% OF
PROJECT APPROVED FACE ANY
CHALLENGE UNDER C. CLASS. RT
HAS SHORT DEADLINE THE
PROSECUTING A CASE. OKAY
ALREADY RECEIVED PREFERENTIAL
TREATMENT IN THE COURT. HE PUT
CASES INVOLVE EXTENSIVE
BRIEFING AFFECT TIGHT
AFFECTATIONS FOR THE RECORD-
AND THE JUDGES WANT TO HAVE-
COPY THAT EVERY SINGLE PAGE- AT
THE EVIDENCE THAT DANCE RELIED
ON THE MINISTRY OF RECORD
REDUCING THE SHORT TIME LINE
FOR PRESENTING THE CASE TO A
JUDGE WHAT I'M REGIONALLY
RESTRICTED PETITIONERS. RIGHT
COMPLETE JUDICIAL REVIEW.
SECOND THE BILL WOULD ELIMINATE
PETITIONERS RIGHT TO COMPARE
THE ADMINISTRATIVE RECORD BY
SHIFTING PREPARATION TO THE
AGENCY. THIS WOULD PREVENT
PETITIONERS FROM HAVING ACCESS
TO EVAN EARLY ON IN THE CASE.
THAT INCREASE TO COVER THE
RECORD AND HOMES INCREASED
LITIGATION COSTS I WOULD
PREVENT PETITIONERS FROM
CONTROLLING LITIGATION ****
WHICH IS A KEY COMPONENT OF THE
EXISTING LAW. THIRD AND FINALLY
THE BILL WOULD ALLOW TRAVELPORT
ISSUE AN INTERLOCUTORY REMAND
ORDER CONTEND THE PROJECT BACK
TO THE AGENCY WITHOUT ISSUING A
FINAL JUDGMENT. BECAUSE OF THE
ONE FINAL JUDGMENT WILL THE
CODE OF CIVIL PROCEDURE
PROHIBITING. AT THAT AT THAT
RULE IT PROHIBITS APPEALS FROM
INTERLOCUTORY ORDERS AB THREE
TWO SEVEN NINE WOULD PREVENT
PETITIONERS EVER OBTAINING A
FINAL JUDGMENT NECESSARY TO
FILE AN APPEAL. BUT ALSO
UNNECESSARY. ALREADY HAS A
PROVISION THAT REQUIRES RIGHT
GEN CLUED ONLY THOSE AFFECT
MANDATE TWITTER NECESSARY TO
ACHIEVE COMPLIANCE WITH THE
CLASS. EIGHTY THREE TWO SEVEN
NINE WOULD CREATE UNNECESSARY
BURDENS FOR LEAD AGAIN AND THE
COURT MAY RESTRICT TO PROFITS
RIGHT. EVEN THOUGH MULTIPLE
STUDIES HAVE FOUND NO EVIDENCE
BUT SEE QUITE AS A MAJOR
BARRIER TO DEVELOPMENT AND
VEHICLE EDUCATION IF EXTREMELY
RARE. WE URGE YOU TO VOTED NO
ON EIGHTY THREE TWO SEVEN NINE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION BY PHONE. WE DO HAVE
TO THAT CUED UP AND THE FIRST
ONE IS FROM LINE TO SIXTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
VICE CHAIR THIS IS GRAND ALSO
LOOK HERE COULD CALIFORNIA IN
RESPECT WHAT THE DISH AND
EIGHTY TWO THIRTY TWO SEVENTY
NINE. A WE BELIEVE THAT
COMPOSES ONEROUS ADMINISTRATIVE
AND JUDICIAL REQUIREMENTS FOR
PLAYING G. SOME PETITIONERS.
DURING THE SEEK ON COASTAL
PROCESS WHICH IS LOCATION- MY
COLLEAGUE WITH YOUR P. WILL
DISCUSS OTHER ASPECTS BUT ONE
ASPECT THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
JUST GO TO THE ROUND THE ANALOG
TO REMAND WHICH- NICHOLAS
HERRING JUST COME TO FUND. AND
THAT REMAINED PART PRO-
REQUIREMENT WOULD ESSENTIALLY
ALLOW FOR COMMUNITY MEMBERS TO
BRING A SUCCESSFUL SEQUEL CASE.
PREVENT THE COURT TO ORDER THE
KEY TO FIX THE PROBLEM AND
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW DOCKET
WHILE THE CASE IS STILL PENDING
AND THEN LOSE THAT CASE-
PUTTING. HMM SOME FINAL JOE.
WHICH SHOULD THEM TO A MAJOR
APPEAL BUT ALSO CREEK THEM FROM.
GETTING FEES. OBTAINING A THE
TRAIN PEOPLE ON WELL SO PLEASE
READ AND BE RESPECTED OF THE
THIRTY SEVEN NINE. AND IF THE
DELEGATES LOOK UP HELP TODAY WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR ON ON THOSE CONCERNS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BRANDON ANYONE ELSE OPPOSITION
BY PHONE. WE DO AND THE NEXT
ONE COMES FROM A LINE TWO
EIGHTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU THAT FINANCE CHAIR AND MANY
MEMBERS MY NAME IS HEALTHY TOO
I'M A SENIOR ATTORNEY WITH THE
CENTER ON RACE PROPERTY
ENVIRONMENT- AND- SPEAKING WITH
THEIR RESPECTFULLY AS CLOSE AB
THIRTY TWO SEVENTY NINE. AGAIN
ON BEHALF OF YOUR P. THE
CALIFORNIANS ARE NOT JUST THE
ALLIANCE NEEDED A THREAT THAT
OUR ENVIRONMENT THE VISUAL
PROPOSAL POSSIBILITIES LOOKING
ANGELES AND LEADERSHIP COUNCIL
FOR JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
ARE MORE QUIET AND REPRESENT
AND ARNOLD WITH THE COMMUNITY.
AFTER NEARLY LONG CONTINUED BUT
COLOR THROUGHOUT THE MOST
POLLUTED AREA. IN CALIFORNIA
AND RELY OFTEN ON THE
CALIFORNIA AND ARNOLD QUALITY
ACTIVE ENGAGING CONTENT I
PRETTY MUCH THE ONLY WAY- BUT
THE LAST WEEK OR BACKSTOPS TO
ENSURE THAT AGENCY AND THE
POPULAR COMPLY BUT- THE PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION WELCOME BACK NOW
IF THEY. ARE MANDATED BY THE
FALL. OUR CONCERN ABOUT THE
BOOK THE- NOW TOUCH ON AND THE
OTHER TWO. ISSUES BY FROM
CONCERNED WITH THAT I ME ORDER.
ISSUE PART THOUGH THANK YOU OF
THE PROPOSED. TO ALLOW
PETITIONER TOOK THE MYSTERY THE
FACT ONLY AFTER REQUEST OF ANY
EIGHTEEN CURRENT FISHING
KINSHIP. THEREAFTER OR AGENCY
TO DO SO ONLY LOW OFTEN.
HEATHER RECORD IN ORDER TO
INSURANCE THAT NOT ONLY IS IT
IS ACCURATE AND COMPLETE BUT
ALSO IN ORDER TO KEEP THE
RECORD CLEAN CHEN CRAFT DOWN.
IN THE DELTA CALLED BALDWIN
ACTUALLY GET THEM READ AGENCY
EXCLUSIVE AUTHORITY TO DO THAT.
ANYONE NOT ALLOW PETITIONER TO
BE ABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
RECORD IS ACCURATE AND
COMPLETE. EQUALLY IMPORTANTLY
ABOUT HI AND THEN YOU'D OFTEN
NOT FISHER BUT HAVE TO FOOT THE
BILL AGENCIES BACK ACROSS WHICH
COULD. MAKE TIME TO BE HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS. AND
TURNED CALDERON WOULD
ULTIMATELY UNFAIRLY INHIBIT THE
ABILITY OF THE PUBLIC
ESPECIALLY ARMONK JUSTICE
ADDITION ARE TO BRING A LAWSUIT
BECAUSE THEY CANNOT AFFORD TO
PAY AGENCIES FOR THEIR X.
ARCHITECT NETWORK PREPARATION
CALL WE APPRECIATE YOUR BECAUSE
WE JUST ASK I'M. START WRAPPING
UP WE APPRECIATE THAT. YEAH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WOULD
HAVE QUICKLY ON CONCERNS CHECK
PREVIOUSLY ON SHORTENING THE
GREASY. BREAKING HIGHLIGHTS
FROM NINETY EIGHT DAY BECAUSE
THE DESHAUN RD HELPED AYE QUIRK
THE- STATE TO GREEN UP
WONDERING THAT NINETY DAY
PERIOD WORKING IN J. OTHER
PUBLIC INTEREST PETITION- TO.
HEAR THAT AND EVEN SHORTER
PERIOD AS A REALISTIC AND BEAT
THE FALL- APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE OUR
OPPOSITION WE URGE MEMBERS TO
VOTE. NO ON THE BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. WE APPRECIATE YOUR
ANYONE ELSE ENOUGH BY PHONE. WE
DO HAVE ONE MORE THAT CUED UP
AND THAT'S FROM MINE TO SEVENTY
FIVE SAID JUST NAME AN
ORGANIZATION. YET MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THAT WHICH SHOULD BE
OUT FOR THE CALPERS THE
PATRIOTS COUNCIL STATE
ASSOCIATION. ELECTRICAL WORKERS
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THAT THE
BILL- BUT LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE OTHER THANK
YOU. ESTHER WAS ANYONE ELSE
OPPOSITION BY PHONE. NO MORE IN
OPPOSITION RIGHT NOW PLEASE
PROCEED THE ONE OPPOSITION IN
THE BUILDING YES SIR. KNOWLEDGE
VERY. APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION IN
THE BUILDING. SCENE NINE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE MR
SIR RESURGENT THANK YOU. SO
MADAM CHAIR I APPRECIATE TO
YOUR- EFFORTS TO STREAMLINE
SEAQUEST SPECIALLY TO HELP
ADDRESS THE HOUSING CRISIS-
BUT- AS IS A FORMER LITIGATOR
AYE- TO SHARE SOME OF THE
CONCERNS RAISED BY US BUT SEE
SOME OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE GROUPS ON YOU KNOW I
THINK- AND AS YOU MAY WELL
KNOW- THERE. YOU KNOW THERE
THERE IS THE LAW AND THEN
THERE'S THE REALITY IN WHICH
LAWYERS WORKIN AND I'M
CONCERNED THAT- THE COST SSUES
THAT WERE RAISED BY- THE CENTER
REYES POVERTY IN ENVIRONMENT AS
WELL AS SOME OTHER GROUPS.
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS THAT THAT
I THAT I SPOKE WITH- A CASE IN
POINT I RECEIVED A EMAIL FROM
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL I THINK IT'S- A FAIR
THAT I THAT THAT I SHARE THIS
BUT- ALTHOUGH THEY'RE NOT ON
RECORD IN OPPOSING THE BILL-
THEY'RE RAISING THE ISSUE OF
LAWSUIT GAMESMANSHIP WHERE- YOU
KNOW OFTEN. DEVELOPERS CAN-
CAN- SUPPRESSED ABILITY OF
COMMUNITY GROUPS THE FILE
SEQUEL LITIGATION BY- BY- YOU
KNOW. PREVENTING PETITIONERS
FROM THE OPPORTUNITIES TO CUT
DOWN ON THEIR EXPENSES TO FILE
THESE PUBLIC INTEREST- LAWSUITS
AND SO YOU KNOW WHILE I AYE TO
RECOGNIZE IT AND I DO- BELIEVE
THAT- THAT- IT THERE ARE.
ABUSES OF CIVIL LITIGATION THAT
THAT SOMEHOW NEED TO BE- CUT
DOWN ON- YOU KNOW MY CONCERN IS
THAT THIS BILL- MAY- PUT TO
ESPECIALLY THE SMALLER PUBLIC
INTEREST LITIGATE LITIGANTS AT
A DISADVANTAGE. THE REST WERE
SEARCHING ANYONE ELSE WISHING
TO SPEAK FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING THAT YOU HAVE ONE OVER
THE PHONE LINE FROM. I WILL GO
TO MISTER MATHIS FIRST. THANK
YOU- MADAM CHAIR I'D LIKE TO BE
ADDED AS A JOINT AUTHORED ON
THIS BILL AS WELL AND LOVE WHAT
YOU'RE DOING HERE AND IT'S-
ABOUT TIME WE START MOVING
FORWARD. WITH THESE THINGS
THANK. WE'LL GO BACK TO THE
PHONE LINES IF THEY JUST KEEP
THERE COMMENTS QUICK. NAME
ORGANIZATION SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION PLEASE. SURE
ABSOLUTELY IT LOOKS LIKE THERE
WITH THE OPERATOR RIGHT NOW BUT
THEY DID- DROPPED ONLINE SO
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE THE
CONCERNS THAT WERE EXPRESSED-
WE ARE HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THOSE WHO HAVE
CONCERNS ON THE BILL- MISTER
MATHIS WILL HAVE HAPPILY I DO-AS AN AUTHOR- I WILL SAY THAT.
IT'S NEVER BEEN HARD IT SEEMS
FOR VERY LARGE PROJECTS AND
PEOPLE WITH A LOT OF MONEY TO
GET A LOT OF SICK WITH
STREAMLINING. AND WHAT THIS
BILL IS ATTEMPTING TO DO IS TO
MAKE THE PROCESS EASIER. FOR
THOSE ORDINARY PROJECTS RUN OF
THE MILL HOUSING PROJECTS THAT
ARE JUST GOOD FOR THEIR
COMMUNITY. TO HELP THEM AS
WELL- SICK WAS MAY NOT BE USED
ALL OVER THE STATE ALL THE TIME
BUT I CAN TELL YOU IN MY
DISTRICT IN HOLLYWOOD. IT'S
FREQUENTLY USED OR EVEN AGAINST
VERY MODEST AND VERY. GOOD
PROJECTS- AND THIS BILL IS NOT
INTENDED TO STOP PEOPLE FROM
BEING ABLE TO USE IT WAS A TOOL
IT'S CERTAINLY NOT INTENDED TO.
STOP THE COMMUNITY FROM
UNDERSTANDING THE IMPACTS OF A
PROJECT. WHEN I WAS ON THE
BOARD OF THE- LA CONSERVANCY'S
A MODERN COMMITTEE. I WAS
INVOLVED IN SEVERAL SEQUEL
LAWSUITS ON HISTORIC
PRESERVATION GROUND SO I VERY
MUCH UNDERSTAND. SMALL SCRAPPY
GROUPS TO SCRAPE TOGETHER THE
MONEY TO FILE THE SEQUEL
LAWSUIT. I'M NOT ATTEMPTING TO
STOP THEM. I AM ATTEMPTING TO
BRING FINALITY- TO THE PROCESS
AND TO GET THESE ISSUES
RESOLVED AS QUICKLY AND
PAINLESSLY FOR EVERYONE AS
POSSIBLE. WHICH IS WHY WE DO IN
CRIME IN THIS TO TRY TO
ENCOURAGE RESOLUTIONS TO BE
BROUGHT AND- RATHER THAN
STOPPING PROJECTS COLD TO
ALLOW. THE IMPACT THE INPUT OF
THE COMMUNITY TO BE WEIGHED.
AND ACTED ON BY THE AGENCIES
AND BY THE DEVELOPERS SO WE
THINK THAT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT'S HELPFUL TO ALL PARTIES.
I WE DON'T THINK IT'S LETTER TO
ONE SIDE OR ANOTHER BUT WE DO
THINK THAT IT WILL HELP RESOLVE
ISSUES- MORE QUICKLY. WE WILL
COMMIT TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE OPPONENTS- AND THE
SUPPORTERS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DO SOMETHING THAT'S MEANINGFUL
TO MOVE THE NEEDLE- BUT ALSO
DID NOT. AWAY I NEEDED CONCERNS
WITH THAT WOULD RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AND I'VE- THE YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM CHAIR. SIX PEOPLE
CALL THE ROLL. OKAY ON AB
THIRTY TWO SEVENTY NINE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I FLORA.
FLORA HI CHAO CHAO HIGH EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA. SEE I LOVE
MON THE MOAN HI MATHIS MATHIS I
MCCARTY MCCARTY ALRIGHT BRO BRO
HI YOUR TO CHI NO RIGHT SU CHI
NOW STONE. STONE NOW. VOTERS
NINE TO TWO. THANKS VERY MUCH
OKAY WE JUST HAVE SOME CALLS TO
THE LEFT. WE GOT A- FIX THE
MOTION ON THE YEAH I MEAN TO.
FINISH THIS UP. ALL GIVE ME ONE
MOMENT. SO DO YOU TO. MANAGER
YES OKAY WE CAN WE CAN GO IN
ORDER AND TAKE THIRTY TO FIFTY
SIX IN ORDER- WE'LL JUST GO
THROUGH AND LEFT CALLS BUT- DO
I NEED TO MAKE THE ANNOUNCEMENT
THAT YOU SENT ME ABOUT THE
URGENCY OPTIONS WHEN WE WHEN WE
GET TO THAT MEASURE I THINK-
OKAY. SO LET'S GO THROUGH AND
pMEMBERS FIRST OKAY SO I'M I'M
GONNA CALL THE JUST THE BILL'S
WHERE THERE WAS A MEMBER
ABSENT- IN FILE ORDER THE FIRST
BILL IS. AB EIGHT- TWENTY NINE
NINETY ONE THE CURRENT VOTERS
SIX TO ONE IN THE ABSENT
MEMBERS MCCARTY. RT I. AT SEVEN
TO ONE. THE NEXT MEASURES AB
TWENTY NINE FIFTY FOUR THE
CURRENT LOTUS SIX TO THREE WITH
THE CHAIR I LOW MOAN. MON HI
SEVEN TO THREE. NEXT MEASURES-
THE CONSENT CALENDAR- THE
CURRENT LOTUS TENDER ZERO LOW
MOAN. THE LOAN ALL RIGHT I WENT
IN THIS ERA I'M SORRY BEFORE
PEOPLE LEAVE WE'RE GONNA BE RE
VOTING ON ONE OF THE BILLS
CORRECT SO PEOPLE SHOULDN'T
LEAVE YET. THAT'S THE- TAX THAT
I RECEIVED ABOUT- THIRTY TO
FIFTY SIX. TWENTY PEOPLE TO
STAY TO VOTE ON YASSER FOLKS
CAN BEAR WITH US FOR YEAH ONE
MINUTES YEAH YEAH. NEXT MEASURE
IS AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY NINE
THE CURRENT VOTED SIX TO TWO
WITH THE CHAIR I LOW MOAN.
TWENTY NINE FIFTY NINE. LIMóN
HI SEVEN TO TWO. AB THIRTY
THIRTY CURRENT LOTUS SEVEN TO
TWO WITH THE CHAIR I LOW MOAN
MOAN HI BRO. BRUNO IT'S EIGHT
TO THREE. AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY
THREE SALAS THE CURRENT LOTUS
SEVEN TO TWO WITH THE CHAIR I.
GARCIA LOW AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY
TWO SALAS. SORRY A. B. THIRTY
ONE SIXTY THREE SALAS. GARCIA
NOT VOTING LOW MOAN MON NOT
VOTING
OKAY NOW WE'RE ON A. B. THIRTY
TO FIFTY SIX AND. SO WE NEED
THE FOLLOWING ACTION THE DIRT
IT DUE TO THE URGENCY BECAUSE
NOT BEING APPROVED BY RULES
COMMITTEE AND- WE CAN'T ADD THE
URGENCY BECAUSE AT THIS TIME
BUT WE'RE GOING TO AMEND THE
BILL TO ADD THE REMAINING
POLICY LANGUAGE WITHOUT AN
EMERGENCY CLAUSE WE NEED TO DO
ACTION. NOW OR LATER. I'M
LOOKING VIEWS- WHAT WE NEED TO
DO IS. LIFT THE CALL ON THE
BILL. ASK FOR UNANIMOUS CONSENT
TO RESCIND THE ACTION TAKEN AND
MAKE A NEW MOTION ON THE BILL
AS AMENDED BUT WITHOUT THE
URGENCY CLAUSE I SEE AND THEN
VOTE ON THAT GOT IT NOW IF I
UNDERSTAND SO WITH THE FOR THE
CALL ISRAEL IF THE CALL AND
WE'RE GOING. TO WE'RE GONNA
AMENDED TO ADD THE REMAINING
POLICY LINDA THAT AN EMERGENCY
CLAUSE. FIRST WE'RE GOING TO
ASK FOR UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
RESCIND THE PRIOR ACTION. OKAY
THANK YOU OKAY. OKAY SO NOW. I
NEED A NEW MOTION OKAY SO WHO.
WITH THE MOTION AND A SECOND
SELECT OKAY IN OUR HAVING A
FRESH ROLL CALL ON THE ON THE
BILL SAME AMENDMENTS NO URGENCY
CLAUSE AB THIRTY TO FIFTY SIX
FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN HI FLORA
NOT LOADING FLORA NOT VOTING.
CHAO JOE HI EGGMAN. EGGMAN HI
GARCIA. GARCIA NOT VOTING
LEMOND HI LOAN II MATHIS MATHIS
NOT VOTING MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE
BRO. BRUNO MERIT CJ HIGH- TO GI
STONE. VOTERS SIX TO ONE SIX TO
ONE- WILL LEAVE THE ROAD OPEN
FOR ANOTHER FIVE MINUTES JUST
IN CASE SOMEBODY WANTS TO COME
BACK AND VOTE. ON THAT BILL
OKAY. OKAY WILL CONTINUE GOING
DOWN FOR THE ABSENT AB TWENTY
EIGHT HUNDRED QUIRK THE CURRENT
VOTE IS SIX TO THREE. THE CHAIR
VOTING I'D ABSENT MEMBERS ARE
MCCARTY. MCCARTY I MURATSUCHI I
READ CG I EIGHT TO THREE. AB
TWENTY SIX NINETEEN STONE
VOTERS FIVE TO THREE WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING HI SHIAU SHIAU
HIGH. WHERE TO CHU I RED SU CHI
I. SEVEN TO THREE. AB THIRTY
TWO FOURTEEN LEMOND CURRENT
LOTUS SIXTY THREE WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING HI CHAU CHOW HI TO
CHANGE MY RATES TO GI. EIGHT TO
THREE. AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY
THREE FRIEDMAN THE CURRENT
LOTUS SIX TO ONE WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING HI HOW. CHOW HI. GARCIA
GARCIA NOW NOT VOTING TO KNOW.
SEVEN TO TWO. AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY ONE FRIEDMAN CURRENT
VOTERS SEVEN TO THREE CHAIR
VOTING II CHOW CHOW HIGH. EIGHT
TO THREE. AB THIRTY SEVENTY
FOUR CURRENT VOTERS EIGHT TWO
ZERO CHAIR VOTING HI CHAO CHAO
ALL RIGHT NINE TWO ZERO. AND
SET UP WE WOULD HAVE OKAY WE
HAD TO REASONABLE TIME FOR YOU
TO VOTE ON AGAIN ON IT. OKAY SO.
I'M SORRY. DO YOU WANT ME TO
EXPLAIN IT AGAIN. IT HAS TO DO
WITH THE URGENCY BECAUSE WE
JUST HAD TO REMOVE IT BECAUSE
RULES TO THE ATTIC SO WILL BE
THE SAME SAME BILL WITHOUT THE
URGENCY CLAUSE. OKAY SO YOU'VE
ALREADY RESCINDED VOTE YES WE
RESCINDED AND THERE IS A NEW
MOTION MADE AND SO WE CAN LET'S
OPEN THE ROLE AGAIN FOR THAT
BILL OPEN THE ROLE AGAIN ON AB
THIRTY TO FIFTY SIX. THE LOTUS
SIX TO ONE WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING HI. STONE STONE ALL
RIGHT SEVEN TO ONE. AT THE.
OKAY A AB TWENTY. AB TWENTY
NINE NINETY ONE THE CURRENT
VOTE IS SEVEN TO ONE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GARCIA AND IS- RECORDED
NOT VOTING GARCIA NOT VOTING TO
KNOW. SEVEN TO TWO. OKAY WE CAN
ADJOURN WHERE TURN.